clock orientation has not yet begun it
is simply because I'm waiting for
members to show up because the
information I want to pass
along is information that the members
should be here
to absorb
so we're going to wait until we get a
little bit better attendance that means
our first public hearing will probably
be
delayed but uh such is life it's the
beginning of a new session year so it's
always a bit of a rocky start we'll get
can
representative Wendy Thomas is here so
start so good morning everybody and
welcome to
the initial meeting of the house science
technology and energy committee for 2020
4 as is our custom we will begin our
meeting this morning by all rising and
joining Representatives Thomas both of
pledge United States of
America stands nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for all
happy
birthday so our first order of business
to is to all issue a hearty happy
birthday wish to representative Wendy
birthday all right so what are we doing
today for the next few minutes we're
going to have a brief orientation just
to get everybody back up and running and
on the same page about what we're
doing and then starting uh in 10 or 15
minutes or so we're going to open a
public hearing on House Bill
1047 we'll also have public hearings
later today on House Bill 1230 House
Bill
1398 that will complete our our work for
today we'll be back here tomorrow where
we will hear two more
bills public hearings beginning at
9:00 after those public hearings are
completed we will have a work session on
the bills that we
heard today during today's public
hearings and then at 2 o'clock tomorrow
afternoon we will have an executive
session on the five bills that we will
so that is our plan for the next couple
of
days we have 20 bills assigned to our
committee this
year representative Doug Thomas and I
have worked out a tenative schedule that
sees us complete our work on all of
these bills in early
February five of the 20 bills are early
bills that must be done by the 15th of
February anyway but it is is our hope
that we can
get the majority of these bills done by
early February not just the early
bills why do we want to push them
through so
quickly the house Speaker has determined
that it is in the best interest of the
house for all of us to meet as often as
we can on
Thursdays this session year rather than
stacking up hundreds of bills to be
dealt with
in three Marathon house sessions in the
middle of
March the house Speaker would like to
have regular Thursday sessions either
all day sessions or possibly even
halfday sessions with afternoon sessions
on a Thursday afternoon that would leave
time for committee work on a Thursday
morning well the only way that's going
to happen is if those of us who serve on
policy committees crank out bills so
that they can be brought to the house
floor on a weekly
basis so we're going to do our part
we're going to try to get through our
bills and get them to the house floor
promptly so that the speaker can hold
these weekly house
sessions and we don't have to go through
this business of marathon sessions in
the middle of
March I don't know how many of you are
Ware of it but I've been here for this
is my 10th year in the legislature and
we've had a couple of marches where we
were in reps Hall until 3 or 4:00 in the
morning and that was not fun nor was it
policy yes we had to stop the clock
because midnight was a deadline and we
weren't done so we stopped the clock and
kept going until 4:00 in the
morning so we try we're trying to avoid
that kind of situation for this coming
year and as all of you are no doubt
aware by now we have something like 815
bills that have been submitted this year
so it's a heavy
workload we were lucky we only got 20 uh
but we have to do our part to help the
rest of the house get through this heavy
workload of 800 bills and so we will
crank ours out as quickly as we can uh
representative Harrington remember you
have to ask for permission to speak I
have a question yes go ahead uh are you
going to share the the schedule you and
Doug worked out so we'll know in advance
so we can plan well it's not completely
worked out um but yes we will share it
okay so that is our plan going forward
for
couple of other announcements that you
should be aware of in the office just
off to our left here there is a stack of
copies of the 10-year State energy
strategy you are welcome to take a copy
if you don't already have
one question representative
nter um when was that put together is it
new or is it 10 years from next eight
years ago
or I think it's the 2021
version yes 2021 version thank you
okay all right so 10-year energy
strategy copies are
there each of you has received a folder
that contains bills for the coming
year it is unfortunately not complete
there were three bills that uh Os or not
OS but U house administrative Services
has not had a chance to finish printing
yet so there are three
bills that are assigned to us that are
not yet copied and in your folder I
think it's
1697 and 1627 I believe are the three
that didn't make it but anyway this is
the only copy of the bills that you are
going to receive this year so I urge
each of you to take good care of these
copies consider potentially getting a
three- ring binder and putting all your
bills in the three- ring binder if you
haven't already done
so
uh and take good care of these copies of
the bills because these are the only
ones you're going to get of course you
can print your own copy but uh whenever
you want but
as far as house committee uh Services is
concerned this is the only copy you're
year
so next I want to remind everybody since
we're about to embark on public hearings
I want to remind everybody about the
hearings first of
all during a committee session if you
want to speak you have to be recognized
by the
chair several times last year we had
people just spontaneously speak and that
interrupts the flow of activity for the
committee and can be confusing to people
who are watching at home so please if
you want to speak raise your hand raise
it high so you can catch my attention
and I will recognize you to
speak but you have to to be you have to
wait until you recognized to speak to
avoid collisions and chaos and clutter
mind now public hearings are here for us
on the committee to understand the bills
being presented to
us it is our job therefore to ask
questions of the people who are
describing the
bill we're not here to debate the bill
amongst ourselves or with the people who
are explaining it to us we are simply
here to ask questions and gather
information now if you have a question
to ask you raise your hand I'll
recognize you and you can ask the
question I will permit one follow-up
if after everyone else on the committee
who wants to ask a question has asked a
question and you want to ask a second
question I will permit
it but in your first round of
questions and I Ur urge you all to
remember that we treat everybody here
equally we treat people with
respect we maintain house decorum at all
times and if we have any difficulty with
someone
who's presenting information or somebody
who's sitting in the
back watching the display of
information we
will call a
break to deal with an unruly situation
if it should develop and we might even
involve house security officials if it's
necessary hopefully that won't be
necessary we've been pretty lucky up to
this
point so is everybody clear now
on how we're going to conduct our public
hearings anybody have any
McGee thank you Mr chairman happy New
Year um the question that I have is
around amendments um last year we had
someone come to present a bill where
they brought along an amendment that had
been made since the Inception of the
bill and they were prohibited from
presenting that Amendment but I have
seen even members of this committee go
to Second committee and and bring an
amendment along with the bill and
present it at that time so I wanted to
ask how we are going to be um handling
amendments since they're kind of our
bread and butter that people often find
something wrong with the bill before
they bring it to the
committee excellent question so the way
you handle that situation is during
public testimony on the bill it is
proper to
discuss changes that you intend to make
to the bill via an amendment it is not
proper to submit the amendment the am
the amendment can only be submitted
during executive session but you can
discuss during testimony
the changes you plan to make and for to
give you a good example this afternoon
when I introduced House Bill
1398 I'm going to discuss a couple of
changes that I plan to make to the bill
before uh with an amendment before it
goes forward now we're executing that
bill tomorrow so my Amendment will be
ready tomorrow followup yes followup
followup would be related to that so
that will there also o be a work session
uh where we will be able to be familiar
with the amendment before we have to
vote on yes that's why I scheduled work
sessions before tomorrow's exec session
okay thanks good questions thank you
sure good clarification representative
Doug Thomas thank you thank you Mr chair
I sorry if I just got confused so the
work session appears before the
executive session so does that mean that
the uh Amendment will be discussed fully
uh before the executive
session or that or or what I know it
can't be formally introduced but will be
discussed
fully yes amendments can be discussed
during a work session if they are
questions okay seeing none let's begin
our business and I'm going to formally
open a public hearing on House Bill
1047 relative to establishing a
committee to study the effectiveness of
State Outreach to Residents without
computer
yeah oh so rep representative Wendy
Thomas will introduce the bill then
correct
okay so representative Wendy Thomas
you're on and don't forget to turn on
the
mic is this on or off this is
righty
okay all right so um I am representative
Wendy Thomas I'm not the prime sponsor
on this bill but I am a co-sponsor
representative Muse is the prime sponsor
this bill is asking to establish a
committee to study the impact and
effectiveness of communications
Outreach by the New Hampshire state
agencies on economic and Healthcare
initiatives for residents lacking
electronic devic
it is important well first of all it is
another study committee bill right why
on Earth would we need another study
committee um glad you asked got 10 re uh
no I have nine reasons why why we should
uh have this committee number one
inclusivity and E Equity a significant
portion of the population may not have
access to electronic devices or the
Internet by studying the impact of
communication Outreach on this
demographic the committee can help
ensure that information reaches all
residents of New Hampshire number two
access to Vital Information economic and
healthc Care initiatives often involve
crucial information that residents need
for their well-being if a portion of the
population lacks access to electronic
communication channels a committee can
identify gaps and propose alternative
methods to disseminate information
effectively three policy Improvement the
findings of the committee can inform the
development or modification of policies
related to communication strategies this
can lead to more inclusive and
comprehensive approaches that consider
the diverse needs and capabilities of
the
population number four resource
allocation understanding the effective
the effectiveness of current
communication strategies in optimizing
resource allocation the committee can
recommend adjustments to ensure that
resources are directed towards methods
that reach a broader audience even those
without electronic devices number five
public engagement and participation a
committee focused on this can enhance
public Enga engagement by creating
avenues for those without electronic
devices to participate in e in economic
and healthc Care initiatives this
ensures that their voices are heard and
considered in the decision-making
process six healthc care access giv the
importance of Health Care initiatives
ensuring that the information reaches
all residents is critical the committee
can identify areas where these
communication gaps may impact Health
Care access and propose solutions to
bridge these gaps seven economic impact
economic initiatives often require
public participation and understanding a
lack of access to information for
certain segments of the population can
hinder their ability to engage in in
economic opportunities the committee's
findings can guide strategies to
mitigate such
barriers eight and I was mistaken before
this is the last one public trust and
confidence effective communication
builds trust between citizens and
government agencies ensuring that
information is accessible to all
regardless of the technological
capabilities contributes to
fostering public trust and confidence in
government initiatives in summary the
committee serves as a proactive measure
to assess and enhance the impact of
communication strategies ensuring that
economic and Health Care initiatives
reach all residents regardless of their
access to electronic devices this
approach aligns with principles of
inclusivity Equitable access to
information and effective governance
thank
you thank you representative Wendy
Thomas questions from the committee
Kennedy uh thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for taking my question um I
was just wondering if there's any
evidence that these agencies are not
communicating I I don't think it's a
matter of an agency not doing their job
I don't think there's any compiled
report that's available anywhere that
information further questions
representative McGee thank you um it's
sort of along the same lines
um uh the question always would be well
my first question would be why a
Communications bill comes to this
committee but my second
question uh would be uh around
um that evidence question of whether
whether there's been difficulty reaching
people I know we all passed an emergency
bill when all the electric rates went up
and then we heard reports the following
spring uh that a very small portion had
actually been delivered to people and it
may actually be a result of this very
this very thing so we do have a specific
example to the representative's question
uh in our committee for a program that
we tried to Institute and it didn't
actually get to the people so
how uh how uh looking at the bill itself
what are the expectations in terms of
who is going to participate in this is
this just going to be a regular
committee that's got senators and Reps
or um you know H how do we propose to
solve the problem if we do this study
committee right so um based on the bill
it it uh the committee would be um
comprised of the standard um the members
of the Senate and the house that those
are onlines uh
S8 and nine in the bill and actually and
so because it includes the Senate and
the the uh the uh the house um there's
there's a certain obligation that that
people have to to come to this committee
and and provide information if it's
requested so I think it would be uh
people representatives and Senators who
have in interest in this topic and who
have some sort of uh competence in this
ask
followup I'm sorry I thought I had hit
the
button I'm loud to me so I had no idea
um so the question is around the uh
whether or not the expertise will live
on any type of subcommittee made up of
legislators to figure out who has
technology in their homes like I think
that would be hard to get at and I think
that's probably why our agencies have
had trouble reaching certain people and
and I think that that that's a fair
question or a fair objection um but
somebody's got to break through this Log
Jam you know the agent don't have this
information we need this information we
all know that we need the information
not only do people not have
technological devices but um I I even
know members of the of the house that
have to stand in a corner of their house
because that's the only place where they
can get to the internet you know so we
need to be able to identify these people
somehow and this is this is just taking
the bull by the horns and and seeing if
we can do it ourselves if we can start
the start start the process on the
conversation because it needs to be
done representative
muns thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you for taking my question and happy
birthday um I don't I don't disagree
with any of the um the reasons that you
cited for why we
should do a better job of making sure
that the word is getting out to people I
guess my my question is do we need a
study committee to do that or could we
in instead
ask uh one of the state agencies the and
the two that come to mind are the
department of Information Technology or
the department of admin administrative
services to deliver a report to the
legislature EX on these issues I I I
just wonder you know what added value a
study committee made up of three uh
representatives and you know maybe a
senator or two will add to the um
will will will Aid in you know
addressing the problems I I think that's
a valid um observation and I actually
think that if we could commit to a work
study group here in this committee
because the Bill's in the committee that
this representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair
uh
so prior to the
internet we communicated by
Mail
newspaper and then radio and
TV I am unaware of any other mechanism
that one could
use uh be outside the internet in order
to facilitate Communications uh and
those Vehicles would potentially
engender public meetings at different
times and places where people could show
up do you have any other ideas that uh
are going to facilitate broader
communication and are you asking the
this committee to develop those methods
or
or ask Departments of the of the state
to use those methods more often than
they
do yes
guess
what yes I I believe this bill is asking
agencies to pursue those those Avenues
um and yes I believe this this committee
would would try to figure out ways to to
get the information um it's you're right
we all communicate with the internet I
haven't even turned my TV on in months
because I stream everything on my
monitor on my and my computer at home
but a lot of people don't have access to
the technology and we're you know our
our our town newspapers are dying left
and right we have no way to sort of
reach these people there there are
Billboards there are things like that
but nothing is going to reach these
people like the internet so if they
don't have access to these these
electronic devices or the internet how
are we going to reach them and that's
that's the question that this committee
is charged
with representative Harrington has a
question thank you thank you for taking
my question um my question is what what
is not in the bill I've read through
this a few times and what I don't see
and what I'm assuming is a long-term
goal and I'm trying to uh see if you
agree with this um is that the goal here
is taxpayer subsidized access to the
internet is that the goal of this uh
ultimate goal of this
committee no
how would you can I follow up follow up
how would you envision that when they do
all this study uh how is anything going
to happen where's the money going to
come from well I think that that's part
of the the the responsibility of the
committee is to figure out if if there a
solution costs money where the money is
coming
from well I think we know where that's
coming from representative Doug Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair uh
thank you for taking my question um I
have no doubt that you're interested in
some of this
information and perhaps there are some
people out there they don't have the the
internet we we know but um I'm just
curious did have you heard from any of
the state agencies that would be
supplying these this information as to
their concern that their information
isn't getting out what what surveys or
what reports are out there that would
indicate that we have an issue with this
that needs to be worked done I'm just
curious uh um you know is it just was it
your assumption from some of your
constituents that that don't get this
information or or where is this
assumption coming from that people
aren't getting the information that they
need I'm just curious what what document
or survey out there might be telling us
that we need to act on something no I
think it's the opposite I don't think
there is a report out there that that
identifies this and that's that's the
need that this committee would would
address follow up followup so my
understanding my understanding is that
because there is no report out there of
any issue we need to look to see if
there's one I I don't no that's not what
I said um there because there's no
report that identifies the extent of
this of this
problem um because that does not exist
that's what this committee would would
rectify okay representative lii has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um I'm
wondering what the committee might do to
avoid selection bias as we often see we
get a squeaky wheel which is some small
but not representative group that may be
um essentially um the only thing that
from um the the the responsibilities of
this committee are outlined in lines 8
through um
26 and so it would not be influenced by
any lobbyist or any squeaky wheel as you
put it um this is empirical data it's
collecting numbers of of residents
households that don't have electronic
devices or that have an
issue do you have a followup followup um
and the question I'm still trying to ask
is how would we avoid having the people
thus identified be uh unrepresentative
state I'm sorry I'm not sure I
understand um what you're what you're
asking uh whatever we do is going to be
focused on some small number of people I
would think and the agencies might you
know e the selection selection bias is
the thing I'm concerned about is that U
we won't get a report that reflects the
whole of the state but only a minority
wheel um I selection bias um certainly
exists I just don't see it um existing
in this committee um I I appreciate your
concern for it um but this is this is
the entire um population this is not
just one one small group this is finding
Pockets yes of course you know so I I I
I'm struggling to
to appreciate the um concern that you
have I'm I'm just not sure I'm
understanding it correctly I have to
move on representative PL has a question
uh thank you uh thank you for taking my
question many of my concerns were
answered and I didn't hear this one has
any of the public or
residents came out do you have is there
out there a group or a number because
the US Census of 2022 show that we have
95% um return of New Hampshire residents
have computer access internet access and
they own a device and that's up 1.4%
since
I'm just wondering is there residents
out there that came to these agencies
that said they did not get information
thank you um first of all that the 95%
that you quoted is that access to a
computer or access to a home computer so
are they counting Library use or School
use for
that may uh thank you that that's
including computers and smart devices
cell phones okay and I'm I'm sorry what
was the rest of your question
the how did somebody come all right um I
wish the prime sponsor were here because
he could answer that um I
I am not the prime sponsor so nobody
came to me the prime sponsor came to me
I agreed that this was a a good idea
that needed looking
into so I can't answer that I don't
know representative Noel has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question and happy
birthday uh is there an implied measure
of what the impact and
Effectiveness that uh of of how those
would be measured impact and
Effectiveness would be measured as they
develop this I think that would be the
responsibility of the committee the
committee would develop
yes thank you you're
welcome okay representative McGee has a
question um Mr chair I was going to ask
if anyone else is speaking on this bill
because I I have a question really of
doe if there if somebody else is coming
yes there is one other person signed up
to
speak it is not doe well I have a
question of doe if I could I will gladly
vacate the chair well before you vacate
the chair I have a couple of questions
so I'll come back to uh representative
McGee's questions after that my first
question for you
is will the
or does the Federal Communications
Commission Lifeline program provide any
uh of the information that you
seek uh with this study
committee I don't know but that's
certainly something the committee could
look into and the information could be
gathered from
there okay my follow-up question is on
page two of the
bill lines one through three it talks
about the committee shall report its
findings and recommendations for
proposed
legislation but if you go back to page
one lines 18 through
26 there is no mention
anywhere in the committee's duties that
it will identify or
Define
legislation so I'm having difficulty
understanding just understanding just
exactly what the
report is supposed to do is supposed to
provide at the end of the
process uh that's an excellent
observation and as an extech writer I
would agree that those two pieces don't
match um I think it is implied for
committees um any study committee that
the uh end result is some sort of
recommendation whether it's
legislatively or or agent agency-wide
but um but you're right those those two
pieces
don't specifically match but I think it
it's implied of all committees that they
the end result is a recommendation of
some
sort okay thank you very much now we'll
let you off the
hook representative Kennedy has one last
question go ahead I have one last boring
question sure uh this is a a procedure
Al question and it probably just shows
my ignorance but the the members of the
uh committee from the house and the
Senate it just says appointed there's
nothing about party affiliation is that
work I am not aware of any committee
that's formed by by party I think it's
only by members I I could be wrong I
don't know Mr chair are you can you
answer that one well I do know that when
the speaker appoints people to study
committees he does try to balance
um between Republicans and Democrats to
the best of his ability I understand
that but it's not it's never written
into to law is it it is occasionally
really it is yes I'll look into that
thank you all right thank you
representative Wendy Thomas and now um
the department of energy is uh going to
come forward and answer a question from
representative
McGee
good morning uh committee uh Mr chair
and members of the committee uh for the
record Griffin Roberge uh State energy
program manager at the New Hampshire
Department of energy uh first time
testifying in 2024 so good to see each
of you uh willing to take any questions
on this bill but I just want to note
that um the department did not um intend
to testify on this bill uh I might not
have readily available answers but more
than willing to get back to you
later yes thank you Mr Rob I appreciate
your willingness to come up here and try
and help us my question gets to the
question I provide I gave earlier or the
information I provided earlier and it
goes to um the question of whether
there's a need for the bill because
oftentimes when we have study committees
that's the main thing that we grapple
with and so I wondered if you could
provide additional information about the
program that was implemented as a result
of our emergency funding because I had
read an article in the spring following
the passage of that bill to provide
emergency relief for people's High
electric bills uh that said that I think
under 5% of the money had actually gone
out the door so we we put a significant
amount of money into that and declared
Victory and said we've got money that's
going to go out to people it's going to
help but it didn't get to the people so
I I would like you to comment on whether
the agency is aware of any difficulty in
us maybe reaching intended audiences
because I think that's the essence of
this bill sure and uh thank you for the
question I don't think I could maybe
give a direct answer on that just
because respectfully I've been
completely focused on 2024 legislation
you're asking me to unearth something
from last year um but I do know that you
know there has been um some discussion
about some uptake in the HB 2023
emergency uh assistance program um you
know more than willing to follow back up
with with a lot more specifics on that
but I I I would just want to note that
um what what was the final version of
House Bill 2023 was not what um I would
submit the department was maybe
advocating for because I think we had
initially identified at in in the
initial discussions on that bill is that
allow giving everybody assistance on
their bill would be the easiest way
because you are the way the program came
out is that you are asking people who
traditionally do not take advantage of
assistance programs to now all of a
sudden become familiar with those
programs and to take advantage of it
whereas it would have been a lot easier
if there was just a a simple dollar
amount allocated to everybody's Bill to
bring down that that cost a little bit
um but I'm more than willing to dig into
a little bit more of the specifics
regarding the uptake and follow back up
via email if that's
okay okay thank you for that thank you
all right next step is um Mara Weston oh
excuse me representative Doug Thomas has
a question thank thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question uh
based on what your answer was to
representative McGee here just one quick
question does the department have a
mechanism to receive feedback on any of
its programs um or people calling in
requesting help uh or is it just someone
making a phone call sure and thank you
for the question uh as I think most
members of this committee are aware we
have a wonderful division director by
the name of uh Amanda Nunan who runs our
consumer service division at our
department um that division is staffed
with a number of folks who kind of
manage I guess you could say a call
center receive emails calls from uh
various constituents on a variety of
things disconnections having difficulty
with uh the Community Action Agency uh
trouble with their bill um so I would
say there is a dedicated uh Team of
Staff who are regularly involved in
providing constituent service to energy
consumers in the
state great thank you very much thank
you okay Mara
Weston representing the New England
connectivity and
Telecommunications Association Miss
Weston good morning members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Mora Weston I'm here representing the
New England connectivity and
Telecommunications Association a little
closer to the mic please thank you how
about that yeah better much better okay
great um I represent necta the New
England tele connectivity and
Telecommunications Association and in
New Hampshire our members include Bree
line Charter Communications and Comcast
and I'm really here this morning to
offer our association as a resource if
this uh Bill were to move forward in
general I don't often find myself
testifying in support of study
committees but this is one where we
think actually there could be good value
um to constituents um we'd like to be a
partner in any of the conversations
um and although we would never advocate
for taxpayer subsidized access to the
internet as I think representative
Harrington mentioned we always advocate
for awareness adoption and leveraging um
existing programs and one program for
example that our members have invested
heavily in is the affordable
connectivity program and that program
provides discounts to um
to customers who need uh assistance both
in in terms of um accessing the service
and also accessing equipment um and what
we know is that to date uh less than
38,000 New Hampshire households have
enrolled in this program and we think
that this is one example where um
entities such as those I represent and
the state could partner together to help
educate New Hampshire citizens about
these types of programs so that if they
don't have access or access to the
equipment they would know and understand
what what is available to them so we do
see benefit in this we support the
effort and would' be happy to partner if
forward okay questions from the
committee representative Doug
Thomas thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um very simple
question you um and I excuse me for not
remembering the program that you
referenced the less than 38,000 people
that uh uh had not or had only rolled I
guess in it um H how do you know that
and what percentage of the overall
population does it
represent so I have written testimony
for you and I'm looking at it and
there's a footnote here that says there
is an ACP enrollment and claims
tracker um that we referenced for that
that 38 37,000 plus number and in New
Hampshire um our members serve
approximately
485,000 customers now they're not all
going to be eligible for these types of
programs but we think that there is a
gap that there are people who may be
eligible for uh these types of
low-income programs who are not
currently accessing them and that's just
one example of one program um there are
many different programs that are offered
by different providers and we see that
there are many barriers to access and we
just would want to work to educate folks
and get the word
out
followup thank you for the followup
so just to be clear and I don't doubt
those figures whatsoever but just to be
clear how do you differentiate
between the Gap people in in in the Gap
as they're being in a gap because they
don't know about the program or they
don't care to apply for the program or
they just don't think it's worth it for
them to apply how how do you
differentiate between all of
that I'm not the
expert um so I I don't have those
answers for you today but I think if
this were to move forward my clients
would certainly want to educate you all
more about all the various programs that
they have who is accessing them and what
the criteria are for access to those
programs I know we partner with the
schools in some instances with
municipalities in some instances and so
in general we would want to encourage
you know any partnership to help get the
educate representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question Miss Wesson
thank you for being here um so you are a
telecommunications and connect ity
company and you also are unable to
necessarily identify all of the people
that you need to reach out to so um so
it it sounds to me as though you're
coming to us understanding that this is
an issue that would be helped by greater
Focus um since the state itself has had
trouble identifying certain populations
and it sounds like you do too right you
you have something to offer those
populations but you don't have an easy
way to reach them is that correct
correct so I represent the the
association and our members in New
Hampshire are the providers and yes I
mean we we as I said partner with school
districts municipalities any
organizations that we can we go out into
the communities to educate about various
programs that we offer and yes we do
perceive that there is a gap and so we
welcome any opportunity to continue that
educational process thank you you're
welcome
representative kman has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh you said that
uh you don't advocate for taxpayer
subsidies uh yet it sounds like you are
funding various programs I'm just
curious where this funding comes
from uh there are various Federal
programs that we Implement and um we
also have our own programs funded by our
members Internet Essentials and again
there's a variety programs but our
members look to provide service wherever
they can provide service and to whomever
they can provide service and we do have
many different programs to help achieve
adoption okay further questions
seeing
none thank you I want to thank you Miss
Weston for testifying and now I'll call
on representative muse from Portsmouth
to talk about the bill that he
introduced or is the prime sponsor
of Representative Muse welcome to
sdn thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
colleagues and my apologies uh for being
late we've had an an interesting morning
on the Sea Coast we typically don't get
a lot of snow and uh this storm we got
more snow than
anyone
um one of the reasons why I ran for
office um after 30 years of working and
Consulting is that I like to solve
problems and when I see problems one of
the things that I try to do is I try to
understand them a little bit better
because I think you need to understand a
problem before you jump in and try to uh
suggest
Solutions um I I think what this bill is
about is better understanding a problem
that's hurting our state's reputation
and also hurting a lot of lower inome
people in this
state
um many of the people who are eligible
for programs like low-income heating
assistance SNAP benefit uh SNAP benefits
uh as well as uh Medicaid Health Care
are low-income people who do not have
access to uh devices like computers uh
and smartphones uh some do uh it's
inconsistent sometimes they may have a
device but they may no longer uh
actually have a carrier that can get
information to them um and so one of the
things that we continually run into as
an issue across agencies in New
Hampshire is the entire issue of how do
you actually reach these
people um and one of the things that we
hear a lot from the agencies themselves
and it's not like the agencies
themselves aren't working hard but one
of the things that we uh that we hear a
lot is that um essentially they're
they're working hard to get the word out
uh and and when you work for a state
agency in New Hampshire uh communication
is about getting the word out the
unfortunate thing is when all we're when
that becomes our goal then putting
anything
out is a way to address that goal and to
solve the problem without actually
solving the problem uh a lot of times we
don't have a measurable goal and that's
why uh we could have we we may be having
an issue uh with the Medicaid coverage
for children where 6,500 kids uh uh are
now off of uh Medicaid uh because their
parents never responded to an
eligibility check request in information
well why is that did the parents just
ignore
it did the parents get the word how are
we how are we doing this um when it
comes to SNAP benefits we actually had
to pay we I'm sorry we actually had to
pass a bill uh a year or so ago SB
404 because our Outreach numbers were so
bad uh we realized that we had to do
something about them um and we actually
appropriated
$250,000 for an Outreach program uh to
increase snap Outreach uh at the time we
passed that bill uh only about half the
people who are eligible for these
benefits we actually taking advantage of
them
so
um this is something that is when I see
these stories it it it bothers me and
and I think probably the one that
bothered me more than any and probably
the reason why this bill is in front of
this committee is what happened with
low-income energy assistance last year
where we had a $35
million uh appropriation and the idea
was that uh this money would actually go
to lower income people who just were
outside the eligibility guidelines uh
for federal low-income heating
assistance uh and ultimately we had
about 2% of the people who are eligible
taking advantage of the program um and
about 2% of that money actually spent on
heating relief during a summer that I
can tell you or during a winter that I
can tell you from my own personal
experience was probably the single most
expensive winter deita home that uh I've
had in New Hampshire and I'm guessing a
lot of other people were were in the
same situation as
well um so the response to that uh was
was interesting um one of the things
that we we did was in instead of
questioning Outreach um and and how we
were actually trying to uh to make
people aware of this and and and make it
simpler let's say for them to to take
advantage of the of the um you know of
this particular this particular program
um one of the responses was we should
have just given $100 to
everybody um because that would have
been a lot easier and so the the
question that I have is given all of the
different programs that we have that
Target low-income people
what is it that's so difficult about
reaching these folks um how can agencies
in New Hampshire begin to work better
together um not only when they have a
program to communicate but in general um
are there things that we can be doing uh
as a state that will that will help the
situation so so for example one of the
things that might help is more awareness
of a federal program that actually
subsidizes um Internet carrier chares
charers for low-income people uh that's
available so there are there are things
out there uh there are pieces out there
I think there are fragments of solutions
um but what we have consistently in the
state is an approach where every agency
that has to tackle this kind of a
program uh seems to think it it's enough
to have a campaign to get the word out
without actually saying what are the
measurable goals that we are trying to
achieve and then driving towards those
measurable goals um I worked in in
Consulting for a long time and one of
the ways you sort of mask the people who
are trying to take your money for
communication versus people who are
trying to solve your problem or the
people who are trying to take your money
would say we could spend it on this we
could spend it on that we can get the
word out right the people who are
actually trying to solve the problem
first of all are trying to understand
the problem
better uh and then what they what
they're trying to do is once they F once
they they believe they understand the
problem they set measurable goals and
targets that actually are demonstrations
of progress that they're actually
meeting meeting these goals and with
with programs like this I mean we have a
a big measurable is how many people are
taking advantage of them what percentage
of them is that but I think one of the
things that's important for us to do is
to begin working towards achievable
goals in area in areas like this and and
to make sure that when we approve
programs like this we have
targets uh and that those targets are
clearly communicated to state agency
this is one of the things that that
frustrates me you know when I when I see
situations like what happened with
low-income heating assistance is because
I don't think it had to be that way
there there were there were things that
went wrong from the paper based
application process there were there
were many things that that slowed it
down but given our history uh of
communicating with that type of a
population number one we should have
known better and and number
two I think that there there are things
that we can do as as a legislature to
make it uh to to basically improve
results in this area and and I think the
bottom line is if we're going to spend
money on these things let's make sure we
spend wisely and the people who are
targeted to get this kind of help are
actually in a position where they can
get it and I don't think anybody felt
great about what happened to low-income
heating assistance last year and so part
of this and what I would urge you to do
is if there are things in my bill that
you don't like that if you they they're
not necessarily aligned with a problem
that as as you see it that needs to be
solved please go ahead and change it but
but I think this is work that that does
need to be done and it's work that can
result I think in some point at F in
future legislation or um a uh just
smarter interaction uh smarter bills
when we write them and smarter
interactions with the agencies uh that
we support as
legislatures and with that I'll take any
questions you might have thank you
representative Muse questions
representative Ms thank you Mr chair
thank you representative I'm glad you
were able to get here
uh you've um provided a some more
insight into this bill than we we had
previously I I have two questions the
first is um it sounds like this is much
more than just trying to
ensure computer or internet access to
the greatest number of people is that
correct I would say it's a it's a big
part of it and and I think part of it is
just the way the uh the uh uh Les wrote
the uh wrote the analysis of the bill um
but yeah I think it it's wider spread I
think the I think the issue is why do we
seem to consistently have issues uh
reaching and getting the kind of numbers
that we're looking to get when whenever
we're talking about some type of a
program that impacts low-income people
okay um that that's that's really what
I'm trying to get it and then my my
second question was and I had asked this
previously um I I think you you know
everything that you've described are
certainly uh things that we should take
a look at um I I guess I I wonder why
the need for a study committee why
couldn't this just be um an in agency
task force that's uh directed to provide
a report um and and I I come from that
um you know I I base that on the fact
that I don't really know what three
representatives and three senators are
going to be able to do to add to the
discussion it it could be an inter inter
agency tax task force the is the issue
is how do you get one of those assembled
um so if we think that one of the
solutions to this or or a way to
approach it might be creating an inter
agency task force after we get the
information I think that's great the
problem that we have now is that we
don't have an inter agency task force
what we have are a bunch of separate
agencies doing their own thing and
trying to get the word out all in their
job representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman uh just
very simply I noticed that there's a a
Target date of November 1st of this year
for that report given that we don't even
know when this commit committee would be
formed do you feel that that that's
really enough time to get all the data
and then make appropriate
recommendations second-year study
committees are always a challenge and
one of the biggest challenges that we
face is that by I think November 3rd or
4th uh some of us may still be here and
some of us may not be so I think that's
one of the reasons why why uh why that
deadline uh to make sure that we have it
so that the next legislature is in a
position where they can use this
information representative lii has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
um my question is um why do we want to
do this through the legislature we've
had the example of the fuel assistance
program and the 2% uptake however
perhaps you know from my point of view
that was a safety net and we didn't want
people freezing in New Hampshire in this
case why would the telecommunications
companies not try to make potential
customers aware of these programs that
are available that basically the money
would flow to them do we really need to
have the legislature
involved I think one of the reasons to
involve the legislature is we see we're
just extremely inconsistent about how we
do this so for example in the case of of
S sp404 um we actually approved a
quarter of a million dollars for
targeted Outreach I believe that the New
Hampshire food bank is in charge of that
and then one of the things that they're
doing is they're actually working with
other food banks across the state to
increase awareness of the benefit um
they're also doing things on their
website as opposed to the State website
uh so there's they're basically a lot of
good things that are happening there um
what I'm not 100% sure of even even now
is how effective have some of those
things been you know are they seeing is
is Outreach actually turning into an
uptick in results because I think it's
important even when we try to do the
right thing not not to just Pat
ourselves on the back and and go away
and said well we tried to do the right
thing but but to kind of go back and to
take a look and try to understand it you
know so we tried to do the right thing
did it actually work you know are are
more people signed up for SNAP benefits
are we finding that you know are there
still gaps um you know who's not signing
up for benefits what do we know about
those people do we know anything about
them is there any way we can get more
information about about them and how we
might be able to reach them in a way
that we're not doing now this is a thing
and and having worked in this field for
a long time I wor I did a lot of
corporate communication work and every
company you work for uh was different
they were retailers there were defense
contractors they were computer companies
and software companies um they they were
all very very different um but one of
the things that you we found pretty
consistently is when it came to lower
paid workers there were a lot of
commonalities and a lot of learning
experience that you you can kind of have
across those silos so I'm I'm thinking
and and sort of part of the theory
behind that this bill is if we you know
if we look at the way that agencies are
doing it now we can break down some of
the those silos encourage the sharing of
information and really just help these
programs be more effective because when
we're spending the taxpayers money we
want to make sure we're spending it
effectively and efficiently on the
things that we wanted to spend it on in
place all right thank you representative
Muse uh glad you made it in today and U
I'd really like to move on because uh
we're 15 minutes late for our current uh
most our next public hearing do you
absolutely need to ask this question
it's just ack one all right a quick
question from representative McGee thank
you Mr chair yeah um we had a question
earlier about whether the committee
would be focused on sort of a selective
solution and the question that I have
is would you anticipate that U that a
committee like this or a task force
would be looking
for categories of populations that maybe
need to be dealt with differently so
that when we send something out we would
understand whether there are people who
maybe will never have technology access
because they've missed the boat and
they're older and they're not going to
learn and they don't want to use a
computer so I'm just curious whether you
think that we might also come up with
more of a composite about what kinds of
resistance we're dealing with in terms
of reaching people yeah it I I think
that's all part of understanding the
problem uh so so yes and and and my hope
is that when a committee like this comes
together we actually have a fair number
of people in the house who have
communication backgrounds so um you know
keeping an eye on that as as we'd be
selecting members of the committee I
think would be helpful uh just simply
because there's a lot of basic
information about about Outreach and
targeting and things like that that
folks like that might already be aware
of and and it wouldn't be coming at them
uh the first time so and I know
representative McGee you're one of those
folks uh and I think we have some others
in the room as well so um so
yeah all right thank you very much we
appreciate you being here and I have no
more pink cards on this bill so I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
1047 and
spite of the fact that I would like to
take a break we're not going to because
we're a little bit late so I'm going to
open a public hearing on House Bill 1230
relative to establishing a committee to
examine weatherization initiatives for
homes in New Hampshire and I'm going to
call on representative Chuck grassy the
prime sponsor of the bill to introduce
this bill to our committee welcome to
science technology and energy thank to
see you again this was my um a committee
that I served three terms on back in the
70s so when it first started uh but uh
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is uh representative
Chuck grassy from Rochester W 4 I'm uh
here to introduce House Bill uh 1230
which deals with weatherization uh one
of the things I could say right now is
that all of the testimony you just heard
is relevant to what I have here I
probably don't have to say anymore uh
but I will tell you that um I was
working have been working with a number
of groups over the summer and last
spring as well uh dealing with Energy
Efficiency um and and housing two
different topics completely uh but one
of the things that I found is that there
was a large uh problem uh with our
weatherization program our Energy
Efficiency programs uh that we really
weren't getting the Outreach it was
necessary now I understand that these
are done through the Caps um but one of
the major constituencies that we have
that tend to not um take advantage of
this program as you heard previously uh
is seniors uh there's a large group of
seniors uh that in our in our state who
um do not have the technology to go
online to get this information do not
understand the application process in
many cases and the application process
can be very very complicated uh and what
I've done is is requested that a
committee with only one Senator makes it
easier to get them together um and three
house members that would study this over
the summer and BAS basically intake
information from the state and the
appropriate cap agencies uh on how uh
you know what the process is currently
and how we can make things better and
easier and increase that Outreach I had
a personal experience with the New
Hampshire saves program uh went through
a situation about 10 years ago where we
were replacing the furnace in our house
that had failed um everything was going
well and uh when the contractors came in
I went online to see what kind of
assistance was available there was
assistance available for me that we
qualified for uh worked with Unitil they
said oh yes you qualify for this and I'm
pretty astute as far as computer's
concerned and I checked right along all
the way uh when my contractor finally
gave me and I had checked the week
before and it was still taking
applications on November 1st
unfortunately my contractor delivered
the invoice and I went online there was
no money available that cost me
$2,800 that and the thing is is that I
think what we need to do as a state and
as a committee is to gather this
information and take a look at how we
can improve the accessibility to these
programs and particularly the
weatherization program uh so that more
people who are in need can take
advantage of it uh this will not only
save those people dollars but will also
save the state in uh and as far as
Energy Efficiency is concerned um as I
said everything that was said before
pertains to this bill as well um so I
think it's two bills you could put
together and you could probably even
have the same study committee with two
less Senators if I understood you right
and I will be happy to answer any
questions thank you questions for
representative grassy representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative grassy for taking my
question I actually work with a
community agency based in White River
Junction and we do weatherization for
low-income people in the Upper Valley so
I'm I'm certainly in favor of getting
more weatherization done uh the bill
talks about proper weatherization and
I'm wondering is how how how is that
defined
um as you know legislative Services was
backed up a lot of times when this bill
did come out um you basically to what
you got out of legislative services and
I know that I had one re re rewrite
rewrite and I got it on the last in fact
I didn't even have it on the last day we
had to sign off without having a final
bill in hand uh I don't know how you
defined uh proper weatherization I think
that um that's something that the
committee could certainly take a look at
and may want to amend it to to change
the wording on that uh but I think that
what you're looking at is weatherization
that will help save people um that we
create a more efficient uh structure and
and home uh for renters and homeowners
uh and uh that would uh save people
money all all along because you're not
only saving money for the homeowners
you're saving money through uh fuel
assistance programs as well
and uh so how you determine proper I I
don't know what the word how you define
that followup thank you for the followup
um the follow-up is uh in terms of
actually identifying uh where we need
weatherization am I correct that that
you would uh say that we'd probably be
doing it through state agencies and the
community action programs they would be
our sources of information well I think
you could also use yes but I think you
could also use local communities as well
because because sometimes building
inspectors uh and tax assessors have
that information as well particularly
when you're looking at at homes uh that
people live in which may be substandard
um and these were things that you could
do to um to to help those folks so if
you're aware of a an apartment complex
or an older home that has been converted
that has not uh been brought up to full
Energy Efficiency standards uh that uh
that a building inspector may be able to
make you aware of that so I would say
that sometimes the cities building
inspector or Town's building inspector's
office would be a place you could also
get further information as
well representative lecki has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
um I as a hypothetical I still wonder
why we need to be involved as a
legislature in this if I were a
weatherization contractor I'd buy myself
an infrared camera drive around and
identify potential customers and let
them know that there was Aid available
and so excuse me um I'm just wondering
why would we would want to do this
through the state when individual um
contractor has a great incentive to try
to identify the properties that need
help uh that would be nice uh so but
representative but it doesn't happen um
most these contractors are relatively
busy as well so I don't see them going
unfortunately additional questions
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
this kind of goes along with the
previous uh legislation that we heard
from and that is that uh you're you're
talking about a problem where we don't
we don't know what we don't know so
would you agree that that you know a
large part of the problem is that we
don't have a good idea of what the
housing stock in New Hampshire is and
this is as much a housing problem as it
is a weatherization problem and and so
uh that's that's the unknown that we
need to seek more information about
thank you thank you for that question
that's very important and that's what
got me involved in this is that I was
working with the housing group in
straford county and also a state group
that will hopefully be testifying you've
received some testify testimony from
written testimony from them as well and
when I was also dealing on the energy
side of things I I found that there was
a convergence between these two groups
the housing group that I was working
with that we don't know and that is part
of the problem we don't know and that
the Outreach is not working that we
currently have and we need to find a
different way to to do it and I'm hoping
that you know we may not come up to the
answer between now and November first uh
but at least we'll start bringing the
information together into a central
database someplace that somebody may be
able to utilize to move forward with
future
representative Ms has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for uh taking my
question um when you were doing research
on this uh on this bill did you reach
out to the Department of energy to see
if they have any reports that address
some of the um the items that you've
listed as the duties of the committee no
I I did not read out the department of
energy but I did work with our local cap
in in straford County cap okay uh to uh
talk with them about what they're doing
and I found that there were things that
were deficient uh such as they did not
know what the housing stock was uh and
what the opportunities were for them
they just you know they they get as much
uh they get as many applications as they
want uh and they fulfill those um could
they handle more work sure uh did they
want more more work not necessarily uh
but uh the thing is is that uh I found
that talking with a lot of clients or
people that need the service is that the
application process was very difficult
and this is something we need to take a
look at as well that you know when
you've got particularly seniors who uh
made as I said before may not have
computer access um or may not um be
aware of they you know they aren't
keeping up their financial records the
way they have in the past uh but they uh
they may be on Snap they may be on a few
other programs um these we we need to
make things we need to provide more
assistance to them as well and I think
that's something that this committee uh
could find that is there a way that we
can do our Outreach better and provide
better assistance to people to be able
to get um more uh WEA isation done
Hampshire representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair um
thank you for being here thank you for
taking my question um I um am a
certified building analyst through the U
building performance Institute and so
one of the things that I learned is that
most houses most buildings and actually
it's not just houses but businesses lose
between 25 to 35% of their energy costs
literally through the roof because of
poor insulation so I mean making sure
that buildings are insulated is a big
deal that's the best way you can save
money uh for your household or
anything NH saves does a pretty good job
with weatherization information and
rebates and things like that how do you
see this
committee working with NH saves would it
replace NH saves would it link arms with
NH saves is does have nothing to do with
NH saves well no I I don't think it
replaces them for sure and and and I
don't see this committee I I see this
committee is basically taking a look at
the situation working with NH saves to
say how are you identifying your your
clients how are you providing more data
to them the problem I had with NH saves
is when I started my project I had to
wait till I got an invoice before I
submitted and when I finally submitted
the invoice the money was gone if I had
been able to lock in that promise at the
beginning of the project it would have
saved me a lot of problems um and and uh
you know that's something we need to
take a look at are the programs working
the way they supposed to are people um
aware of what the responsibilities are
and what they have to do and then is
there assistance to be able to help
people along the
you representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um this question
is mainly like
um I I wanted to feel if R
intent is what you're
proposing only go so far as informing
people that the program is available and
by that I mean I know there are people
out there particularly seniors um maybe
they might like to have better
weatherization but they don't want
people coming into their house and they
don't want people saying hey you should
have weatherization because you're not
doing your part and we must come in your
house but they don't want to so I want
to be sure that the intent of this
program would be just to inform that the
program is available and it really
doesn't go much farther than that is
that is that what your in intent is well
I I don't thank you for the question I I
don't think it's I mean certainly the
program doesn't Force anybody to have
their house inspected um and and if
people are made aware that the
information that the the funds are
available or services available um you
know that's that's fine and I think that
the the study committee in itself would
look at beyond that uh into not just
making information available to people
but when we collect data we almost we
also may be able to identify additional
resources that are available beyond the
weatherization program that will help
people with energy efficiencies in their
homes particularly for low income and
seniors uh who who do need that help um
there's no programming if you don't want
people to come into your house there's
nothing we can force you to do to make
us go into your house or to L Us in that
I don't see that as any intent in here
you representative MC Williams has a
question thank you chair um thank you
representative Grassi uh my question is
related to two two technical issues um
just sort of an awareness piece uh the
first is um using high resolution
thermal imaging via GPS and satellite um
this is probably more of a department of
energy than representative grassy issue
but I think that uh the awareness that
we do have data and that the state is
able to access this data would make a
big difference especially to
representative Wendy Thomas's comment
about the roof being the number one uh
area where residential buildings lose
their heat in the winter time and so
you're basically throwing your money out
the roof all winter while you're trying
to heat it and so using satellite
analysis of each of these known
locations where we have folks who are
Poss possibly eligible and if they knew
they were eligible they might apply for
some funds and stop throwing money out
of the roof using um high resolution
thermal imaging could be that data
aggregator piece to address some of this
information so I just wanted to put that
out there are you familiar with this yes
okay and has your town been using this
EXC excuse me has your town been using
this not that I'm aware of okay all
right and then the second piece to this
is um how we track our building data in
the state of New Hampshire specifically
for res presential we've had
conversations in this committee before
and I just want to bring it up again
because I think it's relevant to this
discussion um we have talked about doing
some kind of metrics to analyze when a
building is sold when a residence is
sold if we were to do a blower door test
and include that information as part of
the MLS listing for the house that's
being sold then there would be data on
that building in the marketplace
historical data that shows it was sold
in 2022 to and it had a blower door test
and this is the data on its performance
at that time so I think that being able
to track and having some sort of um data
that carries with the building helps us
do our work better is your committee
looking at something like that to manage
the data that that wouldn't be outside
of its scope I think it's something that
could be uh certainly could be involved
with that um in my career I spent 25
years as a town planner and I was also
one of the first people to work on on
GIS here in the state of New Hampshire
I'm working with the granite system and
I think that that would be an excent
Resource as well to bring that type of
uh information in um you know I was not
aware that they were places were doing
that type of stuff I hadn't heard of
anything I've been out of the field for
more than 10 years now uh but certainly
that would be a tremendous asset that
this committee could look at as as
bringing in and using as a resource uh
to provide more data to these the cap
agencies who are the on the ground
people uh when it comes to
weatherization awesome yeah so just for
your reference thank you yes uh SpaceX
company satellite view is one of the big
ones that's doing it now thank you I'm
done representative MC Williams you
weren't here at the beginning of our
session but I just reminded everybody
that if you want to ask a follow-up
question you do have to be recognized
for that thank you representative McGee
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative grassy for coming here
and presenting us this bill you sort of
mentioned in an off-hand way that this
bill could fold into the bill that was
heard PRI
and I'm just curious whether uh you've
just been discussing some specifics that
may be very distinct from the Outreach
only focus of the of the first bill so
uh to that point do you think that there
actually might be some benefit in the
two bills if the committee decided to in
a work session say uh combine them in
order to see them go forward because
we're not going to have a lot of study
bills that go forward I don't think and
and you know listening to most of the
testimony because a large part of this
is Outreach but there's also the
collection of data and I think and and
you know identification of resources and
I think you're looking at that in both
bills uh and so I think there's there's
quite a bit of similarity between the
two bills that they could be merged uh
to have one study committee even if you
had two separate bills come down it
wouldn't have to be both bills could be
sent to the same
you representative nter has a question
thank you um how much are we currently
spending per year for weather is it
information following up on
representative n's
question on line 20 of the
bill it calls for the study committee to
develop a comprehensive set of
recommendations and potential
legislative proposals to promote and
incentivize weatherization efforts in
our
state and yet there is no mention
anywhere in the bill about
analyzing the affordability and the
cost of weatherization
efforts and there's no mention in the
bill as currently written about
performing any kind of cost benefit
analysis of
particular programs or
weatherization
initiatives how could we move forward
Ward without having that vital piece of
information uh thank you Mr chairman um
you know I I I you know this is one
thing that we have to take a a bigger
look at I because right now we have a
weatherization program and I don't think
it's meeting the needs of our citizens
we have a much greater demand out there
it may not be an identified demand but
it is a demand that it's out there um
and as we get are able to use better
Technologies as uh you know satellite um
infrared um that's going to even create
a greater awareness of what is needed
out there um you know whether it's being
efficiently spent um you know what is
the cost benefit uh of our current
program I don't know if anybody's really
identified that uh we uh you know we you
have yeah and and the thing is is that
uh that's something that uh um you know
needs to be taken a look at and is that
is the weatherization program doing its
currently doing its job and is it
efficient and um if it is there is a
greater need we need to identify that
greater need that's out there find it
and and serve
it so can I interpret from your answer
that you would be willing to add to the
study committee's
charge certainly a a a requirement that
they do some cost benefit analysis sure
okay thank you representative Ms has a
question thank you Mr chair um as a as a
followup to the chair's question doesn't
uh or don't lines 12 through 17 in the
bill get at uh analyzing the the costs
and the benefits well thank you because
actually line 14 does say assessing the
economic and environmental benefits of
weatherization um and so it does uh it
does do that I don't know if it you know
if there is a cost benefit analysis uh
but that does uh right there say that we
need to take a look at the benefits of
Economic and environmental benefits of
the
program I would argue that the glaring
Omission from that particular line is
that there's no mention of
costs that's what a cost benefit
analysis is all about well I I I'm not
going to just I'm not going to get into
debate I I think that the but we're not
here to debate this
subject I appreciate that okay seeing no
further questions let's move on I'd like
to call the next uh person who wants to
speak on this bill and that is Griffin
energy
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record Griffin
Roberge from the New Hampshire
Department of energy uh here to testify
in a neutral stance on House Bill
12:30 um working its way around the room
right now is a letter of testimony uh
from the department and really what it
does is it just kind of highlights um
our Department's role in managing the
federal weatherization assistance
program or WAP um just provide the
letter provides a brief overview of the
uh weatherization assistance program uh
basically the program is a as I
mentioned a federally funded program
that helps homeowners and renters um by
providing funding for Energy Efficiency
measures to reduce home energy
consumption um this is a means tested
program and limited to those making uh
less of 60% of State median income um to
deploy the program the Department
contracts with the five Community Action
agencies across the state caas as I have
in the letter or community action
programs are or caps um they operate and
deliver the weatherization services at
the local level so they conduct the
client Outreach the income verification
and enrollment they work directly with
contractors to uh to complete projects
individual
homes um once an applicant is deemed
income eligible an energy auditor will
uh contact the applicant and do a
comprehensive energy audit and identify
um areas of improvement in the home um
typically um the projects are ranked in
terms of highest energy cost savings
first and then they go down um so
typically as has been mentioned here um
they're largely insulation projects so
air sealing um uh insulation in the
attic wall insulation um insulation in
basements and crawl spaces um the again
I just want to credit the Community
Action agencies they are very
knowledgeable um about the program uh
the program's expectations and they are
dedicated to stretching our WAP funding
to the greatest extent possible um they
often work quite frequently with New
Hampshire saves and I believe it's the
home energy assistance program to
supplement WAP funding um and on average
um the state of New Hampshire receives
about $2 million each year in WAP
funding and obviously this varies year
toe subject to uh Federal Congressional
Appropriations and then finally with the
passage of the infrastructure investment
in jobs act in
22 um there was a one-time appropriation
of another 18 million to the state of
New Hampshire for the WAP program um I
did also want to note that in going
through some of the duties in the bill
as introduced um the department is
unable to identify the number of homes
uh throughout the state that are or are
not weatherized um New Hampshire does
not maintain any type of database about
what an individual homeowner might be
doing in their home in terms of putting
insulation in the wall or putting in a
new heating system um and then finally
the thing I want to note here is that uh
WAP is again a federally funded program
with federal dollars come Federal
strings um states are very limited in
modifying or changing their WAP
Assistance programs really in any way
shape or form um states are required to
comply with federal guidelines um if
they do not they run the risk of having
their whap funds pulled back uh by the
federal government um should the bill
become law um the department is
obviously willing to participate in the
committee's proceedings and um that
really concludes my testimony happy to
take any
questions thank you I have a question
for you in 2022 we passed House Bill 549
which authorized the department of
energy to spend up to $400,000 a year to
promulgate the benefits of energy
efficiency and home weatherization can
you give us any kind of status as to
what the department has done with the
money so
allocated and what kind of programs it
has initiated as a result thank you for
the question um that is something I'd
like to follow up follow back up on
again because this was focused on this
bill was focused on the uh
weatherization programs I was uniquely
kind of focused on our WAP program um if
right I'll follow up with you uh follow
up with the committee by
email okay thank you representative
Wendy Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chair um on page two your second bullet
states are limited in modifying or
changing their waps um is that a general
warning or do you have a specific
concern about this bill sure and thank
you for the question I and I apologize
for not being more specific in the
letter I think that point was focused
on
lines 20 and 21 in the bill where it's
talking about a comprehensive set of
recommendations and uh potential
legislative proposals again it's a
federal program I I just don't want
legislators state legislators getting in
the position of imposing State
legislation on a federal program because
it puts the department in a position as
to whether or not we're running a foul
of federal rules and regulations or
state statute that's I guess where we
coming
from representative PL has a question
uh thank you chair thank you for taking
my question um how does the department
of energy advertise this uh weap program
and is the funds all uh exhausted sure
and thank you for the question um to the
great yeah to the greatest extent
possible the department uh draws down um
its WAP funding every year we never want
to be in a position where we are sending
money back and I'm sorry I'm answering
your second question first um we never
want to be in a position where we send
federal dollars back um to the US
Department of energy um and again to the
greatest extent possible the Community
Action agencies uh work very well to
stretch these dollars to the greatest
extent possible um if a project can't be
done they'll often hit up the home
energy assistance program under New
Hampshire saves to see if they can
extend that a little bit further um when
it comes to advertising the program it's
my understanding um that a lot of the um
onus falls on the Community Action
agencies who are very well
um they're basically on the ground
working with these uh lowincome
communities because again WAP is focus
is a means tested program and focused on
those making less than 60% of mean
household income um so they're very well
Adept at making sure people are aware of
their program offerings um and making
pipeline representative nder has a
question thank you Mr chairman not to
put you on the spot but um more than one
this morning I been hearing Federal
funding Federal funding so tell me where
does the federal government get its
money sure and thank you for the
question uh it raises it um through
taxes from
taxpayers representative lewicki thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for the uh
taking my question uh there's been much
mention of these Community agencies that
are doing the actual
Outreach do they actually have some data
do they you you go out once again with
an infrared camera or whatever or try to
identify people who may be able to
benefit from this thank you for the
question representative I'd like to
follow back up if that's all right with
you via email probably the same one I'll
send the uh to representative vos's
question um again I know Community
Action agencies as a lot of other people
uh face Workforce challenges I don't
imagine um that they're sending folks
out in the field to knock on doors and
that type of thing but to great extent
I'd like to follow back up with you and
get you more spoton answer thank
you representative ryos has a
question thank you Mr chairman
um inherent in your um testimony Mr Abes
the clearly the way uh the
existing WAP works as well as the New
Hampshire saves programs are essentially
they are are opt in PE
homeowners must take the initiative
correct
to apply begin the process of getting
their property assessed for um you know
its current state of efficiency and
potential assistance
um the roughly 2 million a year in
funding seems to be you know the way the
programs have run for years and then the
onetime appropriation of $18 million
would have been looks like you know an
enormous um infl in influx of resources
available what's the current state of
the use of that uh $18 million where are
we with
that disposition of the 18 million and
and is there uh is that funding
available sort of in perpetuity for
should we get more more applications
should
we uh get a lot more people applying for
B for the program to get assistance
would that $18 million be there to help
them sure and thank you for the question
so the specifically regarding the
infrastructure investment jobs act
appropriation um that is uh an
allocation that's made for a fiveyear
period so we get it all up front we have
five years to spend it down um uh based
on my discussions with uh folks on our
weatherization assistance program team
um there might be the option to extend
the award period if needed if for some
reason we haven't drawn down the 18
million within the five-year period um
but obviously that is not our goal we
we'd like to spend all the money as soon
as possible um regarding you know I
think there was uh a policy effort made
by Congress and the Biden Administration
to certainly direct um Federal funding
toward those who you know are of limited
means and are certainly more subject to
volatile energy price swings um I think
that would you know and it's an it's
been an existing program it's an annual
program so I think the thought was that
they would inject more money into that
um I believe I hope I'm answering your
question I think I'm hitting all the way
around it uh but we certainly do um
intend to draw down the 18 million it is
relatively new to the department again
it was just um appropriate I think to us
just recently but I think we're in the
process of of drawing down those funds
okay thank you thank you to follow up on
representative rol's question is the18
million in addition to the 2 million
yearly that's correct funds
so the 18 million divided by five is 3.6
million you add 2 million to that
there's 5.6 million available for
weatherization for the next five years
is that correct I I would say if using
your analys using your example if you
were to take the 18 million that we all
have up front divide it by five years
you get about 3.6 million a year
assuming everything remains constant we
get roughly that $2 million
appropriation added on it's about four
to five million I guess you could say
each year for the next five years okay
good thank you representative Kaplan has
a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question Mr robish um you
know along the same lines so we're
seeing roughly a doubling of your budget
do you anticipate that that money will
be spent that you will have applications
to to to spend down that money and uh
you know a follow-up question would be
how do you interact with New Hampshire
safes and how does that budget compare
to the New Hampshire safes budget sure I
guess three question thank you for the
question I think we do intend to
certainly draw down the 18 million again
we never want to be in the position
where we're sending money back to the
federal government and that is something
that WAP staff in our department work
collaboratively with staff at you know I
heard mentioned earlier straford County
cap and the other caps around the state
to make sure the money is being deployed
efficiently and effectively um I've
already spaced I'm very sorry what was
the second question you asked I'm
sorry how do you interact with New
Hampshire saves I'm sorry about that how
does that budget compare to the New
Hampshire saves budget sure so the New
Hampshire saves budget is certainly uh
larger I would say than um the
weatherization assistance program budget
um again Community Action agencies were
work very closely with individual
homeowners and the contractors that they
have contractors with to do the work and
then to identify measures that would be
the best use of w funding versus New
Hampshire saves funding and they work
very closely with those parties to make
sure that it all works out in the
end representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Ro
nice to see you again um so my question
uh has to do with uh it was a question
that came up earlier I believe it was
the chair that posed it around the
return on investment for Energy
Efficiency because I believe we see
reports all the time and certainly the
New Hampshire saves program which is run
by the the uh New Hampshire utilities
default utilities um they generally come
out with a report on the trienal Energy
Efficiency program New Hampshire saves
every three years and it always covers
the return on investment which the last
time I saw it I think it was 3.8 so it
was a you know $3.8 for every dollar
invested do you does the department of
energy maintain that information can you
give us a sense of what the return on
investment is for the dollars that we
spend and the second question
is am I correct in understanding that
the New Hampshire shaves program is
funded through the regional greenhouse
gas initiative dollars I know I know
that the first dollar of the auction
goes to Energy Efficiency that's the the
only program that we've designed that
can be funded through Reggie so I'm just
curious is is that correct
still correct so I'll answer the first
one I'm going to get to the second one
if I lose it I'll ask you to just repeat
it so um on your first question about uh
reporting on cost benefit uh for WAP at
least specifically um again like to
follow up with you in the committee on
that I know that we have regular
reporting um that we report to the US
Department of energy on on the progress
of our program um I am not a WAP staffer
so I'd like to get a little bit more
into the weeds as to whether or not we
report any uh return on investment
information to the feds I can then relay
that on to you okay um your second
question uh obviously the New Hampshire
saves program is primarily funded
through the system benefits charge on
customers bills um the regie rebates as
far as I understand obviously
everything beside everything beyond the
first dollar of every allowance sold is
rebed back to customers um the remaining
money is put into What's called the
Energy Efficiency fund which I believe
is something that new hampsh saves uses
um as well um again I a lot of my
homework today here was a little bit
more focused on WAP again like to follow
up on that one and get a little bit more
specificity on the use of the yeah I'd
appreciate understanding yep how that
works
yep representative PL has a question uh
thank you once again thanks again taking
my question um since lap was funded
since
1976 I'm not sure how along New
Hampshire has but to your
knowledge we heard to I'm sorry backstep
we heard today that some of the few
assistant monies were not spent to your
knowledge is there any other weather
weatherization funding that is not being
spent to the max sure and thank you for
the question I think what the earlier
reference was getting to in terms of
fuel assistance funding I'm assuming it
was talking about the programs
established under uh HB 2023 from a few
years ago um regarding the federal
funding whether it's weatherization
assistance program or Li Heap or the
fuel assistance program um those monies
uh tend to be drawn down every single
year um if there's an outlier there I
can certainly again follow up with the
that okay seeing no further questions
for Mr robar question please uh
representative McGee I just have a
followup to representative F's question
um
so is it safe for us to assume that
there is a higher demand than there is
funding in these programs that if we if
we draw down the money every year thank
you for the question so yeah I I would I
think I think that would be fair to say
um yes um yeah I would say it's fair to
say Obviously the amount of homes that
are uh weatherized every year varies
based on program budgets and the amount
of uptake and everything like that one
home might take more funding versus
another home um but I would say yes
there there does continue to be a need
for um weatherization assistance program
funding and we certainly do deploy it to
the greatest extent possible thank you
thank you Mr robers for being here this
morning and answering our questions next
lame good morning Mr lame and welcome to
stn
don't forget to turn on the mic goodness
thank you so much for having me today I
appreciate it uh my name is Brandon Le
May uh I am from Manchester I'm also an
organizer with rights and democracy uh
just here to speak in favor of hb1 1230
uh and I just want to kind of uh skip up
some of the things that have been talked
before and just kind of talk about my
experience I do a lot of Outreach
particularly in areas with a lot of
renters in
Manchester and throughout the past
couple Summers haven't been able do a
lot of door knocking in the winters um
we've reached out to a lot of homeowners
and also middle and low income tenants
who have expressed an increasing
struggle to be able to pay their
utilities and the reason why I bring
this up is because HUD defines a cost
burdened renter if they're spending more
than 50% of their rent and
utilities on sorry 50% of their income
on rent and utilities as well so your
housing costs are heavily into your your
utility costs and what we found is that
a lot of the tenants that we' spoken to
struggle to keep their Apartments cool
in the summer and warm in the
winter and this has really I think
highlighted the need for a study like
this we need this study in order to
confirm what we've been seeing on the
ground because anecdotal evidence is
great but we really need to figure out
exactly how many of these renters in
places like Manchester are struggling to
keep their apartments or their homes at
an appropriate temp uh at an appropriate
temperature so I feel like the study
bill would help us actually clearly know
where the need is and then what should
be done about that because obviously we
shouldn't be legislating based on
feelings um but yeah so I am also really
excited about the idea of weatherization
in general uh mostly because you know
this legislator is doing some great
things to incentivize more housing being
built in the future the thing about
housing costs is that it's going to take
a while to get those down it's going to
take a while to get the supply that we
need it's going to take a while in order
to renovate a lot of the apartments that
we have but one thing that we can look
at is if we can reduce people's utility
bills that's a way of bringing down
people's housing costs and that's an
ability for this legislator to direct or
legislature to directly impact people in
a positive way there so I'll um see the
rest of the time that I have I'll open
up to any questions that we
have questions for Mr lame
representative MC
Williams thank you so much chair um and
thank you Mr lame for coming out to
speak with us um I guess my question is
i' just like to understand a little bit
more about how you decide which doors to
knock um as an Outreach piece to this uh
I I agree with you that if
weatherization and efficiency are the
lwh hanging fruit and that's really what
we should be doing to address first when
it comes to cost for energy for our
constituents so big picture how do you
decide like what is there a met a matrix
what what are you doing to make the
priority choices that is a really great
question representative thank you so
much well a little bit about me is I was
born and raised in Manchester so I know
the neighborhoods really well there um
we also do pour over some of the uh
census track data that we have we track
neighborhoods uh with some of the lowest
income in the state in particularly in
Manchester as well uh we go after places
with people uh you know who are more
likely to be renters so for instance 50%
of Manchester uh are renters and we were
going after neighborhoods that were more
than 75%
renters so a little bit of gut feeling a
little bit of pouring over data and uh
combine them into an Outreach plan thank
you further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you Mr lame for testifying here this
morning and call on our last speaker on
this Bill thank you and that is M
Fredericks of Durham New Hampshire
speaking on behalf of
mic hit it there we are um my name is m
friedricks um I grew up in exodar New
Hampshire and moved back to the state uh
two years ago and now reside in Durham
and I wanted to speak on this bill today
because um I have um joined the the
town's elected Town Council um and did
that uh through my work on the planning
board and the energy committee and one
of the things that I learned first by
joining the planning board um and then
the energy committee was the uh High
burden that our area residents were
experiencing with their utilities and
this is in Durham which is one of the
States you know better off communities
um and we have neighbors who are
spending um 800 to over a th000 on
utilities a month in modest homes these
are retired folks um are Heating when we
moved in was over 6,000 um a year and um
as I I started down this road to WEA
eyes our own home and try and bring
those costs down because we knew that
those costs were unsustainable for us as
um as a young couple and firsttime
homeowners and as we did that um we
really learned that uh I we were able to
manage it for our own home but I started
talking to many of my neighbors and many
of whom are elderly um and in that
process learning about a lot of the
barriers to weatherization sometimes
small things like in order for New
Hampshire saves to come in and do the
work they have to move all of the items
in their basement away from the
foundation walls and they elderly folks
who can't do that physically anymore um
or can't between the caretaking
responsibilities that one has for the
other who's now severely disabled and I
think that this sort of a committee
could really help to identify some of
those burdens um and the more that uh we
talked about this as an energy committee
um in Durham but also the energy
committees across towns are quite well
connected um and and have kind of a list
serve and meet periodically and what
we're you know what what I remember
hearing from all these other towns is
that folks are not only focused on
municipal buildings and their energy
committees that really across the state
people are concerned about helping
residents to weatherize their own homes
to bring those costs down um and they're
trying to understand and get information
out but I think that they're they're is
a gap in understanding you know um what
is the the unmet demand and how do we
reach all the people who need assistance
and so in the own you know our own
research for the town of durhams energy
committee um we actually are looking at
founding a nonprofit in order to help
residents navigate this process because
we do see that there are such great um
gaps in needs um within our own
residents and we spoke with the straford
county cap um and learned that one in 16
homes in straford county is on the
weatherization assistance weight list
and one of the reasons that there are I
mean that's one of all 16 home that's an
incredible figure to me um but one of
the reasons for that is that there's
sometimes also a mismatch between how
the funding can be used and um some
pre-existing delayed maintenance issues
um so just hearing that figure that
demand is so high and seeing the
statistics for the amount of fuel
assistance and electric assistance that
is going out it seems to me um to
be almost irresponsible with taxpayers
money frankly um to not to be continuing
to fund the fuel assistance and electric
assistance which we absolutely need we
we do not want people suffering in
unheated homes but to do so without
examining you know why are these
buildings using so much heat and energy
and what are we doing to improve that
situation because we could be providing
F assistance fuel assistance for 10
years at the you know more than $6,000 a
year because we're not doing
weatherization work and that that
doesn't make any sense to me um and
similarly with housing we are you know
we've recognized this urgent need for
housing and this huge um need for
affordable housing and um speaking with
you know I've been following that issue
as someone on my Town Council and
planning board and hearing from
different nonprofits across the state
one of the things that they recognize is
the energy burden and the fact that
utilities are making up a significant
part of cost for some households um and
to not acknowledge that in our housing
crisis means also that we are putting
out money um you know taxpayer funding
to deal with the housing situation and
try and address that but the utility
component needs to be addressed within
that because that's part of the equation
and so any responsible use of taxpayer
money to be funding things like invest
New Hampshire should be looking at
utilities as well because that's a
significant part of the housing cost um
so that's just I I wanted to come and
share um what I felt like I had learned
um from working in my local Municipal
level um and connecting with other towns
across the state so thank you thank you
Miss friedricks questions representative
Doug
Thomas thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um just for my own
clarification when you mentioned that
you have uh constituents that are paying
$800 to $1,000 a month on utilities
would you please define what utilities
um are composed of is it electric fuel
water or what what what does that figure
consist of um so in talking with them
that was just for heating costs but I
just heating I broaden it to um
utilities because it kind of varied on
what their heating source is we have
people who are using electric resistance
heat we have folks on propane we have
folks on heating oil um we don't have
very many folks on natural gas as I
think is the case for most um most of
New Hampshire we do have folks using
firewood um so just from having spoken
with various Neighbors in that context
follow follow up thank you and just to
tag on um with your experience let's
focus on electric uh um assistance I I
happen to know a person who um is well
below the poverty level in terms of uh
uh yearly income applies for electric uh
assistance and gets a whopping $9 a
month taking off the electric bill have
you found that to be a similar case in
Durham people applying and getting
really not much for their work for
filling out applications um I haven't
followed through with that to work with
people on getting the assistance um I've
connected more with them on the
weatherization and looking at New
Hampshire saves so I I've just shared
them their information with cap and I'm
I'm afraid I can't offer any insight
onto that your question sorry
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Miss
Frederick for taking my question um it
sounds to me as though you're pretty
involved and pretty aware so when you
mentioned your own um your own uh
utility bill that was not going to be
sustainable I'm wondering if you've
taken any action and if so how much it
might have cut uh that $6,000 bill that
you alluded to just curious yeah um sure
so we um did we signed up through New
Hampshire saves and we had some
weatherization work done um and we also
realized that our while our boiler was
still functioning um it was incredibly
inefficient and that was one of the
causes for our High um heaing costs and
so um we've started to do um part of our
home with heat pumps we couldn't afford
to do all of it um but our monthly bill
um it's a little tricky because electric
costs have gone up so much um but I
would say that um last winter our
monthly bill went up for maybe 150
electric with you know no electric heat
to about 300 with the heat pumps and we
are still continuing to occasionally use
um our wood pellets well we we use our
wood pellet stove and occasionally um
some of the the uh original system that
uses the boiler uses heating oil um and
so adding it all together um um I would
guess that it's you know probably safely
under $400 a month in the winter um and
if we go you know that's six month uh a
year um that we heat in our home we we
keep it cool in October and May so 2400
now I would say a year versus 6,000 when
we first moved in it's a pretty big
difference we're starting to wander a
little bit from the subject of the bill
so please keep confine your questions to
this study committee Bill representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
m Fredericks for coming in um in line
with uh my comment to representative
grassy that this is as much a housing
problem as it is a weatherization
problem I'm just curious uh about the
thing you mentioned about delayed
maintenance that you found that a lot of
the houses uh were unable to take up the
weatherization uh projects that they
were offered because of delayed
maintenance so I was wondering what sort
what extent of delayed maintenance that
uh that entailed because my experience
once you start trying to improve a house
you find that the problem sometimes is
much bigger than originally you uh
envisioned so what what what is do you
have an idea of what the extent of that
delayed maintenance is what kind of
problems they they uh they are and also
what percentage of the houses on your
waiting list that you mentioned would be
would would fall under this category of
of houses that have delayed maintenance
issues thank you um so that information
came from a a conversation with the St
for cap um weatherization assistance
programs director um who I found was was
extremely useful um and you know that
information about the one in6 homes in
the county overall so there over I think
it's over than 5,000 homes that are on
the wait list right now for straford
County Alone um and the examples that he
gave and I apologize that I don't
remember on the spot his name but um I'd
be happy to try and find that or I'm
sure you could find it on the website um
the examples that he gave were primarily
roof repairs um that they couldn't go in
and do additional insulation with the
the roof needing repair and they didn't
have the funding to repair the roof and
so what straford cap was doing was
trying to actually individually fundrise
fundraise for those homes as part of
their nonprofit fundraising their annual
fundraising and do um specific projects
to try and help help um home by home
make improvements but obviously that
that is extremely slow goinging um and
so they just have kind of an increasing
backlog in terms of the the homes that
assistance okay seeing no further
questions we want to thank you Miss
friedricks for testifying here this
morning and thank you with no other pink
cards extent for this public hearing I'm
hearing and I'm going to ask
representative plog to give us
information about the blue sheet on this
Bill if you have
it um not at this moment shair okay
we'll call for that later then and in
the meantime I'm going to open a public
hearing on House Bill
1289 establishing a commission to study
the replacement of the peer plant in bow
with a clean energy base load generator
and storage and I'm going to call on the
bills Prime sponsor Jared Wheeler to
introduce introduce this
legislation representative wheeler
welcome to sence technology and energy
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh I am late for work so I'm
going to be as brief as I can um I
introduced this legislation
here m mostly because and I got a call
from the lobbyist uh a couple of weeks
after I had requested the LSR saying
that they were totally compliant with
the regulation and it's not for me about
whether or not they're compliant with
the regulation for me it's about the
material that they're burning at the
plant um a large amount of federal
funding right now is available for uh
moving coal plants and other uh fossil
fuel plants in a just way towards uh
renewable energies and other things and
and that funding is only available for a
certain period of time and chairman Vose
as you and I have discussed uh after uh
uh before session the other day um the
bo Co plant is is set to expire in 20126
that set to to close um my opinion on it
and and why i' I've still chose to come
forward and and support this legislation
is that despite the fact that it is set
to close I think that it would be uh
beneficial for not just the uh
legislature and and the New Hampshire
state government but the the people of
Bo to have a comprehensive commission
that includes uh everyone who would be
involved in uh that transition including
the workers the the the the uh owners of
the plant the community in Bow um and
obviously throughout the process of of
the plant closing that there will be
opportunities for the public to provide
input to the company I think that it's
uh a good example of of what we can do
here in the legislature to have that
comprehensive commission that that
addresses that issue uh uh in a deep and
and well processed way with all of those
stakeholders at the same table instead
of uh one onone conversations one at a
time um coal and its harms uh uh the
evidence for me is in um and there is
specific evidence that I will provide to
the committee in my WR email testimony
after this uh linked to higher mercury
levels cancer asthma premature deaths
and people with heart
and lung disease in b um so this is
something that is directly affecting the
people of bow and uh in one hour the
plant emits more CO2 than than the
average American does in 26 years of
life so so as much as you know people
are trying to get us to use plastic
straws and and the individual
responsibility aspect of of where we're
at with climate change I think it's it's
examples like this where you have uh a
beaker plant uh uh producing more CO2
than one person does in 26 years and in
one hour of of it producing uh its its
energy and so you know to bring it back
to why now I think it's just important
uh given the fact that the plant is
commissioned to set to be decommissioned
by 26 to have a comprehensive commission
that addresses this issue um and as I
said I'll try to be as quick as possible
but I'm happy to take uh uh uh any
number of questions that you have I know
that there are other people who are
testifying who will be able to answer
those questions as well but that uh
essentially is why I brought this bill
and I thank you Mr chairman for the
opportunity to speak on it thank you
representative wheeler and uh members of
the committee being sensitive to
representative wheeler need to get to
work um be careful with your
questions representative Thomas has Doug
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question so
as I look at your bill here uh it
focuses on replacing the peer power or
the power plant with a clean energy
power
generator um knowing or perhaps you know
uh I I'm I'm not aware of any clean
energy generator that would generate uh
the Lost uh megawatts coming from the
footprint that the current plant now
occupies
um so would instead of focusing on um
clean energy in General on on the on the
study committee uh perhaps uh just a uh
a review or a study on what could be
placed there instead of the current
plant to generate an equal or more
amount of megawatts that would be lost
because peer power plants are very
important during
periods like this and we need to be able
to generate almost
instantaneously um uh Power that would
be needed on a a moment's notice is that
something that you would consider or
what other type of form could be studied
I'm I'm definitely open to anything that
we can achieve which Mak sure that we
can uh uh meet Peak demand when it comes
to our energy grid um I guess the
concern that I would have with opening
it up too much is I also have a concern
with with natural gas and and how how
that's purported I mean I'm not uh a
scientist and that's why I'm not on
science energy and Technology but I
think that there are conversations that
should be had around nuclear energy you
know keeping in mind the the concerns
that people have but um I think that uh
there should be a comprehensive
conversation about uh the peer plant and
and and for me it's um I hear that
concern but it is more about the fact
that they're using
coal representative Harrington has a
question thank you and thank you for
taking my question question uh as I
assume you're aware that there is a
mechanism in place in New Hampshire and
New England to build power plants uh
people build them they've been building
them for years and we've gone to a
deregulated structure where we have
Merchant plants where private uh
companies decide to finance they sign
contracts and then they for power
production and they build plants uh so
what I assume you're proposing here is a
replacement to that where somehow the
government's going to get in and finance
this or or mandate that a plan can't be
built there because there's no
prohibition right now unless you know
something I don't that would prohibit
anybody from building wind or solar
whatever clean energy you want at that
site no I the the legislation isn't a
mandate or or a government enforcement
saying that you must it's a a commission
with the stakeholders involved in the
plan including the owners uh about what
could
be follow up really quick so what you're
saying is the present process where
markets are all to do this doesn't work
you're substituting some government form
of commission to come up with an
alternate method from the way we build
power plants now well what I'd say to
that and you know I don't want to get
into a discussion about markets and
their impact on on the energy grid but I
I you know I have my opinions on that
but I I what I would say is that I think
sometimes the market despite being
important and an important piece of the
economy can leave conversations like the
environment and its impacts on uh people
in the community and their health uh by
the wayside and that's when it's
important for for public entities in the
public uh sector to step in and have
commissions like this to study the
impact of its health and and
Replacements that could be there to make
sure that uh people can participate in
the market um without cancer
representative liwicki has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative um one thing I notice in
the U membership of the uh proposed
committee is that ownership is not there
and this would seem to me to be an
oversight would you be open to amending
to have ownership of the plant be
involved happy to I'm absolutely open to
Amendment then on that
absolutely representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair um you
may be aware that in the town of marac
we have a dirty corporation that is
closing down that being St gobain uh
Dees is very involved in the oversight
of of this closing specifically with
regards to environmental toxins do you
see Dees playing a role in in this
committee um in the process going
forward for this yeah absolutely I would
hope that Dees would show up when the
committee would ask it to and and
participate uh as much as possible and
and uh I think Dees has you know shown
its its uh willingness to do so and and
um yeah my short and direct answer to
that would be absolutely yeah thank
you representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative wheeler for being
here the bill as written doesn't
actually say that the replacement should
be at the same location as the current
plant and the
current uh location of the plant
certainly imposes some limitations on
what could replace it I can't imagine
say a wind farm going right in there or
even um a solar array big enough to
replace what's there would you be open
to the idea of replacing this plant with
something somewhere else I think that's
a great idea representative Corman and
that might allow for uh you know
alleviating representative Thomas's
concern where we could find a clean
energy replacement that meets the peak
Hampshire additional questions
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative wheeler for
for coming in with this bill
um you know you've heard some feedback
on maybe the language being a little bit
focused and and and uh you've said that
you don't really have an idea in mind
that you're trying to mandate uh is it
fair to say and that your main intent is
to provide the the community and the
town of Bo and the state of New
Hampshire with some input into the
process of transition in this plan and
that's that's really what you're trying
to that's really your concern with this
legislation yes thank you representative
Kaplan I think that's well put and I
think um there's many examples of uh you
know environmental projects here in New
Hampshire that uh where if the public
doesn't feel adequately involved then
things can kind of blow up and and we've
seen that here in the legislature with
uh um landfill sightings and other
things like that so I think it' be good
before that process begins to to make
sure that the public is involved and and
avoid any explosion like we've seen on
on other ends like
that okay seeing no further questions uh
let's let representative wheeler get to
work and I'll call next on
Matt por Nick kesu and I hope I
pronounced that correctly uh
Matt yes thank you for having me uh it's
Peru I don't have that much time because
I have to get back to school uh but I I
just want to start off by saying that my
my family immigrated to New Hampshire
about 30 years ago and they they they
sought to be a a legacy in in the United
States and I feel that I I will no
longer be able to continue this Legacy
in New Hampshire for my kids if the
environmental issues persist I stand
before you you all today to express my
support for hb1 1289 as it pertains to
clean energy solutions to form a
commission about transitioning to clean
energy as an ambitious High School
sophomore from Manchester New Hampshire
I often ask myself what college will I
attend what career will I pursue but
most of all where will I be able to live
happily in 10 years in the 19 90s my
family immigrated from Romania to escape
the corruption created by the communist
rule of Nikolai chesu fighting solace in
New
Hampshire and beginning an American
Legacy for our family growing up both me
and my parents before me love visiting
Hampton Beach skiing at Pats Peak
staying at vacation homes in the
mountains and more over the past few
years these places have deteriorated
with increased rainfall and and warmer
Winters I want the best life for my kids
as as my my father did before me and his
father had before
him but it has become clear that New
Hampshire is slowly becoming dangerous
and inhabitable once a place my family
found prosperity and Solace now filled
with pollution from place like the
maramax station coal plant a catalyst
for higher mercury levels cancer rates
asthma
rates and premature death with people of
heart or lung
disease nonetheless the issue of
pollution exists in New Hampshire during
my parents generation but not to the
extent of today as a member of the Next
Generation New Hampshire what will be
our next step should we advocate for
solutions to pollution or do as those
before us and pass the constantly
growing burden of pollution on onto our
children's shoulders I say began to
acknowledge the issue of
pollution through forming a commission
for clean energy prospects at the marac
station coal plant to help create a
legacy of pro progress for the future
generations of new New Hampshire in
summary New Hampshire has been affected
by the dangers of fossil fuel pollutions
for many years and it is imperative that
a commission is form regarding a TR
Traditions to clean energy and Prospect
for the future of the marama coal plant
as well as the input of of the public in
Bow thank you for this opportunity to
testify thank you very much we
appreciate you coming in to speak with
us
today representative Wendy Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chair it's
actually just a comment I just wanted to
thank you for taking the time uh from
your school day to advocate for a better
climate future thank
you okay seeing no further questions
we'll call next
on Martha may Emerson who's here to
represent herself and I would remind
everyone that we're not here to discuss
the future of New Hampshire's climate or
the climate of the planet we're here to
discuss a bill to set up a commission to
study the replacement of the peer plant
in blow in Bow so I would ask you to
restrict your comments to
the study commission bill in front of us
and with that I'd like to welcome you
miss Emerson to sdn thank you very much
Mr chairman and members of this
committee um I'm Martha may
Emerson thank
you um I'm Martha may Emerson from
conquered I live in the south end and um
what I would like to speak to is the
effect of this on personal lives um in
New Hampshire but particularly in areas
close to the plant um I live 5.1 miles
from this plant and um the intensity of
pollution from the plant certainly is um
extends most intensely for a three mile
radius around the plant but there's no
wall there that keeps that pollution
from extending the the emissions from
the plant extending further so um in
terms of conquered in terms of all
neighboring communities in terms of
cities across our state the pollution um
from the the stacks of the bow plant can
extend up to 100 miles and so that is an
effect that certainly
impacts all of our state as well as
neighboring states so um chairman Vos
has expressed um a a recommendation that
we not speak to the future of um
pollution resulting from the power plant
um so I will I will try to um reframe
the scope of my remarks and terms of
that request um
specifically the bow power plant is an
old plant built in the
1960s um it has demonstrated in the
recent um past year um during um an
emissions test required by its
permitting that um last February after
that emissions test the results showed
that the plant was um emitting pollution
at
73% over the requirements that it its
permit allows for
emissions um because of that there was
um a retest requirement for the plant
which um the retest happened actually
three times um not until October
November and
December the October retest as you may
well know um was there were no results
it had to be discontinued because of
equipment failure boilers
leaking there was a second retest in
November and again it was not completed
because of equipment malfunction and
leaking
boilers the third retest in December
that also is not completed and no um
nothing was revealed in terms of
why there has yet to be another retest
scheduled um to see if this is a
functioning plant in spite of all of
this the plant was online during the
past
summer
um I can I can go on with a couple of
other pieces of information that I think
um really indicate the necessity to move
quickly on not continuing the operation
of the bow power plant in August of last
year New Hampshire Department of energy
um of of Environmental Services excuse
me informed the plants owners the
granite Shore power that its permit
breaches met criteria for federally
reportable
violations which can result in fines and
EPA
um I don't know there's a lot of
evidence that we need to do something
and in part because of the age of the
power plant as mentioned by
representative wheeler there is at this
time um Federal funding available on
first come first serve basis to
decommission coal power plants and to
replace them with clean energy
sources uh I think that's a real
opportunity here and I would
encourage that um we move as Expedition
as possible to bring this this bill
forward and to act on it so that people
in New Hampshire can benefit from this
federally supported
funding to accomplish the goal of what
is inevitable the closing of the plan
and to support replacing it with what we
I think all agree um as in repres
representative Wheeler's comments that
we need Peak energy
plans okay well thank you very much for
coming to talk to us this morning it was
nice to meet you we have questions from
Miss Emerson representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for coming
to speak with us today um I think we can
all agree there's some certainly some
Merit to the bill but the question has
already come up around sort of where the
oness in terms of how the plant is going
to be transitioned have you heard at all
of any plans from Granite Shore power
because I I I think the owners of the
plant are actually more aware than any
of us about the pressure to transition
with the closing coming up and I think
part of the problem is that the public
is not aware of any efforts to
transition the plant to a you know a
cleaner more
sustainable um energy source energy
asset if you will um so I'm just just
wondering if you have heard anything in
in the energy space or the public space
or where you live about Granite Shore
Powers efforts to try and come up with a
plan that will meet the federal
expectations around transitioning away
from the
coal thank you for your question
representative McGee um unfortunately
no I wish I could say oh yeah they're on
it um and um plans are are
in underway um they aren't even
responding in my view responsibly to
some of the problems that are violating
their permits right now um so I guess
that's my answer not answering your
question specifically but answering with
their lack of inaction yes thank you
thank
you seeing uh representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you Mr Mr
chair um I'm just curious you said you
live in conquered and or you live five
miles from the plant the plant um are
you aware of any water reports that
identify contamination in the water and
if so are these reports that could be
gathered for this committee that's
something I certainly have thought of um
I'm very green at testifying and um did
not have an opportunity to U go through
all the bullet points that I want wanted
to particularly in terms of
contacting um the the folks who are the
Waterworks of conquered um we do have an
open water source Penacook Lake as the
city water supply and um you know not
only what's up there is coming down
whether it's on the playgrounds or
Memorial Field or um all over
this region extending potentially out to
100 miles from the plant um depending on
the Wind where it's blowing so no I I
don't have that but it is something that
I intend to follow up on thank you very
much okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you for coming to talk to
us this morning and I'm going to call on
the next person who would like to speak
with us and that is Shantel Ryu of
gtown
I would remind you that we're here to
discuss a bill to create a commission to
study replacing the plant in Bow we're
not here to discuss climate change or
pollution or matters of that
nature thank you you've got it thank you
um good morning um SE science technology
and energy committee and uh thank you
for being here today to learn more about
these proposals and to hear from our
community um my name is Shantel Ryu I am
a fourth generation Granite Stater aside
from a brief stint that I spent on the
west coast I have spent most of my 31
years here in Southern New Hampshire um
for 30 of those 31 years I had no idea
that I was living Downstream always a
town or two away from the marac power
Generating Station in Bow um upon
learning about the station I started
researching the effects of burning coal
and the continuous use of fuels um
coming to understand how our direct
environment is impacted here in New
Hampshire um the as you've heard I think
from several people um a great statistic
and I think it warrants just hearing
again um you know the station does
create negative health and environmental
impacts while operating at full capacity
it does emit
CO2 um more CO2 in an hour than an
average American does in 26 years as
someone who has lived with asthma for
most of their life I am concerned about
that specific statistic and that's why
it sticks out to me um especially when I
live in such close proximity to this
plant that being said I can certainly
see why New Hampshire's natural
resources way of life and tourism are
being threatened by the environmental
impact with increasingly warm Winters
and property damaging floods from
excessive rainfall now that's not all to
blame on the plant but our direct
environment could be greatly improved
upon transition to renewable energy um
with the looming possibility of the
marac station being de commissioned I'm
sitting before you today to ask the
science technology and energy committee
um for support in creating a commission
to study the replacement of this peer
plant impo with a clean energy base load
generator and storage station this
commission would focus on the possible
clean energy solutions that would not
only help improve New Hampshire's direct
environmental and health impacts but
also help reduce electric costs that are
directly affected by our over Reliance
on outd fossil fuel
technology the creation of this study
would also ensure the residents of bow
plant workers Department of Department
of energy Department of Environmental
Services and the state have seats at the
table for this conversation I believe we
also discussed the owners coming in as a
part of this conversation as well um and
directly affect the transition as it um
directly applies to their communities uh
myself and many residents of New
Hampshire want to see the um want the
marac generation Generating Station to
provide clean steady and well-paid work
for our local labor force while also
protecting our water ground and air I
want to take this moment to appreciate
the committee's time and consideration I
will now accept any questions if you
have them thank you Mr Maru any
questions representative
muns thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you for coming in and joining us um in
in your mind what is the outcome what
outcome are you looking for from this
commission I mean are you looking for I
just throw out a couple possibilities
you may have others I mean are you
looking for a concrete recommendation on
a project to be built are you looking
for a report that just
summarizes kind of discussions among the
stakeholders what what is the outcome
that you're looking
for
thank you very much for that question um
so the outcome that I believe I'm
looking for is
um well first and foremost to definitely
have um these groups come together and
discuss um kind of put on the table what
they would like to see um overall what I
would like to see come from this um
study would be uh recommendations on
your thoughts or you know the thoughts
um you know what the possibilities could
be um because there are there's solar
there's wind and we discuss that it it's
quite possible it could be right where
the Jing station is or the possibility
of Elsewhere I think it's kind of more
seeing
it's laying foundation for what could be
I think is what we're looking to achieve
here it's like the first step into the
transition I hope that helped okay thank
you very much seeing no further
questions I would uh like to call on the
last person who wants to speak on this
friedricks and I'd ask you to keep your
comments as brief as possible as we're
running out of
time I will certainly do my best thank
you um so M friedricks again from Durham
New Hampshire um and uh I support this
bill um and for me the connection um
does come back to New Hampshire's
warming Winters um and that specifically
to this bill the reason for focusing on
clean energy in the study commission is
tied to that um for me it is really sad
to think that if I have kids they might
not experience New Hampshire the way
that I did which is swimming with eels
in our Coastal rivers and going Maple
sugaring and ice fishing and the river
behind the my dad's house where I grew
up 20 years ago was an ice fishing
Village every single winter the last two
Winters it didn't even freeze over and
so it is very personal to me to think
that the reason I move back to the state
may not be a reason that keeps me here
because it is possibly not um what I
thought it would be in terms of the you
know the experience that I hope to have
for my family in the future um and uh
but but returning to the bill um the
reason that I think this must be a clean
energy examination is also because um in
New Hampshire we already have RSA 378 37
which is a statute that defines that we
will look at energy technology without
preference for type of technology and so
we already do that as a state um the
reason it is so important to be
examining clean energy at this moment is
because it is evolving so quickly
technologically um it is you know that
our regulatory envir perhaps is not cut
up with where the technology is and
there's also currently a lot of federal
funding um that can help with costs
around this and so this commission by
focusing on clean energy would really
bring together the stakeholders in terms
of our legislators in terms of the doe
and the dees to examine the regulatory
environment and to assess whether you
know does it make sense to be asking for
some changes in future legislation in
order to build um you know to make pave
the way for in an energy environment
that is diverse um and to examine
sources of funding at this point you
know if we can take advantage of federal
funding that is already allocated out
there and New Hampshire residents can
benefit then I think that's worth
examining and in fact our governor has
already decided to do that by pursuing
some of the IRA funding um and our state
legislature is also supporting that um I
think that um you know I I don't have
great feelings about whether it makes
sense to to only look at this location
or not um I do recognize that a grid
location grid connectivity cannot be
moved and marac station currently has
the grid built around it and so I think
it makes sense to really focus on is
there something that can happen there um
you know that could be could absolutely
be solar they have over 300 acres it
could be um green Hydro it could be
regular Hydro perhaps it could be small
scale nuclear um there are plants across
the country that have done those sorts
of conversions but um
until we bring all the stakeholders
together that's kind of hard to know um
into representative Harrington's point I
think that absolutely there is a market
mechanism for this to happen already in
the state of New Hampshire but the one
piece that that doesn't include is
really the residents of Bo and the
surrounding communities and as a town
counselor I have a lot of sensitivity to
that because the hardest thing we do is
to pass a budget and to try and prevent
raising property taxes um and through my
work with the nonprofit at 350 NH um I
joined them just this past summer and
have done some door knocking um in Bow
and and knocked in probably 120 doors
and spoke with probably 50 different
households um and their greatest concern
right now are property taxes and how
high their rate is in their town if they
lose marac station if it's
decommissioned quickly they lose that
tax revenue and that could have very
real impacts for some of those residents
who were struggling to stay in their
homes in a afford those taxes and so
bringing in the residents of B and
bringing in you know that local voice
this is really the opportunity to
provide them that to allow them to um
get a sense of what is happening you
know they're not controlling the outcome
but they have a voice and they can be
learning um they can be making plans for
the town budget they can be thinking
about their own land use processes which
are all crucial things for you know your
select board to be doing
um and I think that um you know uh it
makes sense to bring all the
stakeholders together in this commission
um and to do so urgently because there
is additional funding that's out there
um that funding I believe is focused on
clean energy but I could be wrong on
that um but it is first come first serve
and it will disappear um if New
Hampshire doesn't pursue it and that
could have very real impact for Bo
residents in terms of if they lose the
source of tax revenue um that will
really affect them and the fastest way
to examine different uh you know
opportunities I don't believe it's for
you know the private investors to be
doing their research and figuring out
what they'd like to do and then approach
doe and also you know I ISO New England
and FK and you know then the Department
of Environmental sciences and then DS
has to go and do studies and public
input and then eventually it'll end up
to the B you know planning committee and
and be in front of them but if you can
bring all the stakeholders together then
that may actually make this process much
more efficient and also you know provide
cost savings as a developer I me one of
the things I've learned from the
planning board is that um you're going
to have public input that's how our
state works we like that local control
new New Hampshire residents want to have
their voice if you wait to bring it in
until the very last minute it's a lot
more expensive for the developers and if
you can bring it in early and start
educating people and start understand
understanding what people are looking
for then you're much more likely to have
a successful project um and so that's
why I think this commission really makes
sense now to take advantage for all
those reasons to really represent um the
residents of B and New Hampshire
residents as a whole um and make sure
that this is something that um can
really benefit uh the state that it is
feasible um that it's commercially
viable and that is something that is
going to be of benefit to New Hampshire
as a
state thank you m Ricks we have a couple
of questions representative Corman has
one thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question the current plant
maramax station has a capacity of
megaw um what are your thoughts on what
would be a reasonable capacity for a
clean Baseel load plant at that very
location so I think that that is a
technological question that I am not
equipped to answer and I recognize that
I don't work in the energy industry um
but I think that that's what this
commission needs to study and address I
imagine that um I don't know what the
capacities are for small scale nuclear
for example or for green hydrogen but I
think that some study has to be done on
that and I also recognize that um you
know the the this
plant's you know um blueprint base load
is much larger than what it's actually
used for today so whether it makes sense
to be pursuing you know a maximum um
contribution at this location or rather
something that can at least cover what
is currently there I I leave that to the
commission I think that that's where we
need our regulatory um bodies where we
need our industry we need our private
you know Market as well to provide input
um the one thing I would say is that you
know whether or not um the current
plants owners are are part of this um
commission I think that that could make
could possibly be reasonable either way
but I do think that um it might be I
would I think it's important that this
commotion focus on making sure that Bo
residents um are aware of what's
happening and have a chance to
also um learn about different
possibilities and to share their
concerns and their um and what they
would like to see and I would I think
it's important that the focus of this
commission stay on that as well as for
the state as a whole and then of course
this is ultimately it's um you know this
is a market um are you ities are
market-based this is privately owned
eventually you know no decision is this
is not a mandated thing in any way it's
a voluntary kind of information finding
um you know process that would hope to
bring together the stakeholders and make
sure that New Hampshire residents have
have a voice particularly the most local
residents Bo residents okay I think you
answered that question thank you
representative nter has one thank you
the state of Ohio has classified natural
gas a known hydrocarbon
as clean energy what is your definition
of clean
energy so my definition of clean energy
is something that is not going to be um
contributing to additional um carbon
dioxide or other greenhouse gas um
emissions in our atmosphere um in a way
that would cause continued um Greenhouse
effects and warming of our climate and
so I think you know new sh state has has
defined clean energy and and I'm going
off of the definition that the the state
has already established I I'm not you
know I don't think this one commission
should be trying to rework um all of New
Hampshire's laws so I think we have a
definition followup followup are you
aware that in China they're building um
a new coal plant every two weeks to
manufacture the parts for um solar wind
other sources of so-called green
energy I am aware that um China is
continuing to build coal plants they're
also switching to Renewables at a very
fast rate and I had a fascinating
conversation with Nikki Haley um about
this and how we might um hold China
accountable to reducing their own carbon
emissions um and was really excited by
that conversation remember we're not
here to debate we're here to ask
questions um representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair um
you've done a terrific job of advocating
for the town of bow and you've made it
very clear that the residents of bow are
uh stakeholders and all of this has the
town of bow considered or would they
consider creating their own
commission uh that is bow Centric uh to
address
this um I think that's a great question
I I think that um I know that the energy
committee has had some discussion of
this um but I you know and I won't speak
for them um but as a a town rep who's
you know volunteer as as as you are all
as well this is not our you know our
paid um full-time job um it's really
hard to gather the sort of technical um
and Regulatory experience as a volunteer
Committee in a small town you know to
examine the possibilities here we really
need to hear from
industry we need to hear from Dees we
need to hear from Department of energy
we need to hear from our legislators um
and I think that can only happen at at
the state level in terms of bringing
these different folks
together thank
you okay uh representative Ms has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again for coming in you've you've
done a a great job of uh presenting a
very compelling argument why it's
important to bring people together and
have
the kind of discussion that you're
looking for and and I want to follow up
a little bit on what uh representative
Wendy Thomas just asked you um the way
this bill is structured it would create
a
commission that best casee probably gets
established in
June and then sunsets on November
1st is that enough time to have that
kind of discussion or should we be
looking at some other mechanism to have
a really robust
discussion um I think that the
legislature may have a a better response
to that than I would um I do think that
six months would allow at least for the
stakeholders to come together it would
allow for representative to be chosen
from the town of B which would be really
important to have the town be working on
that and identifying um and they would
have to um you know find a process to
represent their their residents um as
well in that and it would be an
opportunity to certainly bring together
a lot of the existing research um about
which opportunities are out there it may
not have complete findings in terms of
you know whether a certain option is
feasible at that time but I think you
know six months the department of energy
is putting together a climate action
plan for the State of New Hampshire now
in less than six months so I think that
um you know important groundwork can be
done in that time especially in terms of
getting all the stakeholders into the
same space seeing where they're at and
understanding um what funding mechanisms
are POS possibly available right now
that wouldn't be available in the future
and I think those are the most time
critical um components and also to
understanding for the town of bow what
sort of timeline may be there for marac
station how do they need to plan for
their own town budget and their property
taxes okay okay thank you very much
seeing no further questions I want to
thank you for testifying here today and
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
1289 we will now break for lunch and we
will return at 1:00 to your house bill
1499 establishing a committee to study
the civilian clean energy Community
resilience and conservation Corp we'll
you
to resume our activity for the day we're
short shortly going to commence a public
hearing on House Bill 1499 but before we
do that representative PL is going to
give us some statistics about the three
bills we heard this morning
representative PL uh thank you yes on
Bill
1047 there was one in favor one
pro House Bill
1230 there was two in
favor House Bill
1289 there was three in
favor thank
you okay and you do not have information
about the
online I'm sorry chair uh the online is
down at the moment oh it is okay all
right well with that being the case then
I guess we can move on to our next order
of business which is the introduction of
House Bill
1499 establishing a committee to study
the civilian clean energy Community
resilience and conservation Corp and I'd
like to bring forward the Bill's Prime
sponsor representative Wilhelm from
Manchester good afternoon sir and
welcome to stn thank you so much
chairman Vose and honorable members of
the science technology and energy
committee uh for the record my name is
Matt Wilhelm I proudly represent
Hillsboro County District 40 which is
Manchester WS 13 10 11 and
12 um I'm here today to introduce House
Bill 1499 to establish a committee to
study a clean energy Community
resilience and Conservation Corps here
in the state of New Hampshire uh I got
my start in public service uh my first
job after graduating from Plymouth State
College as a team leader with City or
New Hampshire uh training and supporting
a diverse team of young adults uh from
across different backgrounds and walks
of life uh who came together to serve as
americore national service members in
some of our state's highest need and
underresourced public schools uh we
served as full-time tutors mentors and
Role Models uh following datadriven
curriculum uh working to help students
make progress on attendance behavior and
course
performance uh we did it full-time for a
year uh all for a modest living
allowance and an education award that
was equivalent to the pel grant which is
now um between six and
$7,000 uh which I used to help pay back
my student loans that experience
uh changed my life it jump started my
career uh and honestly looking back it
was the very best job that I ever had I
worked long hours um but it got me
really fired up about uh giving back to
my
community and in the rich bipartisan
tradition of Civilian national service
which dates back to the 1930s and 40s uh
with the Civilian Conservation Corp
whose Legacy uh can be experienced to
this day all across our state and around
the country uh including just down the
road Road in Allenstown at bearbrook
State Park uh which was built by the
hands of uh the hardworking men of the
Civilian Conservation Corps it was only
men at the time uh some of whom went on
to serve in the military and work for
the state of New Hampshire start
businesses uh and even serve in the New
Hampshire House of Representatives uh
like me they got their start serving
their communities and their country as
civilian national service members
tackling the challenges of their time
for them it was conservation it was
planting trees protecting public forests
uh from the ravages of fire erosion uh
insect pests and plant diseases uh
opening up some of America's beautiful
Wilderness Area by constructing roads
and
trails uh and building useful facilities
like bathouses and picnic pavilions uh
which I enjoyed with my family just this
past summer it's inspiring to know that
I stand on the shoulders of giants who
came before me uh and it's upon the
continued bipartisan Legacy of national
service over the last 30 years with
americore that I come to you today to
propose the next chapter uh here in New
Hampshire the clean energy Community
resilience and Conservation Corps so
House Bill 1499 prepares the state of
New Hampshire to be competitive when
applying for federal funding through
maror specifically for the purpose of
establishing this type of focused youth
civilian national service Corps that
provides valuable Hands-On Career
Training supports clean energy Community
resilience and conservation efforts
across the state and mobilizes young
people to come together across
difference to make a difference which is
something that I think we can all agree
uh we need more of right now the New
Hampshire clean energy Community
resilience and conservation Corp would
be designed to build upon the existing
network of americore through volunteer
New Hampshire uh which is our state's
commission for National and Community
Service uh and local nonprofit programs
like the student Conservation
Association
uh whose national headquarters is
actually here in New Hampshire it's in
Charlestown uh and it has a flagship
program that operates out of Bear Brook
State Park programs that are already
accomplishing really important work like
wildfire remediation resiliency Disaster
Response and Workforce Development but
also establish new programs uh that
address specific needs in communities
across our state so what does it look
like in action um well that's up to you
and to uh members of the study committee
uh if we create it but other pilot
programs across the country are doing
really important work to reduce carbon
emissions save energy costs by
weatherizing homes uh and public
buildings performing energy audits
installing solar panels and other
Renewable Energy Systems maror members
can also be found uh supporting urban
areas by creating and maintaining uh
city parks and green spaces improving
storm uh storm water management
maintaining city parks and greenen
spaces I already said that uh recycling
uh maintaining Urban farms uh americore
members reduce greenhouse gas emissions
associated with food systems through
Community Gardens Farm to Table
initiatives reducing food waste
nutrition education uh and whether it's
in response to or in preparation for the
increasing likelihood of natural
disasters Amore members help communities
prepare respond and recover from natural
disasters so you know we want to be well
positioned to make our case to the
federal government uh to americore that
New Hampshire is ready to stand up a
clean energy uh Community resilience and
Conservation Corps here in the granite
state and that's uh what my bill would
do it would convene stakeholders you
know executive departments national
service field local community leaders
nonprofit organizations of Interest high
schools uh institutions of higher ed
employers to shape launch and sustain a
program that meets the needs the unique
needs of the Granite State State um you
know over the summer and fall I would
Envision that this uh committee would
identify public private and nonprofit
funding sources uh Community needs
potential Partnerships uh there's work
that needs to be done to identify
projects and partner with americor and
volunteer New Hampshire uh which would
be responsible for Grant making and
oversight um there was a study conducted
a few years back uh by ICF and
commissioned by uh the Charles Stewart
mop Foundation uh found that national
service programs leverage the skills and
talents of citizens to address unmet
Community needs uh offer substantial
monetary benefits for all stakeholder
groups and a significant return on
investment economists report that for
every dollar that Congress appropriates
to Americar returns more than $17 to
society program members and the
government um you know I hope that there
will be Partnerships with employers uh
to ensure that Workforce funding and
curriculum is in place including
apprenticeships and pre-apprenticeship
programs uh they'll ensure that these
americore members not only have an
impact during their term of service but
are also set up for 21st century clean
energy jobs that will come online in the
coming years as our uh energy economy
shifts away from fossil fuels and into
Renewables and that's why uh you know
companies like revision energy and uh
you know which Dan weeks uh is an americ
or Alum himself I know he often
testifies in front of this committee um
but Dan knows that his company stands to
benefit uh from a program like this and
the quality Workforce that it will
produce uh young people want to do this
work uh half of all voters under the age
of 45 say that they would consider
joining a program like this if a
position was available to them uh our
environment needs it our state's economy
is going to need workers with this kind
of background and training so it's
really a win-win
um there was a a study commission uh a
few years ago uh that studied Pathways
from civilian national service programs
like americore and the peace score uh to
an affordable degree or credential and a
meaningful career here in the state of
New Hampshire um there's some good
recommendations in there uh that I think
can help the work of a study committee
uh to really Define a program that that
will be successful uh deliver results
for the communities it serves and then
also prepare uh the 21st century uh
Workforce with uh the workers that it
needs so uh with that happy to answer
any questions thank you
chairman thank you representative
Wilhelm so I have a couple of questions
to start out you mentioned in your
testimony americore and something called
New Hampshire
volunteers volunteer New Hampshire is
that what it was that's right
sorry
uh the bill doesn't mention
those organizations any anywhere uh so
I'm a little bit confused about what the
purpose of the study committee would be
would it be to work with the maricor to
establish something here in New
Hampshire
or on line 11 it says shape a new
civilian national service
program what does shape mean in this
context I'm I'm confused about exactly
what you're trying to accomplish
sure yeah so uh before New National
service programs launch and there's an
umbrella called americore and underneath
it are different types of programs some
are education Focus like the one that I
served in called City ear um the student
conservation Corp is another example uh
there are these clean energy and
conservation and Community resilience
cores that are cropping up across the
country because young people have said
that they want to do this type of
service in their communities because
because they're interested in jobs uh
that could result uh from being a part
of sort of this transition from fossil
fuels to the clean energy economy um
this study committee would convene
stakeholders which would include
americore could include volunteer New
Hampshire um but also include highered
institutions could include local uh
nonprofit organizations could include uh
Community leaders and uh nonprofits that
are doing good work in their communities
that said hey this is a way for us to
scale our work to do more of it uh and
engage young people in the process so
you know in order to apply for federal
funding that would be available uh they
need to go through their state service
commission for New Hampshire that's
called volunteer New Hampshire um and
that's how you get access to americore
funding and there are millions of
dollars uh that are available uh through
that program that has had bipartisan
okay thank you additional questions
representative
Harrington thank you thank you for
taking my question um I know you
mentioned Federal fundings and I see
there's no FN on this bill so is the I
goal going forward that there would be
State funds as well as Federal taxpayer
dollars used to fund this new call or
whatever it is yeah it's a great
question representative so uh I think
looking at uh private funding looking at
philanthropic funding how that I mean
that that is how most of these americore
programs are funded um there are some
states or municipalities that also
provide funding from time to time that
has not been a tradition here in the
state of New Hampshire uh so many of
these programs uh get up up and running
they they get a chunk of funding from
the federal government uh but then they
get additional funding that's uh
fundraised through foundations through
you know philanthropy New Hampshire
chable foundation for example follow up
quick follow up so when you say Federal
money you mean taxpayer dollars I mean
Federal funding which is taxpayer
dollars absolutely thank you
yep representative muns has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for being here um my my
reading of the bill is that it doesn't
actually
establish this um core that you're
talking about what it's trying what it
does do though is hopefully um create a
blueprint that is going to be available
that'll be there so that if federal
funds do become available or other
funding sources do become available that
we can then take advantage of that and
that at that point we would actually
establish this core can you just clarify
that for me you bet and I think there
there are a number of different ways
that you know new cores can become
established uh some have been completely
privately funded in the past you know to
say hey we're going to start a pilot
program to show that this works uh so
that when we apply for additional
funding you know we've got a track
record of impact uh that we can point to
uh others you know take the time to to
put together a plan before applying
directly for federal funding or for um
you know money that's allocated to
volunteer New Hampshire and then they
decide where that funding goes so this
is really a process
uh to pull stakeholders together to to
decide what a program could look like in
the state of New Hampshire identify
Partners uh perhaps there's a college or
university that wants to offer academic
credit uh that wants to offer additional
scholarship dollars because they're
looking for uh these types of of young
people who are you know community-minded
and service driven uh who want a career
in a in this particular area um I think
we need to jump that process and in
order to figure out what the the the
power and possibility and potential is
here in New Hampshire
followup followup um so you know we've
put we put this plan together we've
identified um you know funding Avenues
Etc um would would we need State
legislation to actually establish this
core or could that happen without
legislative action thanks for the
follow-up question uh it could happen
without legislative action it could be
that there is a leading nonprofit
organization or uh a college or
university that steps forward to say I
want to be the fiscal sponsor of this
program uh because we've got we we see
it as an opportunity for us to meet our
Strategic Mission uh and they could take
it and run with it and they they may
have ideas about the ways that they
could fund it um you know again to not
require any state funding uh because
again there you know State there there
are many maror programs that are running
throughout the state of New Hampshire
and they don't have americore they sorry
they don't have state funding uh they
only have Federal funding which again is
matched um that is leveraged uh to have
impact representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um thank you
representative for being here um there
the deliverable is a report that goes to
the house and the Senate and the
president and all that kind of um could
another deliverable be um a federal
application for funding or is that part
two does that come afterwards that's
part two but I think the the the
application for federal funding would be
strengthened by a plan like this thank
you representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um my question is
around the um the description of the
deliverables that you're going to try
and get to in the time frame that you
have because we November 1st is the
cutoff right the report's going to be
delivered in a relatively timely manner
um so I'm just wondering whether you
think the timeline is sufficient in
order to achieve um the goals of
identifying the stakeholders and then
getting those stakeholders to identify
the details of the program which seems
quite folsome I mean it can cover a lot
of things in a state that's diverse
right it could yeah could be all kinds
of stuff for sure thanks for the
question um I do think that there is
ample time to pull together even just
sort of the be bones plan uh and then
from there I think there will be a
number of recommendations that would
come out of the study that could include
further work to identify funding sources
further work to identify uh local
projects to make sure that we're having
a reach in urban areas and Suburban
areas and rural areas across the state
um you know could be could be a decision
decision made at the study uh through
the study to uh just focus on
conservation just focus on clean energy
just focus on community resilience or
two out of the three um lots of
different ways this could go um but I do
think that it's an ambitious plan but
also achievable uh in the in the amount
of time that's
allotted followup okay so along those
lines um what I was thinking was um do
you anticipate that when you try to pull
together the stakeholders for this
initial slice at the Apple um that you
would be trying to identify stakeholders
who might be able to stay engaged I'm
trying I'm trying to figure out what the
through line is right so stakeholders
that might be willing to stay engaged in
terms of managing the project because
you need some kind of a governance
structure and if the report doesn't come
back to us asking us to do something
further what what happens you know does
it just get dropped so I'm just
wondering who would who do you um
perceive as being participants in this
uh study if it goes forward you bet uh
thanks for the followup so I think that
the the stakeholder groups you know
include nonprofit organizations that are
already doing this kind of work already
uh it could include colleges and
universities high schools uh could
include employers uh potential
employers um I think there are a lot of
different stakeholders that could come
to the table I think the hope is that uh
one or more of them emerge that would be
willing to serve as uh the fiscal
sponsor of the project to really take
ownership of it and say we're gonna
we're going to run it whether it's a you
know a a 12ers program or it's you know
a 36 or maybe a 60 person program um
lots of different ways that this plays
out in other states and other
communities um but I do think that that
is one of the goals is to you know
figure out who's who's really interested
in driving this uh and seeing what their
willingness is to take it on thank
you representative bernardy has a
question thank you Mr chair uh so when I
heard you go through the list of
potential taskings that these um various
uh service organizations could do um
some of them included what I consider
operational private businesses or there
are people out there doing that kind of
thing so how are we going to make sure
that we don't have a federally funded
organization coming in and taking away
Private Business Opportunities yeah
representative thanks for the question
um one of the really smart things that I
think was in the americore legislation
that F that passed by the federal
government 30 years ago uh was to making
sure that no private employees or even
public sector employees are being
displaced uh by new national service
opportunities so that is something that
is in federal statute uh and it is
against the law and there are regular
audits to ensure that that doesn't take
place representative n has a question
thank you I have a three-part question
can you
define um coastal wetlands describe how
you protect them or rebuild them rather
and then explain how rebuilding them
protect the coastal communities from
Storm surges and flooding great question
uh and so these are some of the uh
duties and responsibilities that have
been put out by the federal government
saying hey if you're going to develop a
future program like this this may be one
of the things that you consider uh so
I'm not going to sit here and Define
that I think what's important is that if
the study committee is established that
they consider whether or not that is
something that would fit the description
here in the state of New Hampshire uh
whether that's something that core
members could or should be working on um
because it's not something you know each
each of these programs it isn't like
there's just sort of a cookie cutter
that says hey this is it it's going to
look the same in all 50 states across
the country or in every Community uh
across the US it's really important that
uh there's a group that is invested in
the concept that really discerns whether
or not that is something that is
appropriate for that Community uh and so
that's what the study committee would
do
representative Tony Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for coming in and
presenting this bill um this is a
national service program that's that's
being uh promulgated by the federal
government is it up and running and I I
might have Miss This in in your
testimony but is it up and running in
other states and what does that look
like is it is it being funded by as you
mentioned you know private businesses or
colleges or employ who's who's behind
the the the funding for it yeah thanks
for the question I think there it looks
different in different states I know
that there are five states that have a
program like this operating now another
five that are shovel ready uh and that
are getting private philanthropy uh to
help them pilot their programs um Maine
established one I think it was it's
either two or four years ago now uh and
they are just now uh getting core
members up and running so they are
really kind of a pioneer of this um and
I think it' be interesting to look you
know especially when we think about you
know Wetlands does it make sense to uh
take a look in what what Maine is doing
you know maybe it makes sense to bring
colleagues from Maine knowing that there
are similar um you know environmental uh
you know there's some similarities
between our two states given our
proximity uh does it make sense to bring
them in to talk about what they're doing
what their approach is to make sure that
wheel representative licki has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for for taking my question um you
mentioned that volunteer New Hampshire
could conceivably be part of this and as
I see it if we do something through the
legislature we might do nothing but slow
it down because before anything could
happen we have to have the commission
give a report um we have to have bills
filed and so that puts us into the uh
middle of 2025 at the earliest whereas I
would think that a private organization
could be more Nal would you disagree or
agree uh it's a it's a really good
question I think given uh the funding
Cycles uh for americore which run
through volunteer New Hampshire uh
having a report that was finalized by I
think it's November 1st in the
legislation uh would be good timing in
terms of preparing uh an organization or
group of organizations to apply for that
Federal funding so I don't think it
would slow anything down I think it
might actually creates emergency uh to
get people to move forward thank you
thank
you representative Harrington has a
question question thank you um just I'm
looking at your bill here on the um
section on the duties and it talks about
uh deploying lowcost reliable clean
energy could you be a little more
specific as to what type of lowcost
reliable clean energy you're referring
to yeah thanks for the question I was
actually thinking about this earlier
today so there was an article
um trying to think who this
was so I'll I'll I'll share this around
but there was a
an article that ran back in July I think
this is well regardless
um it was talking about school districts
who want to take advantage of funding
that is available uh to put up solar
arrays uh but there are a lot of school
districts that are smaller that are
struggling to uh find the technical
assistance that they need uh in order to
uh work through the paperwork and get
get access to the funding I think solar
is one example of of uh clean energy
that could be uh leverag through through
this program and I think you could have
uh these americore members actually
providing technical assistance with
local school districts uh that would
then uh make Federal Federal money
available make State funding available
uh and then decrease uh cost to
taxpayers follow up followup well so it
sounds like what you're talking about is
not low cost reliable clean energy but
taxpayers subsidized reliable clean
energy because whether it's coming from
the state or from the federal government
it's all coming from taxpayers so low
cost is kind of deceiving here because
the cost could be pretty high it's just
getting somebody else to pay for it is
that correct I would I would uh just say
that this this bill is in your
possession if you feel like you want to
amend it you absolutely can do
that representative Ms has a question
thank you Mr chair one more question for
you are there any examples of similar
processes that have been followed in New
Hampshire where we've tried to do what
you're proposing here pulling it
together a stakeholder group creating a
blueprint Etc I don't know that it's
been done through state government okay
yeah I think it's I think it's come
together in different ways and I think
this is this is one way that some states
go about it um but there are a number of
different processes that that could be
used representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um you
stated that five states already have
this program running five are shovel
ready is there a template or a howto
guide either from the federal government
or from the state governments that that
could be used as a platform for this
program yeah thanks for the question
there are there's a a coalition called
uh America's service commissions that uh
supports volunteer New Hampshire and the
other uh I think it's 51 uh States and
territories that have these uh these
these service commissions that support
National and community service across
the country uh they have put together a
a guide book for uh things to consider
uh for new programs like this that are
being set up and would absolutely be a
part of that process and I think we'd be
you know happy to come and testify as
well thank
you representative bernardy has a
question thank you Mr chair uh so there
are other organizations that do not have
this the broad mandate that you're
looking for here but have selected
pieces of it so like the agriculture
extension service at UNH or uh even 4H
or FFA I mean those are great
conservation
organizations how does this
approach uh help them or does it detract
from them or what what is the interface
in that kind of relationship yeah thanks
for the question I I actually think that
they uh benefit from additional capacity
that these americore members can provide
and so if there is a larger organization
that is the fiscal sponsor of the
program for the State uh oftentimes they
have a a a way that that they can deploy
members even full-time yearround for 12
months uh to a local nonprofit that may
not have the administrative capacity to
apply for that funding themselves
because they only you know could they
only have room in their office for one
more person but that one person could
make a huge different difference for the
mission of their organization so that is
a way that national service programs are
set up um and a a function that that
kind of larger fiscal sponsor can play
in supporting the the local network of
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question and um uh thank
you representative Bernardi I'll have a
follow-up question to what you just
asked I'd like to extend that question
to what I see here in your duties in uh
in the section one um so as I read some
of the duties here we have many state
agencies that seem like would come under
their purview with Department of energy
fishing game
um uh agriculture um so on and so forth
um how does this core mesh with these
organizations that I'm sure are looking
at the same things uh you're talking
about a private organization a state
agency possible um uh uh diverging uh if
they're not coordinating carefully how
does this core help these state agencies
do their job without inter in with them
that's a great question actually think
you can look at the student Conservation
Association they have a student
conservation core across the state of
New Hampshire uh and they have a
partnership with the state parks uh here
in New Hampshire so that come spring
summer and fall uh their members are
deployed across the state uh to help
provide education to folks who are you
know visiting the parks uh provide that
Environmental Education uh do Trail work
uh and that is done in deep coordination
uh with the commissioner of natural and
cultural resources which oversees the
state
parks follow up uh thank you followup um
what are the five states that have this
program operating already I'll have to
get back to on
that yeah I can get back to with the
five states that currently have it and
the five states that are shovel ready
and that are getting some private
running okay I have a question for
um on line 28 of page one of the bill
says develop a sustainable member
recruitment
strategy could you expand on that by
telling me how many people you envision
this core being comprised of and since
americore enabling legislation said that
this this organization can't compete
with the private sector or the public
sector for
employees where are these people going
to come from so what is what exactly
does this develop a sustainable member
recruitment uh strategy mean yeah so
thanks for the question chairman I think
the you know a a member recruitment
strategy first is defining uh you know
what are the ages of the Corp members I
think oftentimes you see in these youth
cores it's 17 to 25 so you get a mix of
folks uh who may have just graduated
from high school may have dropped out of
high school and are working to get their
GED but also want some on the job work
training uh you get folks who are taking
a gap year between uh high school and
college say I I want some time off from
school but I want to develop uh myself
and maybe get some Focus before I start
paying a lot of money to go to college
uh you can get some folks who have
finished a two years's ba uh uh
associates degree at a community college
who are considering going on uh to uh
get their their bachelor's degree at a
four-year institution you could get
folks like me who had just wrapped up
their bachelor's degree and were
thinking about going to grad school uh
but wanted to get some practical Real
World Experience uh in the meantime I
think a a comprehensive recruitment
strategy uh really helps to Define uh
what types of applicants you're looking
for because it could be one of those
areas it could be a you know just for
opportunity youth who are out of school
and out of work who didn't get their
high school diploma and this is a way to
get them back on track um or it could be
a mix of all of them because in my
humble opinion one of the most brilliant
things about civilian national service
in this country is it brings together
diverse young people from different
backgrounds and walks of life to learn
from each other
uh to realize how much we actually have
in common to get people working together
to deliver results and make a difference
for their community on something that
they're really passionate about um and
so I would like to see it be one of
those all of the above approaches but
that member recruitment strategy is
something that uh you know funders
whether we're talking about americore
and the federal government or we're
talking about the New Hampshire
charitable Foundation who this you know
this this fiscal sponsor could go to and
say hey we've got this new idea would
you be interested in funding a small
five person program um they're going to
be looking for answers to that question
now in terms of the size of the core
that you're talking about you know you
you were asking that question directly I
think it could be I've seen successful
cores that have uh as many as 150 people
that are serving all across the city of
Boston and in underserved Public Schools
um but I've also seen programs that have
just three members uh who are do doing
something very specific for uh a
nonprofit or organization to help
fulfill their mission so I think it
could be any size but I think you you
should rest easy knowing that uh no Amer
Corp members will be displacing any
other employee whether you're talking
about a public private or nonprofit
sector uh organization so as a followup
would these people be paid they receive
a living stipan so it's it's not it's
it's it's a it's a small living step I
think my when I was serving in the core
and this was uh back in
2005 um you know we were making I think
it was like $275 every couple weeks so
it was something to to help pay for
basic living expenses um you know
knowing that we were serving our
communities and serving our
country and then you get that education
award at the end which is really the the
driving thing that you know when things
get really tough three quarters of the
way through your service here um you
know you've got that kind of light at
the end of the tunnel knowing that you
can pay back some of your loans from
college so earlier you mentioned that
some of these volunteers or some of
these uh service organization folks
would help towns with technical assist
assistance if they wanted to install
some solar panels or so on and so forth
yeah how are you going to attract people
who have that kind of background and
expertise if all they're going to be
paid is a a simple stipend to help them
meet their living expenses yeah thanks
for the follow-up question I think there
are a number of different reasons why
people serve in in these cores some
sometimes people are uh trying to
rebound from a negative experience that
they had and they're looking for an
opportunity to uh learn some new skills
um knowing that there's some really good
training that's involved uh with
americore and a national network you
know I think when we talk about these 10
programs that you know by the end of
this year will be up and running across
the country there's a lot of information
sharing there's a lot of uh you know
training that will be shared between
those
organizations um you know I also think
that there are you know a number of
employers that are looking for uh
employees who are entry level uh but who
do have a little bit of experience and
and and want to want to know that
they've worked through this this topic
before you know they've done some things
to uh prove prove that this is something
that they're interested in have some
skills in and I think americore provides
a really great entrylevel opportunity
for young people to uh to prove prove
that they're committed to seeing it
through for you know a full year 1700
hours of service over 12 months um but
also enough that they say yeah I'm
interested in continuing to do this
job uh representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um I'm just wondering um so it sounds
like americore sort of acts as an
apprenticeship program I mean people are
learning skills and they're they're
going forward are there any statistics
on um how many positions lead to a
full-time job following the the the
service uh yes thanks for the question
there is actually there's some research
maybe about five years ago um that
actually talks about uh how employers
are looking for this type of person uh
that they're actually a really good fit
and that they uh you know are committed
to doing the work uh I think so often HR
departments are uh you know trying to
figure out what to do especially in a
job market like we have right now um but
if someone has uh a year of americore on
their application and that they saw that
through to completion um they really
jump out of the pile so I can get you
it's a you know 25 page report um but I
can send that around to the committee as
well
okay thank you representative Wilhelm
for introducing this
bill one more question from
representative Harrington thank you um
you you follow up to what the chairman
just asked about getting qualified
people let's assume you can you can get
qualified people now you talked about
people going to a town or a school
district and helping them uh do the
analysis for solar and how big and all
this other stuff and yet you're not
going to replace any workers in the
private sector okay I own a solar farm
for a solar uh company for example now
instead of hiring me they're going to
get this discount or free help from uh
this core of yours so I lose money and I
don't hire as many people as I would
because I'm only doing maybe the final
installation but none of the design and
the Grant application and all that other
stuff that I'd be doing otherwise so it
seems like to me you're going to be
taking away jobs from people in the
private sector and substituting with
these government subsidized jobs at low
pay thanks for the question uh I think
right now what we're seeing is local
school districts saying they can't
afford the technical assistance to apply
for the grants that they need to do
their solar installs and so if well I
can send that article around I mean it
was something from July uh if that's the
barrier that is keeping that school
district from installing solar and
decreasing uh the utility bills for
their municipality then I think that's
money well spent but you know it's up to
you uh to decide what to do with this
legislation thank you chairman and
thanks to the committee I appreciate the
questions thank you all right next up
I'd like to call forward the honorable
Tim Ean from Sugar Hill New Hampshire
representing wmcc and I'm sure he will
tell us what that
is thank you Mr chair thank you members
of the committee um for the record
Timothy Ean from Sugar Hill I'm uh the
Workforce Development consultant at
White Mountain Community College in
Littleton and Berlin as well as a
part-time faculty at Northern Vermont
University which is now becoming part of
Vermont State University so too many
schools that that I work for um I'm here
to support this bill um I've had two
unique experiences one uh in the media
Services World serving as a media vendor
for City year Boston in the mar cor and
I have firsthand seen the impact that
civilian Community cores can have on a
neighborhood and I think that this is a
valuable effort that this committee
this committee to study this type of
legislation would be important to have
as well in my roles at as a part-time
faculty at Vermont State University we
have an outdoor education tourism and
Leadership program where students work
in and around the community and part of
their goal is to get additional
certifications and they work with
organizations like this type of civilian
commission that could allow them to get
certifications that could allow them to
graduate faster therefore save more
money um for example they actually have
a program with the state of Maine where
students there go study Avalanche
training and most of these students work
in within the ski industry so they're
able to get this certification through a
community core organization and instead
of having to pay tuition to take a class
they've gotten the certification over
the summer or the winter and they can
graduate faster um from my role within
the White Mountain Community College I
see a lot of students that come to
school because they think they need to
go to college and some students aren't
ready and I think a core like this could
allow students to take a gap year to
explore themselves their skills their
interpersonal skills their ability
to engage with other people in the
community from different backgrounds and
it would allow them to be able to create
some opportunities sorry about that for
for themselves and that type of
Readiness would then allow them to go
back to school with more focus with more
understanding of what they want to
accomplish and hopefully again therefore
be more cost-effective if they're going
to go to college or Community College um
part of what's important from an
educator point of view as well as a past
legislator is that finding ways to keep
our students involved in our community
and be civilian focused uh Community
focused
is an important effort and I applaud any
bill that does that and so the fact that
this is just an effort to study the
opportunity to create this would be an
important start and that's what I want
to come and testify in front of you all
today thank
you thank you for being here
representative Bernardi has a question
for
you thank you chairman uh
so interesting you uh relayed how you
can get certifications without going to
school
um what is the community college system
think about that pulling away students
from their
potential that program is through
Vermont State University so it's not
it's not the Community College of New
Hampshire that's in the state of Vermont
actually the school
IM engages students to do that part of
the challenge that students in Vermont
have is the cost of Education um Vermont
and New Hampshire have very high tuition
so there are programs at Vermont State
University where they endorse students
getting certifications through
thirdparty organizations to help the
students matriculate faster through the
system they actually think that students
will stay in school and graduate if they
are able to find more cost-effective
ways to find thirdparty certifications
program further
questions representative
Kaplan yeah I was just going to ask the
same question about uh school tuitions
and but just highlight the fact that we
have the highest in state tuition rates
of any state in the country and uh you
know I was going to ask you would that
do you think that would help retain
students and high school students from
New Hampshire in New Hampshire if the if
a program like this was available so
that they could lower their University
and college tuition costs and therefore
you know you could keep more students in
the state is that is that something that
you envision with this program I've been
a part-time faculty in three different
institutions for the last 17 years and
when students aren't ready for
college that's a problem and that
actually ends up hurting schools
students come in they matriculate and
then they drop out I think by giving
students an opportunity to take a gap
year through a civilian core like this
build their skills they then come ready
for school they do well or do better
than they expected and they are
more fiscally responsible with spending
their money to go through college so I
think these are the type of things that
maybe give them skill sets that they
didn't know they needed before they
showed up to the college classroom when
classroom representative lii has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I uh keep hearing
mention of college Gap years and so
forth and I wonder whe is there any
opportunity for low-income um
individuals to be involved in this
because uh to live on a the stipend is
not possible and for someone who's low
income you've got to have a real job
that pays the bills now not a year from
now not uh sometime in the future well I
would imagine that's than thank you for
the question I imagine that was part of
what would be studied in this is is this
available to students who have graduated
col high school and are still living at
home so they have some type of financial
structure already or they have some
other type
of employment on top of what they're
doing in this program I'm not sure
that's part of why I think it's
important to have a committee to study
it
thank you Mr chair I think you're done
with
me sorry I had a side conversation going
on no problem any further questions for
Mr Egan okay seeing none we thank you
for testifying for us today I'd like to
uh ask Nick Paul of clean energy New
Hampshire to give us his perspective on
legislation
thank you Mr chairman uh I'll be
extremely brief I think I can do this in
three minutes uh but I will expect one
reward uh I I was just going to talk
about
Workforce uh with you today but this
seems like a a good opportunity based on
the conversation you just had with
representative wilham to talk about um
our energy circuit Rider program at
clean energy New Hampshire um so when
we're talking about having folks on the
ground providing technical assistance uh
to municipalities and small businesses
that is work that we are doing at clean
energy New Hampshire currently um we
have several ecrs uh around the state um
and I can tell you that there is a a
persistent demand for those Services um
especially on the grant writing side um
it's it's my personal opinion that
having more boots on the ground in that
area would not be uh
usurping uh anyone's prerogative or
financial interests so
that's something to think about um in
organization like ours would be
enthusiastic about partnering with a
program like this or with a maror to
train folks uh to assist our energy
circuit Riders and providing more of
these services to more
communities
um so yeah I would think about that
um someone asked which states uh already
have these programs um so it's my
understanding that uh Washington
Connecticut California Maine and
Colorado uh are those states that
already uh have one of these entities uh
stood up and and those that are looking
at creating their own programs through
public private Partnerships uh are as
diverse as Arizona Utah Minnesota North
Carolina and
Maryland
um the growth in the clean energy uh
sector uh as well as a a shortage in in
filling those good paying jobs uh are
well documented I've cited
um just one article from the New
Hampshire Business Review as well as the
US Department of Energy's uh annual
energy employment uh by state report
just to wet your beak there are a lot
more uh materials uh that cover these
issues uh and I'd be happy to pass those
along as as interest dictates
so
Paul seeing none thank thanks a lot
appreciate you being here and the last
speaker on this bill will be
Rob excuse
me
oh Rob Werner I guess it is of the
league of conservation V voters correct
Rob
welcome now there we go thanks Mr
chairman yes that's correct Rob Werner
I'm the state director for the league of
conservation voters here in New
Hampshire and we certainly are very
supportive of this concept and I really
see this bill as a conversation starter
as an opportunity for the legislature to
provide some opportunity for input to
provide um some credibility of
leadership that you all have in terms of
convening this
conversation and um I believe that also
that that it it will provide an
opportunity greater opportunity
additional opportunities to involve uh
folks in our communities to be helpful
to add to what is already H happening in
many communities in terms of community
service and needed programs and and
perspectives uh on how to actually help
people and help communities become more
resilient uh to provide opportunities
for more information Pathways of
knowledge that kind of opportunity so I
really would urge you to um uh support
this
legislation again it's a conversation
starter and I think that you have an
ability As Leaders of our state to play
a large part in that conversation as you
well
should okay thank you very much for your
a contribution to this conversation
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chair um
thank you for being here um Rob um so my
concern I mean this is a great program
you know I I talked um I did an
interview recently with somebody in town
uh Anita creger who who works with Eagle
Scouts and she she told me that that
people corporations look for Eagle Scout
you businesses because that's a plus
they want to hire those people that's
what representative willhem was talking
about the ages of these are 17 to 25 so
I assume they're still on their parents
health
insurance so that's one of my concerns
is is are these kids protected while
they're in this program and I I think
that's one of the things that needs to
be figured out um
but now what was the other thing I was
going to say um oh so so yeah so they
get a nominal amount of money what is to
keep a private employer from abusing
them making them work 40 hours a week
for this nominal amount of money which
is even less than minimum wage
well um I have to say I don't
necessarily have the answer to that very
specific question but I think that uh
given the fact that there are five
states that have these programs up and
running and that there are five other
states that are looking at it I think
there's an opportunity there to talk
with colleagues uh in other states um
and also to look at the existing
americore program how does that operate
and how does um how does the concern
that you're raising how that handled in
other avenues of service
you additional questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Warner for taking my question
you've mentioned several times service
and um I think that really is the the
point of the bill um this legislature
has had um several bills recently
discussing how schools were operating in
terms of Civic iics education and I
wonder if you could say anything about
your experience in the nonprofit world
with the value of of teaching people
what service in community is at an early
age because I think those are the people
that become the
most um useful citizens or purposeful
citizens even in retirement so um and I
think to me that's the purpose of this
bill right is to have a focal point so
that youth in the state will have some
place to go in ter Ms of figuring out if
they want to serve how they can
serve well I think there's um certainly
a real concept here of doing something
for your community that's larger than
yourself and I think that has a strong
societal benefit that type of community
building also know that employers um for
later in life um I think would be
positive about these kind of experiences
because employ employers is largely
looking for folks that um are team uh
builders that are fast Learners that are
open to new ideas and way of doing
things not so much necessarily the
specific training because what I hear
from employers is we can train folks to
do the specific jobs and skills we're
looking for um folks that have developed
Community skills interpersonal skills
and and uh Community orientation um that
is something that's important around
this so I think that you bring up a very
good concept about that in terms of
civics and being connected to the
community and how that really builds our
democracy really in the larger sense in
the larger sense that we think of that
in terms of how we interact with each
other and how we exchange ideas and how
is it that we are working together
despite our differences to move things
forward forward in a positive
direction so representative Ros has a
question thank you Mr chairman uh I want
to ask just my question is in followup
kind of responding to the concern that
was expressed by a couple of my
colleagues
about the potential
for these core members
to doing be doing things that displace
uh you know private
businesses um seems to me that in the
age group we're talking about 17 to 25
it's pretty unlikely that too many of
folks who might volunteer for something
like this are going to have technical
skills like engineering skills to design
a solar project or or a Wetlands
restoration project or something like
that so isn't it would you agree that
the the likely role and I know I partly
because I know you've served a number of
terms on the conquered city council
right um Municipal
space um isn't it more isn't it likely
that the roles that folks in a core like
this are going to serve if they are
placed with a municipality or with a
nonprofit organization such as
lcv is even though they're going to get
some small stien isn't the role more
likely to be like a volunteer staff
member with say the city planning
department or the town planning
department or whatever nonprofit it
might
be because staff of these organizations
are usually over they have more work
than they can handle and somebody says
let's let's have the town undertake you
know look at putting a solar array on
the municipal landfill or let's have you
know a nonprofit that
says we know this Wetland needs some
restoration but nobody on the staff of
those organizations has time to delve
into you know the initial fact finding
and the initial community outreach and
the initial this stuff uh so wouldn't
these folks be undertak some sort of
volunteer staff member to do the grunt
work if you will the grunt work that the
you know below the pay grade of the
professionals to help that municipality
or that or that
nonprofit put something in motion and
and
a lot of it may be grant writing in the
end to to get money to just but the but
these the role that these folks would
play is more likely be like kickstarting
something that the community or the
nonprofit needs I think so because you
you bring up a good point at that age um
I certainly didn't have a lot of those
skills uh when I was 17 years old um but
I had some opportunities to do Hands-On
work to learn things and to build my own
confidence about how I could operate in
the world and I think that's part of it
too so um it there there's so many
opportunities or different things that
people could be doing I mean from a
practical aspect of restoring Wetlands I
remember with the old CCC I mean people
are actually out there building things
that we use today um and that certainly
could uh be part of it in terms of
helping communities become more
resilient and and work on some of the
very um practical projects that are
needed to do that kind of work and to
get to that point um so yes I see I see
it as an opportunity of skill building
um uh for later in life mostly um and to
again build their own confidence make
connections and I think bolster their
experience thank you
okay seeing no further questions I'm
going to to that's our last speaker and
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
1499 we will take a five minute break
and then we will commence with our fifth
and final public hearing of the day at
afternoon
220 and we are on House Bill
1398 and the prime uh sponsor is
representative Michael Vose
representative oose please introduce
your bill
thank you Mr acting chairman and good
afternoon members of the committee so
I'm here this afternoon to introduce
1398 and I have submitted some written
testimony which is making its way around
the table as I
speak this bill seeks to provide
transparency and tracking for net
metering costs and to ensure that every
electric utility customer pays for those
for the costs of net metering and has
some way to figure out what those costs
are the bill accomplishes these goals by
requiring regulated utilities to recover
the cost of net metering and group
hosting via a stranded cost recovery
charge instead of standard rates the
bill also expands the definition of
stranded cost charges to include net
metering
costs that's the bill as interest
produced that definition is probably not
necessary and will be removed by an
tomorrow the background on this
bill on January 29th of 2021 the Pu
26450 in which the commission approved a
settlement agreement regarding ever
source's request to recover cost
associated with net metering group
hosting via a non- bypassable stranded
cost recovery charge this mechanism
spreads the cost of net metering to all
customers not just default service
customers quoting the order quote the
commission approves a settlement
agreement providing for eversource
Energy's recovery of net metering and
group host costs through its stranded
cost recovery charge rather than through
its energy service rate on an equal
cense per kilowatt hour basis with
corresponding offsets for any wholesale
Market Revenue attributable to net
unquote the state's
currently Uh current regulated utilities
list stranded cost recovery charges on
monthly bills issued to their
customers while the components of the
SCRC are not listed and can contain
other stranded costs customers can be
alert to the changes in the
charge should this bill become law and
seek further information if they so
choose thus a consistent mechanism for
providing information about net metering
costs can help customers understand what
their money buys and that is the
consumers tracking net metering costs
over time will provide an accurate
picture of its true costs that record
can validate studies that predict that
net metering costs do not encumber other
customers if the record shows the
opposite policy makers and Regulators
needed as the earlier referenced puc
order stipulates utilities can currently
recover net metering costs without a
change in
law eversource has been using its SCRC
to recover net metering cost since
2022 Unitil uses an external
distribution charge rather than an SCRC
but this charge doesn't or may not
bill therefore the language of section
two of the
bill currently specifies that regulated
utilities will use a stranded cost
recovery charge to recover net metering
costs and amendment I will file tomorrow
at exec session I will change the
language to
read distribution utilities shall
recover costs associated with net
metering and group hosting through a
stranded cost recovery charge or other
non- bypassable charge as approved by
the commission as long as those charges
bills one last thing I'd like
to add to the record before I ask to
turn it over for
questions so I'd like to read aart a bit
from pu order number 26450 dated January
29th
2021 quoting now quote we find that the
settlement agreement represents a just
and reasonable treatment of net metering
and group host costs and revenues
recovery of net metering and group host
costs through an
SRC Adder is appr appropriate because it
addresses the costs in a
non-discriminatory and non- bypassable
manner in addition the current
calculation and accounting methods are
appropriate and would be continued the
net cost would be recovered on an equal
cents per kilowatt basis and the
applicable CH carrying charge interest
rate would be the same as has been
applied to other such costs under prior
mechanisms
further it goes on to say
that we find it appropriate to further
investigate whoops sorry that was the
wrong
sentence they go on to say we have
reviewed the issues in this proceeding
evaluated the appropriateness of the
SCRC recovery mechanism and proposed
rate treatment for ever sources net
metering and group host
costs and considered the settlement
agreement among the parties and the
staff
based on that we find that the
provisions of the set settlement
agreement are just and reasonable and in
interest so that is the official record
I wanted to establish for this bill and
I would now look forward to hearing what
questions you have to
ask representative
Kaplan thank you uh representative
Thomas and thank you uh Mr chair for for
taking my question
um you say that this uh bill will
provide added transparency to the the
the recovery of net metering costs for
for rate payers uh and you say that uh
that eversource already uses a stranded
uh cost recovery mechanism for for for
such a for such a purpose if if that if
that's supposed to provide more
transparency then why did I would wager
that nobody on this committee knew that
that eversource was already doing so
so I I don't I fail to see how how uh
putting the net metering rate on a
stranded cost section provides greater
transparency that that's not itemized
nobody here even knew that they were
doing that so can you explain further
how that provides transparency for raid
pairs well because it's part of stranded
cost recovery you can look it up or you
can ask you eversource to to give you
the data on what those costs are if
you're so interested now it's not broken
out on your bill all it says on your
bill is stranded cost recovery charge
and then there's a number so you can't
see what part of that is net metering
cost but you can find out if you now
know that net metering costs are in
stranded cost recovery
charge
followup follow oh so you can so if I
can interpret your answer you you can by
further digging into into the data on
your bill you can find out what part of
the stranded recovery cost uh would is
entailed through net metering uh
recovery of of net metering costs can't
you do the same thing with your bill
today by looking at the default service
charge it would be much more difficult
to do that today because it would be a
much smaller part of the standard
representative
Reynolds thank you Mr acting chairman um
and thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question um just as a way of sort of
level level setting
for um the discussion that we'll have
tomorrow um the language in your bill
and the and the first sentence of your
testimony goes straight out and and
clearly makes a a uh a statement
that net metering costs that net
metering has imposes costs uh and to
ensure that every electric utility
customer pays for the costs uh could you
just explain for all of us now uh and
and everyone watching what are the costs
of net metering that you are referring
to the costs of net
metering well if you read the uh pu
order that I I referenced in my in my
testimony the costs are e explained
exactly how eversource
calculates its net metering cost it's
basically what they pay to a customer
generator for the exported electricity
that they
buy and they keep track of those costs
and then they recover them
through a series of mechanisms but
primarily through stranded cost recovery
there are some other credits that
occasionally get applied but mostly it's
through stranded cost
recovery follow up Mr chairman follow
up okay I I will go and and and read
that accounting but um could you just
for us
now when the utility pays a customer
generator for their kilowatt hour
they're getting a kilowatt hour they're
they're they're paying for they're
buying
um it seems that there there's a cost
and then there's there's a product in
return there's a there's a benefit
there's a an asset that gets purchased
with that cost so what are the I mean
clearly by wanting to recategorize these
net reading cost as stranded cost
you're contending that it's an excessive
cost that's um could you explain a
little bit more about why you see it as
just a cost that ought to be categorized
as a a stranded cost when there's a
resource
procured for the cost well I never said
it was an excessive
cost and I don't believe every Source
ever said that either in their
okay um proceeding before the
commission but it is a cost for
eversource because they have to pay for
that electricity normally they pay for
electricity by issuing an
RFP Contracting with a wholesale
supplier to supply electricity and they
pay for it as
they as they acquire it as they are
delivered as it's delivered to them and
so similarly when it comes time to
taking exported power from a customer
generator they have to essentially pay
for it and so they record those costs
and they recover them through stranded
cost
recovery that doesn't imply necessarily
that those costs were excessive it's
just the way they do it it's the way
they have asked for permission to do it
the other way they could do it is
through
rates just default Service rates they
used to do it that way Unitil does it
differently they they um have a
mechanism they call the external dist
distribution charge which is similar
it's a non- bypassable charge it's
similar to a stranded cost recovery
charge but they don't call it that they
do have a separate stranded cost
recovery charge that they use for other
things but they don't put it on the
customer bill so in the interest of
transparency the amendment I'll submit
for tomorrow
specifies that that even that external
distribution charge if they want to
continue to use it should appear on a
customer
bill have
daughter thank you I always need a
refresher course in net metering so I
was reading this while you were
answering him so I may have missed it um
the cost of net metering spreads the
cost of net metering to all customers
not just default services so does that
mean people who are part of net metering
they're paying a lower cost and to
recover the cost the utility will charge
everybody else more is that correct so
we're all paying for net metering all
even if even those who are not part of
net metering is that
correct uh I'm not sure I fully
but but the what it all boils down to is
that stranded cost recovery charge is
part of the distribution charge on the
bill and that's a non- bypassable charge
that everybody pays whether you buy your
electricity the energy itself from ever
Source or not if you get uh the energy
distributed over eversource distribution
system then you'll pay that charge so
even if you're getting your your
electricity from an alternative
supplier uh you'll still pay the
stranded cost recovery chart so you'll
you'll pay the cost of net metering
through that stranded cost recovery
charge
representative
Kennedy uh thank you uh Mr Vice chairman
and uh thank you for taking my question
I mean my question is a little bit of a
you know I am kind of new to this so a
follow up to my my colleague here which
is if you have a person with a a solar
panel and they're generating you know a
few watts of power and they are allowed
to sell that to the utility you know I I
think your point was that that that
thing has the same value as the money
they're paying for it but what I would
ask you is is that power of any value to
the utility or is it completely
useless and you know so they have to pay
money out to people who happen to have a
solar panel but it all it does is ADD
cost to you know the generation of
electricity by or
or
the I mean I guess what I'm saying is
you know if they if they have a plan for
how to how to meet the load on the grid
and then one day somebody it's a sunny
day they they start sending a few Watts
you know to the utility is that take the
place of power that they've already
bought from you know Quebec hyro or
whoever yes um and you know the the
followup I have to this and maybe I have
this all wrong but a lot of these
programs have always seem to me like
kind of a wealth transfer it's people
who got plenty of money and putting
solar panels on their roof uh are being
subsidized and that cost is being paid
for by you know the guy who works in a
grocery store and doesn't have any any
solar panels so I don't know am I am I
completely off on this or is there
that there are questions about the value
of net metered electricity because of
its intermittency and the fact that
utilities have to buy Power that's
always guaranteed to be there there is a
question about whether one is worth more
than the other I don't I think that's
outside the realm of this discussion so
I don't think we should get into that
here today but uh it's a question that
you might want to do more research
on representative
McGee thank you Mr acting chairman and
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question I actually wanted to just kind
of clarify this we're kind of all over
the place and how we're approaching what
we're looking at in front of us and um I
understand your point that you'd like to
see greater transparency so you're
saying if it gets placed on the bill as
part of um the stranded costs then
people will be able to go somewhere and
figure out what percentage of that comes
from net meter charges but as we've been
having the conversation we've uh gone
back to the fact that it still is a rate
recovery mechanism in terms of where it
really Falls so my question is around us
changing this categorization um and then
you clarified and you mentioned that
Unitil is has created a new category for
this external distrib distribution
charge and I think the reason they're
trying to distinguish it is that the
only way we can actually use distributed
energy is by leveraging the distribution
system right somebody has to be able to
manage it to get it to be useful uh
right down the street so um I guess my
question is what is the benefit really
of turning this into a stranded cost
when when I read the the chapter on
electric utility restructuring and see
what it falls into the category of
stranded
costs one of these things is not like
the other the the the rate recovery is a
is a totally different animal and I just
don't understand why it would be in that
category I think it's more confusing to
make
part of that category rather than have
maybe a separate listing for it under um
under
rates I would answer that concern by
suggesting that uh Mr Lata from
eversource will be testifying after me
okay maybe he can you give you a
rationale for why eversource pursued
this mechanism in the first place they
went to the Public Utilities Commission
and requested Ed permission to recover
these net metering costs through
stranded cost
recovery and we granted that permission
26450 and he might be able to give you a
better explanation than I could because
I haven't read the full order
recently um about exactly why they
decided to do it that way but it is a
good question okay thank
you
representative Ms thank you Mr chair and
thank you uh Mr chair for taking my
question um in the last paragraph of um
your
statement you say that utilities can
currently recover net metering costs
without a change in
law why do we need this law then what
does this law do that that is that what
does this change this this bill what
would this bill
change so the
bill as I intend to amend it will
require that the utilities recover their
net metering costs through stranded cost
recovery charges or a similar non-
bypassable charge basically the intent
of the bill is to get that information
on a customer bill so customers if they
choose
to do so have a mechanism and a way to
go and investigate what these charges
are
followup
followup but that information is already
on the bill so what I I'm I'm I'm sorry
I'm just struggling with what we're
gaining here well it is on the bill for
uh
eversource and if you knew what it was
called it would be
on uh it's not on the bill for Unitil
because they're extra or external
internal distribution charge as they
call it is not listed on the
bill and
so the intent of my proposed bill is to
get that charge listed on the bill
regardless of what utility you buy your
electricity from it's there now from
every Source but it's not there from the
other two
utilities so Mr chairman sorry I know
you can I have one more follow you've
had your two wait till everyone else has
their turn then we'll come back
uh representative
PL uh thank you thank you for taking my
questions us uh because my lack of
recall I hope you can answer this um
States regul uh regulated utilities does
that include uh the co-op New Hampshire
you represent MC
Williams thank you chair Thomas um uh
chair Vose my question question is
related to the uh renewable portfolio
standard and renewable energy
certificates requirements that our
utilities need to meet in terms of
percentages um it looks to me like some
of this net metering is being used to
meet those requirements and so I would
say that the value that the utilities
are paying are in order to meet
something that they are statutorily
required to do and therefore I don't
think there should be a stranded cost
because they have to do
it comments well the Pu says that it's
perfectly acceptable to recover net
metering costs via stranded cost
recovery
charge followup followup but it looks
like a double dip just in terms of the
statutory requirement because they have
to in order to meet the the renewable uh
portfolio standard so I can see the Pu
maybe not taking that into consideration
at the time that they made the ruling
but in terms of the new statute that
we're looking to pass we're still going
to be in conflict with with something
books I don't fully understand what
you're trying to get at there the the
RPS and net metering are completely
different programs so I'm not
sure why
explanation maybe we could talk about it
offline uh sure we could discuss this
offline I there's still a cost but
Corman thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you Mr chairman for taking my question
I'm still trying to wrap my head around
the uh
transparency notion here uh it's uh an
amount that at this point you're we
think is a cost there's also an open
docket at the Pu about net metering
tariffs and those may
change but it gets rolled into this
stranded cost
number the
average customer of utility is going to
just see this number and yes they could
contact the utility and find out about
it do you really expect many people to
be doing that and really be aware that
net metering costs are somehow being
rolled into this and that they would
then actually
take the initiative to go and contact
the big utility and try to get this
answer probably not however if we set
this system up so that all
utilities do track net metering costs
this
way then that would make it easier and
possible in the future to break out
those costs and put them on the bill
if it appeared to be worthwhile to do
that if if you're not tracking them
effectively
then it's harder to make it transparent
what people are paying
for follow thank you um and if it were
to turn out that net metering actually
was not a a cost that shifted because of
the benefits of net metering then should
the bill reflect the actual benefits of
everybody well I don't think the issue
here is whether net metering costs are
shifted it's that net metering costs
should
be paid for by everyone as a non-
bypassable
charge so it's not a matter of Shifting
the costs I can't look at you and
speaking to the mic at the same time
sorry I I
know it's not a matter of of costs being
shifted it's just being it's just a
matter of costs
being accounted
for that mean a utility could do the
same thing for let's say
trucks it could track the costs of
trucks and recover those costs in a
separate charge rather than in
rates it would be fundamentally the same
issue same
question uh so it's it's just a matter
of how they go about recovering the
costs
do now would be a good time
representative
Ms thank thank you and please please
bear with me um so if if I understand
correctly
um what you're proposing is that um the
methodology that ever source is
using be applied to all of the
utilities so that so that we're
consistent across all
utilities um and you're not proposing
any call it policy change in terms of
how we treat or view net metering costs
it's just purely how we report rep those
you represent Thomas Wendy Thomas well I
don't have the habit of calling on
myself so oh okay all right well thank
you thank you um Mr acting chair um I
think it's been mentioned in in a
previous discussion most people don't
know what the heck net net metering is
and so if you're uh proposing to put a
net metering charge on a bill will it
all will the bill also include a
definition of what net metering is along
with the benefits of it well I suggested
that that's something that could be done
in the future but I'm not suggesting
now seeing no further questions uh thank
you representative o for your
testimony and moving right along I'm
going to call upon
Mr Griffin robers no stranger to our
committee representing Department of
Defense of uh
fence
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh again for the record
Griffin Roberge uh State energy program
manager at the New Hampshire Department
of energy um going around the room right
now or making its way um is a letter of
testimony from the Department um the
department is neutral on the bill as
introduced um as has been discussed um
House Bill 1398 requires the cost of net
energy metering uh to be assessed under
a stranded cost recovery mechanism
um by new by New Hampshire's Electric
utilities um for context and it's been
mentioned earlier uh the cost of all net
metering payments to customers who
export energy to the distribution grid
and payments made to group host um net
metering host uh group net metering
hosts um are already included in non-
bypassable rate components such as
stranded cost charges paid for by all
customers um these net metering costs uh
have been included in rate elements that
all customers must pay so that there's
no avoiding those costs whether or not
uh if you go to uh competitive Supply or
otherwise all of New Hampshire's
Electric utilities have or are currently
undergoing adjudicative proceedings at
the Pu to establish rate mechanisms um
that include the costs associated with
net metering um for example eversource
currently has one under
de23 091 that's an annual review of
their stranded costs um that is
currently in process um as again has
been mentioned eversource uses a
stranded cost recovery charge on each
customer's Bill and that cost includes
not just net metering cost but also uh
costs related to the divesture of
generation assets it held um in 2018 um
as well as other Reggie cost
environmental remediation costs related
to former manufactured gas plants um Etc
um unitel currently has has a docket
underway and again that's
de
23057 that's an annual review of unit
tell's external delivery charge which
again is another version of a non-
bypassable charge that's comprised of
reggi rebates transmission charges net
metering costs and other costs as well
finally uh Liberty Utilities currently
has an active ongoing distribution rate
case under de
2339 um where the company proposed the
creation of a non- bypassable rate
mechanism called the electric
reconciliation adjustment mechanism or
eam um this uh non- bypassable rate
mechanism would bring together a number
of various costs that are currently
collected elsewhere and places them all
under the umbrella of One non-
bypassable Rate mechanism um this
proposal would include net metering
costs and in that ongoing docket the
department is supportive of that
proposal and if approved by the Pu this
mechanism would likely be included um or
I should say this ratee mechanism will
be similar to those that are done by
eversource and
unitel um should HB 1398 as introduced
proceed in its current form and I
understand representative Vose um
indicated he might have an amendment
tomorrow um the committee might want to
consider amending the effective date of
the bill um requiring all New Hampshire
Electric uh distribution utilities to
meet this language within 60 days would
likely not be possible for the one
remaining utility um that this bill
would likely impact which is Liberty
because they are currently undergoing a
regulatory process on that non-
bypassable rate right now um
Additionally the bills focused to have
net metering costs assessed under a
stranded cost recovery mechanism may be
too specific as it could create
additional administrative and Regulatory
burdens to move these costs from where
they currently are as the Pu approved
them to meet the uh statute language
provided under this bill um obviously
the department is always willing to
provide technical feedback on uh
amendments bills what have you and uh
that position is not changing here I'm
more than willing to talk about any
proposed amendment um and with that I'll
close my
testimony represent of Kaplan thank you
Mr Vice chair and thank you Mr Roar um
I'm curious about these uh these what do
you call them these new rate cases that
the you ities are bringing to to recover
their Cost U stranded C stranded cost in
other words sure
um could you provide information as to
what costs they are considering when
they call for these uh cost you know
these net meter cost to be what what
what could you itemize those costs for
us so thank you for the question so by
and large um the costs for net metering
that are recovered under these non-
bypassable rate mechanisms are those
costs that are paid to customers who
export power to the grid from their
systems um obviously that number e that
number es and flows every year oh sorry
just clarification so the they're
they're charging the
cost the cost that they are charging
equals the amount that they are paying
to the customer generators yes okay yes
sorry about that um
so I'm trying trying to remember where I
picked off so the cost of paying those
customers who export energy back to the
grid that es and flows over time because
the default service rate changes so um
if rates go down net metering costs
likely go down um if energy costs go up
net metering costs likely go up as well
um each of the utilities through various
adjudicative proceedings at the Pu I
know a lot has been discussed here about
emulating ever sources style um in a pu
proceeding unitel and Liberty have
different non bypassable rate mechanisms
that have been approved by the Pu
they're not just a stand stranded cost
recovery charge like ever Source they're
called different things but they're all
essentially a non- bypassable rate
mechanism everybody pays them nobody can
avoid them so they get they get the theg
followup one follow up yeah so so the
utilities are receiving that energy that
they've paid for and they're also
getting the money back that they pay
correct okay sounds like a good
deal
re sentive L wikii okay thank you Mr
chairman um thank you Mr Rob um I'm
somewhat new to this now and uh we are
talking about various things I just
looked at ISO New England site and they
say that their wholeale the price for
New Hampshire now is 8 cents a kilowatt
hour how does that compare with the
default rate and is the default rate the
same as the net metering rate thank you
for the question um yes uh let me flip
over here
forgive me there are a number of
different uh I should say there's net
Maring tariff 1.0 net metering tariff
2.0 so there's different tariffs that
apply to different customers you know
based on the time that they
interconnected
so their compensation might be different
depending on what tariff they fall under
um but circling back to what I mentioned
to representative kaplan's question you
know I know the energy rates have been
were up due to the Ukrainian um crisis
and the inflationary pressures um those
costs are coming down um so therefore
the costs that would be assessed for net
metering under these uh rate mechanisms
would likely be lower as well hope I
think that maybe answered your question
I'm not
sure okay we can talk more offline
representative
Corman thank you Mr Vice chairman uh and
thank you Mr Griffin always good to see
you um Mr Rober you're good
um so I'm I'm a little confused by this
uh the sentence uh additionally HB 1398
is focused to have net metering costs
assessed under a stranded cost recovery
mechanism may be too specific as it
could create additional administrative
and Regulatory burdens to move these
costs from their current rate mechanisms
to meet the Bill's specific
requirements can you elaborate on that
please sure so I think I'd offer two
points is that again eversource being
one the largest utility in the state
has has stranded costs and Stranded
costs are those Investments that at the
time were used and useful for the
delivery of electricity before you know
they have been in the process of selling
off of their electric plants they are
still recovering uh stranded costs from
those Investments at that time um
Liberty and
unitel just by the basis of what a
stranded cost is recovering cost that in
the past used to be used and useful for
the provision of electricity don't have
stranded costs um so I think the
department wants to highlight is that
you call it a stranded cost but it's not
really a stranded cost that's one and
then two um administrative and
Regulatory burdens there a docket
already currently underway um across
these different
um uh uh adjudicative proceedings um
which have been soliciting testimony and
uh ongoing proceedings um this bill
might inadvertently throw a wrench into
those proceedings and just say
legislature says you have to shift it to
this rate this rate recovery mechanism
do
this
followup
So based on what you've just told me I'm
surprised that the department is new
neutral given that you're you're telling
me that it's probably not appropriate as
a stranded cost and it would throw
wrench into open dockets sure and I
thank you for the question that is why I
am here today to testify to that fact
but obviously you know and I've heard it
discussed earlier that this is an effort
to bring transparency onto customers
bills this is a policy call for the
legislature to make if they think that
this is a um a prudent decision to make
certainly you're you're free to do so we
just make you aware of what the impacts
bad
representative
McGee thank you Mr Vice chair I was
looking at you sorry I'm trying to I'm
trying to follow the ping pong that
that's happening here
so so we've already established that the
cost if it becomes rolled into stranded
costs is not going going to appear on
the bill right it will be part of a
charge that does not call out any
specific in other words the transparency
issue that you're saying you're here to
support us because the chairman said
it's based on transparency can you speak
to whether this bill as written uh if
you haven't seen the amendment yet and I
haven't um would lend itself to
transparency because that's what I don't
understand I don't I don't see I don't
see the argument that the bill is
actually Lending any transparency for
the consumer sure and that's already
been brought up actually no and I thank
you very much for the question so I mean
it is a it is a matter for this
committee to consider you know ever
Source stranded cost recovery charge
which is displayed on a customer's bill
is not itemized to include all the
various costs that are C that are
recovered under the stranded cost
recovery charge um it's not just net
metering it's a bunch of other costs as
well um I can cannot comment on unitel I
don't remember off the top of my head if
they display the external delivery
charge on their bill but much to the
same point that charge okay representar
shaking his tail I'll take him his word
um so um not sure probably not displayed
on a customer's bill but that cost does
not just include net metering costs that
unel is recovering Liberty Utilities is
currently undergoing a rate uh rate case
now so depending on what the outcome of
that rate case is I'm I wouldn't be
surprised if right now Liberty doesn't
have anything either follow up and
hopefully this will be a little more
pointed since we've been over that
already um you did mention that because
um eversource moving from PSNH had a
different set of stranded recovery costs
which is really what the statute lists
here they list eversource's stranded
examples of stranded costs yep um and it
has nothing to do with rates which is
why I was confused
because it seems like rates are
inappropriately put in there but you're
saying all the utilities now are using
stranded costs to cover various things
that do not include the same categories
of things that are in the statutory
language that we have is that is that
correct thank you let me clarify um each
of the utilities has their own
respective non bypassable rate mechanism
to capture these costs for eversource
they have a number of stranded costs
left to recover theirs is the recovered
under a stranded cost recovery mechanism
unitel and Liberty to the best of my
knowledge and talking with folks from
our regulatory Support Division do not
have stranded costs they're not
recovering they're not continuing to
divest themselves of Investments that
they made when so you were referring to
non bypassable charges which they all
have but you weren't saying that the
this is just clarification you weren't
saying that the information that is
currently in statute for stranded costs
applied to all this is basically as a
result of the restruct structuring P
that's mostly case that's correct yes
you representative
Bernardi thank you Mr Vice chair so Mr
Rober by putting the all net metering
charges from whatever utility in a
stranded cost line we are consolidating
that information for transparency
purposes so if anybody wants to go
looking for what those costs are they're
already aggregated by each utility they
don't go have they don't have to go
looking for them or figure them out from
whatever track they use they're in one
spot it can easily be identified that's
the transparency issue that we're
talking about is that correct that's
what I believe the discussion to be
yep representative
Ms thank you Mr chair and I want to
assure my colleagues that I did not say
say anything to the people on this
side they left of their own valtion um
thank you Mr Ro um for coming in and
talking and speaking with us
um so you I think you heard some of my
struggles in the in the questioning I
had of of uh chairman Vose um and and I
guess I want to ask you similar
question this bill doesn't change
anything that's already being done is
that
correct as introduced that is how the
department reads it that's correct the
only thing that the bill would do to use
what you had asked earlier it would
emulate eversource's style and apply it
to all
utilities followup followup so is this
bill necessary that is a decision for
answer representative
PL thank you thank you
Mr um representative Bernardi answered
uh asked one of them that if I had three
properties three utility bills I can
correlate the net metering charge with
this from each one what percent of that
bill would be net metering you could as
yes you could and just to confirm in
your thing you says by new uh New
Hampshire Electric utilities all of New
Hampshire are you including the co-op
yeah okay we're starting to cover same
territory I'll give the last question to
representative
Thomas thank you very much um so we've
spent a great deal of time and I don't
know if you're the right person to ask
this of uh talking about these charges
can you give us some specific examples
of what these charges are how much does
it cost to buy from a a net metering
system sure thank you for the question
so uh and first off I didn't say it last
time but happy birthday um so um if it's
all right I'd like to follow up with you
for a little bit more information on
that um you know I there is something on
our website that details the cost of by
which net metering customers are
compensated I think it'd just be easier
if I were to print that off and give it
to you um regarding the nonbi the cost
there recovered under the entire non-
bypassable rate mechan ISM I provided
some examples here in my letter of
testimony I didn't include all of them
if it's helpful I can talk with
regulatory support and see if we can put
up a document
yep okay see others uh more questions
thank you very much Mr rur for your
eversource
good afternoon uh Michael Lata
representing
eversource uh I put two minutes on my
card uh maybe we could do it in in one
given all the questions that have been
asked but I did bring up my laptop in
case you uh you stump me on a question
so um uh eversource is is neutral on the
legislation
as
introduced um as has been discussed
eversource does recover the cost of
payments to customers um and group host
who net meter through the stranded cost
recovery charge um this has been the
case as stated uh since pu order in
2021 uh approving the recovery through
the stranded cost recovery charge um I
would note and I think um if I
understood uh representative V the bill
sponsor correctly with his proposed
amendment I I do think it would be a
helpful clarification not to include net
metering as in the statutory definition
of stranded costs um the stranded cost
recovery charge does recover things
other than uh what is included in the
statutory definition so adding it to
that definition I I think is unnecessary
and um as has been discussed uh could
potentially lead to some level of of
confusion um just an example of of
another
um uh item that is included in the
stranded cost recovery charge that is
not a stranded cost uh and I think Mr
robar touched upon this but the uh
Reggie rebate that customers receive
from the proceeds of sales of Reggie
allowances that does flow back through
uh to all customers through the
SCC um I also think the the um uh
proposed change to the the second
section of the bill uh offering it to be
a bit more expansive to include uh other
non- bypassable charges uh I think again
Mr Roar explained um some of the the
benefits uh to that approach although
again uh eversource does recover these
costs through the SCC stranded cost
recovery charge so that would would not
impact us um I guess I'll just leave it
there and I'd be happy to answer
uh obviously more detailed questions
about how we we calculate uh the
stranded cost recovery charge in
particular net metering um expenses and
credits uh these are filed on an annual
basis uh changes to the stranded cost
recovery charge uh and those as was
previously stated uh are available on
review presentive Corman
thank you Mr Vice chairman thank you Mr
lado always good to see you as WE peer
around this speaker uh yeah so uh since
you invited us to ask you about how
eversource calculates the charges uh
that's one thing I'd like to know along
with uh do these calculations take into
account things such as reduced
transmission costs reduced distribution
costs and also uh other benefits of net
metering
so the the way that eversource
calculates um net metering ex charge uh
included in the SCRC is essentially we
take the the payments that have been
made to customers for their exported
energy which is based on on metering
data um and then there is a certain
group of customers that we actually um
assume responsibility for their energy
uh they are compensated at the net
metering rate but we actually resell
that that energy into the iso Regional
wholesale Market the revenues associated
with those sales flow back to all
customers as a reduction in those that
first Topline expense cost uh so the the
net of those two is is the cost
Associated um is what the rate is is
based off of in terms of reductions in
transmission or capacity or or energy
purchases um those would manifest
themselves uh if they occur through
those various different components of
the bill so for example if net metering
exports reduce um Peak demand uh at a
wholesale metering point at the same
time that transmission Peak is occurring
then all customers would receive a
benefit of of reduced uh transmission
charges because it's it's based upon the
use yes uh followup and uh but I'd like
to make one comment first um we've asked
a lot of questions uh on of of a
technical nature here uh and we'll
continue to call on for questions but I
would ask that the questions be more
oriented towards the bill itself in
terms of uh why is it being moved from
one spot to another versus the Val the
uh you know versus the value of the
actual net metering which is not really
the focus of this bill it's just where
it's going to be showed up so
concentrate questions on that
please thank you Mr Vice chair I will
try to
uh at least Orient my question that way
um so as I understand it a customer
could actually call up ever eversource
right now and say what am I paying for
net metering what part of the stranded
cost is net metering could a customer
also call up and say um what part of the
transmission charge am I not paying
because of net
meter
so if the customer were to request you
know what is included included in the
Strand you know how much on my bill is
associated with energy purchases from
net metering we would Point them to the
stranded cost recovery charge uh
probably filing and and show them where
that is um
uh in terms of showing the uh direct
attributable reduction in transmission
Peak associated with the aggregate um
net metering output uh that that is to
the best of my knowledge subject to
check not not something that we're able
to uh show to customers given current
systems representative Thomas thank you
uh Mr acting chair uh we've had a
similar Bill last year now actually
where we added a charge to to the
eversource bill it was the electricity
um I think it was representative
Thomas's
bills cost of the RPS and we heard from
the utilities that it would it was going
to cost you money to to change the bill
and everything would this bill cost you
not you but but
eversource to you you've got to buy the
software you've got to figure out the
you know you've got to program it and
everything what is the impact of this
bill on rate payer cost sure uh so two
two quick things there uh first again I
can only speak for eversource not the
other uh utility so we do T recover
these costs through the Sanic cost
recovery charge today as as the bill
would direct so this wouldn't really
this would not change what we're
eversource is doing today so there there
would be no no change so no difference
and costs and um the RPS legislation
from last year
uh was not actually a a bill calculation
it was a um a change to the bill uh
message uh so that's a predefined field
and I I think there was sensitivity
around not wanting to add costs which is
why uh it was included in that
predefined field so there there wasn't
an additional cost associated with that
either had there because this goes way
back to to the original RPS disclosure
discussion had there been you know a
desire for a line item calcul
cost representative NL good to hear from
you thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm thinking of my
bill I have solar panels and on my bill
it shows the amount of power that I
purchase and use and then the amount of
power that I sell
what component where where does the net
metering calculation show up in that so
the the costs that are recovered through
uh the stranded cost recovery charge are
the payments that we provide to you for
energy that you are essentially selling
to us putting back onto the distribution
system so it is the compensation that we
are providing you as a customer so it's
the exported credit that you're
receiving um and that's based on the Pu
tariff rate okay
followup followup go ahead so I'm I'm
effectively seeing my net metering
charges on my monthly bill at that point
you are seeing how much you are
compensated for that that output correct
you well I'll call on representative PL
next and then I'll give the last
question to representative uh M
leader
thank you thank you again Mr Lata um if
you could humor me I have I can see the
net metering charge I'm working off
representative um Corman and in light of
my good friend from Stafford
representative Harrington isn't here
this is where I'm going with
that so I have my bill my that payon
head a net metering
charge the megawatt that I put out from
my array on Peak
demand would have a price to it a
cost that same amount of megawatts put
out just into the system without a load
would it be the same would I see the
same cost or would the algorithm show me
the difference because of lower
transmission thank you so when you're
using the term um charge I I think you
mean credit correct so what we're
compensating you for that uh exported
energy correct correct okay uh so so
that is a um uh a rate that is set by
the Public Utilities Commission and it
is a a flat rate um so whenever you are
exporting whether it's you know 12
o'clock in the afternoon or 5 o'clock in
the afternoon uh it's the same uh it is
the same level of compensation because
it it is also based upon the Energy
Service rate which uh does not change
throughout the
day representative McGee you have the
last question thank you Mr Vice chairman
and thank you Mr Lata for taking my
question so in listening to um
representative Noel's uh
example if you pay the customer
generator or the group host and then you
sell the excess energy that's on the
distrib ution system to a neighbor and
then you recover the full cost that you
paid to the original person isn't there
a benefit an additional benefit beyond
the cost of of the
energy to to that it cruise to to the
utility is what I'm saying oh no so I'm
just trying to follow there because
there there's a couple steps so um
exported
energy um that we are compensating
customers for gets put onto the
distribution system the electrons flow
where they they're going to flow and so
those are energy purchases that we don't
make on behalf of customers from the
default service supplier yeah um and
so keep in mind that default Services is
load following so we don't sort of pre-
it up front it it follows customer load
so so we are essentially um the net
metering customers when they are putting
energy onto the distribution system they
are being compensated for that that
energy at the default service price and
it is essentially being used to supply
other customers there is a a subset
category of
larger um it's a mix of hydroelectric
and and solar generators where we
compensate them at the net metering
price they're made whole at that price
uh but we actually take um
responsibility for their exports and
resell that into the market it's sold at
the wholesale price and that provides a
credit credit back it's a a smaller
group uh and so any revenues that that
the utility receives any um uh uh
purchases that we we don't have to make
that all flows back to
customers is it just
yeah is it
um does it get counted as load reduction
in terms of like energy you don't have
to acquire yeah so so in terms of um the
the Energy Service component it is
purchases we we don't have to make it's
served by by um that energy that we're
buying from the uh from the net meter
customer but but that term load
reduction gets you know sort of broadly
applied so there are other components of
the bill as well um that you know folks
uh uh discuss applying that
to okay fur those questions uh thank you
Mr Lata I would like to introduce next
Mr Nick Paul from clean energy who I'm
sure he will tell us why he uh does not
want all utilities to uh put net
Annie has written testimony as well that
was very appreci of you
um I I will note that I was very brief
on that last bill and I've rece uh
received zero cupcakes so I make no
guarantees uh going
forward uh HB 1398 as written uh would
add costs related to the purchase of
electricity from customer generators as
permitted by RSA
3629 to the definition of stranded costs
ided accounting that has long
characterized the arguments of those who
oppose allowing net metering to continue
uh specifically uh detailing only the
costs of this policy while accounting
for none of the
benefits notably this proposal comes at
a time when the concern that there may
exist a cost shift you're all familiar
with that term uh between net muing
participating customers and their
non-participating neighbors has now been
put to rest by information and Analysis
that has been presented at the regional
and state level uh data that is now
available as a result of actual system
performance and impact have shown a
demonstrable financial benefit to the
electric grid from distributed Renewable
Energy Systems as an example of the
actual Financial benefits of behind the
meter solar was attested to at a Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission meeting on
June 20th 2023 when ISO New England uh
the New England Regional grid operator
released a new analysis that found that
Mystic station one of the regions
largest natural gas fired power plants
fueled exclusively by imported LG is no
longer needed for reliability the iso
New England analysis credited stronger
than expected growth and distributed
solar power as one of the key reasons
allowing for this retirement uh to be
more
precise ISO New England cited the
acceleration of behind the meter
resources on slides three and eight of
its explanation for why uh they are now
comfortable with allowing Mystic to shut
down the iso New England Chief Operating
Officer was quoted as saying that ISO
New England was surprised to see this
amount of substantial winter capacity
produced by behind the meter
resources these resources while
intermittent act as fuel
Savers when behind the meter solar is uh
produced during cold winter days the
Region's dispatchable resources are able
to conserve limited onsite fuel or gas
under contract this means the region can
endure longer cold snaps during during
times of greatest winter system
constraint the economic impact of
behindthe meter solar and Energy
Efficiency resources is significant uh
as Mystic station has been operating on
the basis of a cost of service agreement
since June of 2022 and that agreement
had cost New England rate payers nearly
$400 million as of February
2023 here in New Hampshire a more
precise value of solar and other
distributed energy resources are
emerging a broad range of State holders
have been engaged in
evaluation uh of the value of
distributed energy resources for nearly
8 years beginning with puc docket number
de6
d576 at the end of that proceeding in
2017 the Pu approved an interim net
metering tariff be put in place for new
distributed energy resource systems
interconnected after September 1st 2017
for a period of years uh while further
data is collected and analyzed pilot
programs are implemented and distributed
uh energy resource valid valuation study
is
conducted that study was initially
published in October
2022 and an amended version was issued
in 2023 to account for significant
energy Market changes resulting from the
Russian invasion of Ukraine the Topline
finding in both of these versions was
that net metering systems in New
Hampshire could result in a modest cost
shift to
nonparticipants in the newest pu
proceeding to take up the question of
net metering compensation that stocket
uh number de
22-06 both the joint utilities and the
New Hampshire Department of energy
introduced testimony that supported
extending the existing tariff uh as this
level of cost shift was consistent with
the cost shift experienced in other
parts of rate
setting however uh when cnh's
Consultants conducted a deep analysis of
the model used to perform the de value
valuation study uh they found that while
the model was robust there were a number
of incorrect assumptions being utilized
when those assumptions were updated Not
only was the cost shift entirely erased
across all customer classes but the
analysis also demonstrated the net
energy metering uh provides an economic
benefit not only to those who install uh
distributed energy re resources onsite
but to customers who don't as well more
specifically uh the revised analysis
found that the average non-et metering
residential customers would experience a
uh 4% reduction in their bills between
2021 and 2020 2035 excuse me the average
nonn net metering small and large
commercial uh customer in New Hampshire
would see their bills fall by 6% and
0.9% respectively cumul
cumulatively I always struggle with that
word our analysis finds uh that net
metering results in an average of a net
$8 million benefit from non uh de
customers each year importantly cen's
updated analysis has not been challenged
in the follow-up steps of the proceeding
finally uh we are also concerned that
this bill is being brought forth during
the active pu docket that I mentioned
before number de
22-0060 this docket has already been
underway for more than a year has
benefited from considerable work over
the past eight years and includes the
full range of stakeholders who are
considering the full range of costs and
benefits Associated uh with net metering
systems inclusive of energy supply
distribution and transmission
compensation to the extent that uh net
costs exist the Pu and stakeholders will
be proposing how they are reflected in
the final net metering tariffs that
docket is anticipated to conclude
contemporaneously with the 2024
legislative session
as electricity consumption is projected
to increase in the coming decades it is
appropriate to continue to incentivize
these systems as they are the fastest
means to expand electric generation over
the coming decade as New Hampshire and
New England at large await the arrival
uh of newer of new larger sources of
electric power and the transmission
needed to bring uh their supply to
Market uh with data in hand showing that
the net metering uh that net metering is
resulting in a net cost savings to all
customers regardless of participation in
the state's net meter and program and
with the state currently gripped by an
energy affordability crisis uh we find
this bill to be unnecessary and we urge
uh the committee to recommend this bill
as inexpedient to legislate thank you
for bearing with me uh included in your
testimony is this uh Nifty chart uh
which in part demonstrates the findings
uh of that study that I cited it is Al
also cited directly in my written
testimony would encourage everyone to
take a look at it and um would be happy
to follow up with anybody uh later about
questions that they have about
it thank you before I get to the first
question and I realize we haven't said
that uh we haven't said this this year
but I know we've said before in the past
and uh and and you're relatively new
coming to this committee relatively
compared to before you would like me to
not read my testimony I would like for
people to if you have written testimony
pass it around first first and then
please summarize what's in the written
testimony at least the sing points uh I
think well most of us older people can
read so we could we can uh probably read
that but thank you anyway U uh and no no
reflection I'm just reminding everybody
uh that comes uh uh I know one person
can speak from without even notes I
know I I certainly can't but I'll try to
be uh charismatic enough to keep
everyone's attention that no problem can
he can he have a cupcake of course he
can he can have two I don't actually
want a cupcake I just I just I have a
rule that opening with a joke is always
always a better policy than not we I
don't think anybody wants to bite in a
morie that's the only thing it's really
okay represent Reynolds you have a
question thank you Mr Vice chairman um
thank you for your testimony um during
it you referred to um two slides that
ISO New England showed during a firk
recent firk proceeding are those
slides also uh included in your written
testimony or could they be they are
cited in a footnote here and I believe
that there is a
link yep that yep it will be footnote
number two on page two okay so we could
click on that footnote and get those
slides is that the idea uh if you would
like a digital copy I will make sure
that you can copy and paste but you can
also type it in thank you whichever you
like if you have a digital copy if you
could just email it to our uh I'm I'm
gonna pass around physical copies now
but uh if people would if you do send
out a digital copy please make sure you
send it to the committee office so that
everybody gets it you beta okay next any
other questions awesome I'll see no
much next on a Mr Paul button from is it
e Au or
yours yeah my name is Paul button uh
company is energy audits unlimited
EA um it is is a I'm a small businessman
have my business out of Manchester New
Hampshire and basically I facilitate um
I facilitate owners of alternative
energy sources to recover their
renewable energy
credits
um so that's basically who I am um so
unfortunately representative Summers has
left but um she actually said said
something that I had kind of made a a
note of here
handwritten um about double
dipping maybe one of the unintended
consequences of uh of this bill uh
so first of all I'm not a lawyer and I
don't speak legal e okay I'm just a Joe
sixpack smuck I speak
American um
so my the way I see it is that the
utilities pay money for net
power and then they sell it back to
us um and so she had mentioned double
dipping um first of
all they do buy the power from
alternative
sources um but they don't they don't pay
that much for the kilowatt coming off
that source so it's actually um cheaper
for them to buy the power from
alternative source and if you go back to
the uh adage of um you know the best
energy saved is the energy that's not
used so these guys are making money by
not spending money
basically so then they sell it back to
us at um increased prices and so my
question is Jermain to this Committee
stranded for something to qualify as
stranded and thus recoverable as
stranded it must be something that quote
that may not be recoverable once the
competition which is why a cost become
stranded in the first
place so what exactly are the restrained
costs this bill is or this amendment um
is referring to I mean we talking power
plants are we talking distribution
infrastructure are we talking piles of
meters and I guess I need to ask a
question I mean did did the utility
actually ask for this bill as far as I
hear eversource is
neutral so where do this bill come
from
um in my opinion
again it's a u it seems to be an attempt
by the
utilities to write their profit margins
into state
I won't read this next part because
it's
okay
um and I had mentioned before in PR
previous testimony that um I I referred
to this whole idea of um as a legalized
ly and I stand by
that um it's legal because it's in the
law and it's lashy because with dealing
with numbers in excess of
$1,500
so
um and
um basically what's happening is is
that the the lawyers and the lobbyist
for the utilities are coming in on a
daily
basis um with motions and and appeals
and stuff basically dumping on your
desks and stopping you from doing the
people's work for which you were
elected um this is what happened when
RSA 362 was originally
enacted the utilities failed in their
attempt to exclude certain Clauses in
the law that would invoke the
ACP um alternative compliance
payment um they simply never published
any any info about Rex which is the
focus of my business but not the focus
of this meeting
um they never they never published any
info about Rec that were created by law
and that same state law said that any
unclaimed recks could be
swept by the
utilities then these found
wrecks then grandly listed on the menu
and served up to the
Pu by a weight staff of the same said
Army of corporate
flunkies no offense anybody in the
room personally as proof that they are
quote good green corporate
citizens how
convenient except that the word swept is
spelled s t o
Len on their
menu and it's listed as a dish called
greenwashing
ly all right well I was going to read I
was going to try to be clever here but I
think I've overdone my time um I'm just
going to say that
um with and again I'm talking
specifically about my my
business um with the wrecks that are no
longer
attractive um
investment in solar projects or in
general Alternative Energy uh you uh
assets are um this undermines the
structure of a possible distributed
generation model which is an aema to
their monopolistic
model unfortunately for the utilities
Grassroots organizations like CP
cnh have offered very reasonable pricing
for energy supplied and the utilities in
increase
so to leave it hanging any questions I
guess I'd be willing to
answer no see no questions thank you
very much for your testimony sir
appreciate it thank you all I'm going to
call next on The Honorable bill babber
up to here um and for those of you that
remember that Mi uh The Honorable babber
was a prior member of this
committee we've been here too long um
but a welcome back good to see you uh Mr
babber and the floor is
yours well thank you it's a pleasure to
be back here I think
um the uh I just wanted to make two
simple points and uh one is I think it's
it's timing the uh pu has been investiga
ating net metering um for net metering
30 for some time now and we'll make a
decision on this uh within your session
and it could grossly reshape um you know
anything that might be done uh in terms
of net metering and particularly
payments and this might totally be
evaporated at that point so the timing
just seems U premature um to make this
change the other point I wanted to make
is that I think trans experien is a a
really Noble goal and I know U from 10
years ago that you know many of the
questions that you're asking today we
were asking then and the problem is that
there is an absence of data you know
there's an absence of richness on bills
so you can actually understand precisely
exactly what you're being charged for or
being compensated for and most of all
there's an absence of Rich data that you
would be able to make these decisions
BAS based on where are all these
electrons going who's generating them
who's benefiting them you know where are
the costs being incurred it's all about
cost but you know trying to find that
public data that would support making a
you know understood a an intelligent
decision on where they ought to be
placed is totally absent so I think that
you know that's where I would encourage
you to spend more time if you have an
opportunity in this session that's
you let me just say thank you for coming
it was a pleasure to see you back here
you seeing no other speakers I will be
calling on Mr
Clifton bow who needs actually needs no
notes
although I do have written testimony and
with me if uh she could join me is our
new director of legisl regulatory and
legislative affairs uh Dena Dennis and
uh she'll contribute a little bit here
um I am uh here to speak on behalf of
the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire uh which has officially taken
a position to oppose this uh passage of
this bill as
introduced um but before I explain why I
I'd like Dina just to provide a quick
update on the
Coalition uh where we are today compared
to a year ago when we last appeared
committee good afternoon um Vice
chairman Thomas members of the committee
thank you so much for your time and
attention this afternoon um I wanted to
just take a minute or two to hopefully
provide some helpful context um into the
uh reasons for why uh the co the
community power Coalition of New
Hampshire um opposes this bill um so
first off uh Community power Coalition
of New Hampshire or CB cnh is a
governmental instrum instrumentality um
created to serve member Municipal
jurisdictions pursuant to a joint Powers
agreement under RSA 53-a and
53- the last time we appeared before
this committee which was before my time
it was Clif in then um we were just 26
members strong um since then our
membership has doubled we're now at 53
members including six cities 45 towns
and two
counties um we have launched 14
Community power aggregation programs um
in
2023 um that serve about 880,000
customers in 2024 we're preparing to
launch about uh 25 more in the first
half of 2024 and then um another several
toward the latter half of
2024 um and this year cbcn will become
the second largest power supplier in the
state um and our member municipalities
in total represent about 30% of the
state's
population um I really want to uh take a
moment to thank um the leadership of
chairman Bose um and members of this
committee um and the general court that
in 2021 passed House Bill 315 that
completed an important update um to RSA
53- um that enabled the launch of
community power aggregations um and
affirming the original 1996 act uh
finding um since the coalition's
establishment in October 2021 we've
sought to ensure Equitable treatment of
customers whether they are on
competitive Supply Community power
aggregation service or utility default
service in order to maximize economic
efficiency through competitive markets
and realize an affordable Equitable and
sustainable future for all Granite
Staters um and just to add a bit more in
the first five months of cbc's operation
we've saved we've saved CPA member
customers about $7 million compared to
utility default service um and we've
accured about $5 million in joint Reser
joint Financial Reserves um just last
week we announced a rate decrease to 8.1
cents um and that's for the rate period
beginning February 1st through July of
this year for our Granite Granite basic
service um and our price has beat all of
the electric utilities including the
co-op um and included with our testimony
is a handout that Clifton raised um that
overviews these rates as well as our
current membership thank you for the
committee's
time thank you um and to explain why we
oppose this as introduced um I I I will
say I appreciate the uh uh desire for
transparency but um there I think
there's some unintended consequences
here that you need to Grapple with um we
believe that this bill is
anti-competitive and would foreclose the
ability of community power aggregations
and competitive electric power suppliers
known as seps uh to serve net metered
customers it effectively would reverse
28 years of uh State policy to move away
from a monopoly uh with regard to power
supply and um eliminate customer choice
for those who net metered um I'm sure
that's not the intent of the sponsors uh
uh but but and if that's the case and
this bill moves forward uh then it
should be amended to allow costs paid to
net metered customers by com by CPA uh
Community power aggregations and seps to
also be recovered through the stranded
cost recovery charge after all our rates
are lower so the charges uh to that
would be lower however um the way it is
now we cannot effectively serve net
metered customers and that's because
um uh in effect uh what this bill does
is require the socialization of all cost
of net metering um incurred by the
utilities without accounting for uh any
of the benefits or without accounting
for most of the benefits or attempting
to pair cost and benefits it moves us
away from market-based Price signals for
net metering um the specific problem in
terms of locking in this form accounting
and cost recovery um is that it
effectively forecloses the
implementation of RSA
362a colon 9 Roman 2 that provides for
for competitive suppliers and CPAs to
determine their own terms and conditions
for net metering and goes on to say and
this is highlighted at the ba bottom of
page two um such output uh by net meter
customers um that are being served by a
by a competitive supplier or an
aggregation shall be accounted for as a
reduction to the customer generators
suppliers wholesale load obligation for
energy Supply net of any applicable line
losses adjustments as approved by the
commission now the commission hasn't
done that so this requirement has not
kicked in yet we're preparing a petition
to ask the commission uh to make such a
determination and and and to direct the
utilities to move forward with this form
of accounting now why is that important
um and I might add that this notion that
competitive suppliers should be able to
determine their own terms and conditions
for net meter customers and to be able
to serve them has been part part of the
net metering law since it was first
enacted in
1998 so you know we're 26 years out um
uh and in spite of that the utilities
have not prepared to enable that they've
not acted to enable that and uh with
regard to that new Pro that provision on
um how they should account for load
settlement um they is also echoed in the
pu's rules for Community power
aggregation um they have not prepared to
implement it um uh even more
recently um Counting exports to the grid
by net meter customers as an offset to
the power that is otherwise purchased
from ISO New England is essential to any
Market design that wants to enable
competitive suppliers CPAs or seps to
serve net metered customers um and to
account for actual benefits along with
the actual cost um if we don't account
for those benefit benefits uh that these
resources produce
um which includes a reduction for for
competitive supplier such as a CPA uh
includes a reduction to what would
otherwise have to be supplied from the
regional grid and the corresponding
energy and solary service and uh
generation capacity cost um if if we
don't get credit for those exports to
the grid then we can't afford to
compensate customers we don't have
access to the mechanism where we say we
can just charge this to all other C all
customers whether there are customers or
not um we would have to any compensation
we paid without getting any credit for
those exports um would have to be
subsidized by other customers and are
you know we can't do that and and be
fair and Equitable to all of our
customers um on the other hand uh when
utility load settlement systems are
changed to account for exports to the
grid by net metered customer customers
of of competitive suppliers uh then
enactment of this bill as introduced
would create a windfall for the utility
default service customers by requiring
our customers to subsidize the utility
default service customers creating undue
cost shifting and a competitive
disadvantage for any Supply alternative
to utility default Energy service and
you might say well H why is that I I
deta detail example and I'll just sort
of outline it here um if you took for a
given hour for instance um uh for a A
supplier or which could be a CPA or the
utility default service if their group
of customers were to consume a th000
megawatt hours during that uh hour and
they had net metered customers who
exported 100 megawatt hours to the grid
um uh this then the effect on the
regional transmission grid where there
is a meter would see that there's nine
that there's only they're only supplying
900 megawatt hours from the iso New
England bulk Market uh to the
distribution system
um however under the current uh utility
uh
processes um oops I turned in the wrong
direction um uh they don't account for
those exports to the grid
um they treat they convert you know it's
a two channel meter measures uh movement
of energy in both directions when they
see exports to the grid that channel
they take and convert all those exports
to the grid to zero and that's actually
the number they give us they say all
you're if we've had some net meter
customers who signed up we've tried to
avoid enrolling them because we have to
warn them we can't compensate them uh
but where they have shown up they show
up as zeros when they export to the grid
um and and they don't account for that
as an offset to the power we otherwise
have to provide so so for the past 25 28
years um competitive suppliers have
simply not tried to serve net metered
customers um because they have to tell
them we can't give you any credit
because we don't get any credit from the
utility um we still have to buy all the
kilowatt hours we deliver no credit for
the exports to the grid um but if if if
the statute that says you shall account
for it this way uh for us um is
implemented fir first of all the
utilities eversource at least is said
that cannot be done unless it's done for
all suppliers we can't do it for
competitive suppliers and CPAs and use
exports to the grid to offset what you
have to buy unless we also do that for
default service um and if they did it
for default service um that would be
great so in that case there's we'd only
have to buy 900 kilowatt hourss uh from
ISO New England and we could afford to
compensate the other 100 kilowatt hours
or megawatt hours that we get from net
meter customers because we're actually
selling a th the same thing for utility
default service um uh if if the utility
default service um was only had to buy
900 but they were selling a th000 uh but
the cost to compensate for that 100
megawatt hours from net metered
customers is shifted out of default
Service uh then then you've created a
situation where the cost to serve them
beyond the actual cost has gone down and
those costs are being recovered from all
rate payers so our rate payers would be
subsidizing a discount on the utility
default service rate because you're only
accounting for the purchase of 900
megawatt hours instead of a th000 um and
and that would uh tilt the overall
competitive market to favor utility
default service over any other option
and could destroy competitive
electricity Supply supp Market in New
Hampshire alternatively you know more
likely to happen is we would just CPAs
and seps would just say we cannot
compensate you even um at all uh so they
would stay on utility default service um
which would result in a destruction of
customer choice for customers who net
Meer or want to and that's a significant
number of customers we have had uh uh
there are hundreds of uh customers
Within the just the 14 communities where
we've launched that net meter who want
to be on community power supply um but
we have to tell them we can't serve them
at this point in time until we fix these
problems um uh just you know to move on
um as previously stated this seems to be
a solution in search of a problem all
this is already enabled in current
statute the puc's considering um some of
the very same issues that this provokes
in their current net metering proceeding
and and just as an example we filed
testimony in that uh proceeding to
suggest that going forward or or to
recommend that going forward new net
metered customers after September 1st of
this year should be compensated at less
than the full defa default service rate
they should be compensated in a manner
that is comparable to what is being paid
to the to the supplier of default
service so when you in that way wouldn't
be any cost that you have to shift into
stranded cost recovery because you would
just be compensating the net meter
generation for the cost that it's
actually avoiding you you're only
needing 900 megawatt hours from the from
the supplier rather than a thousand
because you're getting a 100 from net
metering
um so that that that is sort of a
concept going forward um and we propose
that
uh if you can reduce this to your actual
avoided cost um and the Delta is
primarily cost not related to the supply
of power it's related to the consumption
of power like RPS compliance costs the
cost to administer default service
working capital for default service um
if you exclude those from the
compensation uh then um uh not only have
you sort of reduce that mismatch between
uh cost and benefit in in this category
uh but you've also um uh what you could
do is take any excess such costs such
from existing net meter customers and
recover that that would be appropriate
to put in the strained cost recovery
charge because it's cost and excessive
benefits um it would also undermine the
utility obligation that currently exists
in the language around uh stranded costs
that says utilities have have had and
continue to have an obligation to take
all reasonable measures to mitigate
stranded cost you might as well repeal
that if you're going to pass this as
introduced because in effect the best
way for utilities to mitigate these
costs is to let enable us and
competitive suppliers to serve nit
metered customers then they become our
customers and they're not com
compensating them for the energy value
they're output to the grid and you've
just taken that whole cost out of out of
the equation for stranded costs um the
law also says stranded costs should be
determined on a net basis that's not
this bill does it's all cost no
transparency or counting for benefits
and they should be consistent with
promotion of a fully compe competitive
market which this kind of goes in the
opposite direction we're moving away
from competitive markets and saying
we're going to lock into law um that all
the costs for net metering are at least
for utilities is socialized all the
benefits are
socialized and in effect it's going to
be be a monopoly function of the
distribution
utility um finally I want to reiterate
that 25 28 years of New Hampshire policy
development has been to try to steer us
towards more competitive markets
economic efficiency Innovation and
customer choice and electricity Supply
that would all be undermined or
nullified by the enactment of this bill
as introduced and and there's various
quotations there towards the bottom of
page five and page six and of course you
know it's it's sort of antithetical to
our constitution our very constitution
of the state that calls for free and
compet Fair competition in the trades
and Industry as an inherent and
essential right of the people that
should be protected against all
monopolies what this bill if does is
memorialize and
institutionalize net metering as a
monopoly for the distribution utility I
I I don't think that's the direction we
should be going in so you should just be
aware that you're kind of undo doing a
policy Direction now I'll admit we
haven't really realized the the the the
appropriate me you know fully
appropriate uh uh way to compensate nit
metering or to enable you know others to
serve uh but we're trying to move in
that direction particularly in the
current net metering proceeding so I
just you know ask that you let that play
out um we we we've put an inor inornate
amount of effort to try to resolve this
issue because um uh
anybody it is the single biggest issue
that our local communities are getting
feedback in in the public hearings on
net me on on U launching Community power
aggregation which is are you going to be
able to serve net metered customers and
and the answers we intended to the law
actually says we have to explain how
we're going to serve net metered
customers in our aggregation plans that
have to be perceived by approved by the
Pu but they all assume number one the
utilities are going to give us the data
um and number two that they're going to
account for these exports to the grid as
an offset to the power we otherwise have
to procure so the final thing I want to
say is that this notion that it's the
that we're not accounting for the
benefits is literally true in the net
metering proceeding I thought a fairly
simple Discovery question that I that we
needed to know for our testimony and to
calculate benefits is how many kilowatt
hours are exported to the grid by net
metered customers and none of the
utilities could tell us they could tell
us we can tell you how much we paid them
but we can't tell you how many kilowatt
hours they exported to the
grid and and and and and and as we've
gotten to the load discussion discussion
discussion we've also discovered they
have no analytics whatsoever on how net
metering affects load shapes so if a
customer shows up and they're only
showing five kilowatt hours um and and
we know that they're showing that for
the whole month because most of it was
offset by net metering they just assume
that any offset was over all hours of
the day 247 and just pushes down their
whole load shape for the entire uh uh
month um based on class average load
shape um which is obviously not true um
so so you know that's part of the
problem and and I think a number of
parties in this we're really surprised
that they've made no attempt uh to
analyze uh the impact of net metering
and so you might say well um does this
you know how is this benefit that is
real um occur and it's because um I I
think Mike Lata explained a bit of it um
it actually does reduce except for the
approximately 100 systems that sell that
they resell the power into the iso
England market for all the other
thousands literally thousands I forget
the total number but it's thousands of
netmed customers in New Hampshire um
they all function as load reducers so
they reduce the amount of power we're
buying from ISO New England and they
reduce um if they produce at monthly
coincident Peaks they reduce um our
transmission charges and and they do
that PV does it for at least five months
of the year there's the coincident Peaks
are uh daylight hours and and as
referenced ISO New England has studed
this um because they got access to tens
of thousands of um net meter data
including on a state specific data basis
which we suggested maybe we could use
that to try to understand how this
impacts uh load shapes but instead that
doesn't occur and and the they treat it
as literally unaccounted for energy
along with some other stuff um uh that's
not accounted for uh because it's
difficult to do and and and it gets
buried in some something called the
residual that is not a published number
it's unknown to anybody basically
because it's figured for every hour um
of the year there's a residual which is
the fudge factor to try to make retail
loads match up with what is actually
measured coming off the transmission
grid um and we did ask a question in
Discovery and we learned something they
publish line losses and they say oh
they're around 7% % so if you figure if
you're a supplier and you have retail
load figure that's going to have to be
grossed up by 7% because if you if your
customer consumes 100 kilowatt hours uh
you need to actually buy about 107 from
the iso New England Market uh uh because
of line losses along the way and um we
said well what what is the actual eff of
um uh uh settlement and eversource and
uh Unitil came back and said well
actually for last year it was only about
4.4% um and that's that's the first time
I think that number's ever been public
um and so what that Delta some chunk of
it is uh and that's 247 some chunk of
that Delta between 4.4 and what's
probably the real line losses is this
unaccounted for energy but they can't
break it out so that's that's the issue
uh so we would uh hope that you would uh
perhaps uh uh hold on to this bill for
interm study or considering amending it
uh so it allows us uh to also socialize
our cost if we're going to stick with
socializing all the benefits or limit um
this requirement to only those costs
that are in excess of uh uh benefits
thank you thank you Mr Bao I I do have a
question but before I ask the question
um uh my only comment is had you been
reading your testimony I'm not sure we
would have been able to see you
uh not sure how high that stack might
have been on the well is it's all right
here on my testimony the net metering
proceeding that might be true that that
was about 40 pages long um so I'll take
the liberty of asking a question so how
um you mentioned that transparency is um
You didn't say quote wonderful thing but
it is a wonderful thing um how would you
approach net metering to become more
transparent um in in a
nutshell um I I guess from a legislative
point of view you you you could ask for
because they do a lot of things on an
annual basis the these reconciliations
strand cost recovery reconciliation all
that is is done on an annual basis is
you could ask in conjunction with that
that the utilities report and publish on
their website um what the costs incurred
were uh but also they should try to
estimate what the benefits are you know
they they should add up those kilowatt
hours that are exported to the grid and
figure out how much uh that translates
into to in terms of power that's not
being purchased from ISO New England
that's buried in this residual number um
they should using the best available
data which I I would suggest ISO New
England has a pretty robust effort to
try to quantify uh the what the effect
of behind the meter generation is um
having obtained access to thousands of
um data points from net metered systems
and they and they actually calculate on
a state specific basis the utilities
could use or Department of energy use
that data to estimate based on uh the
production in New Hampshire or the
specific New Hampshire uh analysis that
ISO New England does how much of that
power is reducing our coincident Peak
demand and consequently transmission
cost um and how much of it is being used
uh how much occurs at the annual
coincident Peak which you know
historically is always been a summertime
daylight hour you know it's late in the
afternoon on hot days typically hot
weekday
um and ISO New England has estimated
that four states specifically that could
be published so that you actually have a
published report on what are the costs
and what are the benefits that that can
be Quantified thank you I will I will
approve my own follow-up question um do
you do you believe that they could do
that at at no cost to them
um
um C could they do that within existing
resources or are they going to have to
hire somebody to do it is obviously
going to take somebody some time to do
that ju Just like it would to comply
with with this um law although as stated
ever Source already does it this way and
and I should mention just Unitil I don't
I can't remember if the external
delivery charges separately listed but
it's a subset of their delivery charge
which is on the bill it shows up on
bills it's just it's just a little
buried just like this as a component of
strained cost I don't think the
incremental cost would be personally I I
I can't see why it would be a big cost
um unless you don't start with ISO New
England data is better than no data as a
good starting point I mean I will say
that one representative eversource
recently said to us that they think that
uh if if they were that that they should
take that if they were going to try to
actually understand the impact of
metering on load shapes they they should
go to the commission and get uh approval
from the commission to do a load uh uh
uh study meaning putting in some um
meters like they do to come up with load
profiles now and try to uh spend two
years to collect data to understand this
um it's a little odd because under
normal operations they've always had an
obligation to try to understand uh load
shapes of their customer base uh because
they because the vast majority of
eversource customers do not have
interval metering so they only read the
meter once a month so they you they used
a certain number of uh research meters
where they put in interview Vol meters
you know maybe for a 100 customers or or
some number of customers as a small
sample and they use those load research
meters as a um proxy for what
everybody's load shape in the entire
residential customer class or the small
business customer class um only the very
largest customers do they have interval
meters were actually individual
customers have their own individual load
shapes that are
knowable uh so so I guess the question
is it might not cost too much but then
again I I can't I can't speak for the
utilities or
doe thank you uh representative rolds
question thank you Mr Vice chairman and
thank you uh Clifton for your
thorough and um informative testimony
but I'm a little confused isn't the kind
of
data that was the basis for the much you
know long awaited and much Herald and
and much talked about deer study and the
the data that was the basis for the
iso's presentation to to FK that the
previous uh witness from clean energy
New Hampshire talked about isn't
that data the basis the basis for those
uh those de study in the presentation to
FK doesn't that exist already and it
does about benefits of and I my
understanding and you know read it
pretty carefully um the the dunsky
report does use a bunch of that data
that ISO New England has collected that
is specific to New Hampshire and the way
they they've had a you know a a de sort
of work group for over a decade now and
they've developed this methodology and
my understanding is the one ways they
did it they contacted several one or
more of the big inverter manufacturers
who have a lot of uh inverters because
because PV produces at direct current
and converts to alternating current and
most of those systems report you know I
can pull out my phone and I can look at
uh the inverter data that shows what my
system is producing in any given hour
for that matter and and and I actually
have a uh Revenue grade metering that
also I can match it against and and see
that yeah that's that's that's a real
number so what ISO New England did is
they talked to these manufacturers they
probably paid them some money and they
said can you give us aggre data on your
thousands of inverters so we can see
actually what they produce and we can
correlate that with WEA conditions and
everything else and they've developed a
fairly rust bottle that they're
constantly correcting on a month I I
don't know if it's monthly but um it
it's at least monthly if not more
frequently they take that realtime data
that's coming in from uh uh I forget the
number I cited it in our testimony th
tens is well over 10,000 thousands of of
data points for PV systems in New
England they take that and match it
against what actually happened on the
system and so when you go to the iso New
England app right this minute you can
actually see um a curve when you look at
the uh uh demand chart um there's a
little orange line at the top of it
which says what the demand would be in
New England absent uh behind the meter
solar and and they break that down by
state so that's part of what dunky used
some of that data does come from the
utilities the utilities have provided
them data about how many systems they've
estimated what the size of those systems
are and then ISO New England has
correlated this with all this data that
they're collecting which is aggregated
data they don't get individual system
data but they get it aggregated by State
and and they're using it to develop a
pretty good model that they they have a
high confidence as as uh being uh uh
reasonably accurate I think you've
answered that question thoroughly sorry
do you have a pertinent followup
okay um you right at the end there you
said pretty high they've developed this
model that has they have pretty high
confidence this is ISO New England yes
so confident that they were willing to
go to FK and say it's okay if Mystic
Generating Station right there in Boston
Harbor fueled by natural gas if it's
okay if we let that system shut down if
we let that plant shut down the region
will still have adequate resources
because of the presence of so much
distributed generation and net meter
let's let's answer that question as it
pertains to this
bill please um well just just quickly
that that that plant was what was called
re reliability must run uh
representative Harrington could tell you
a lot of there's a lot of history there
it's above Market it's it's costing
people to keep that plant running and
what ISO New England you know with they
had the confidence in that data set so
that's the that's the of the question um
that they could go in and say with a
straight face that there's enough
distributed generation in New England
that is producing even in the wintertime
uh that it helps with the problem and
and and just so you know the problem is
that we have limited pipeline capacity
so on very cold days um uh gas powered
plants which rely on just not paying for
transportation because they buy it at a
discount because it Surplus plus 98% of
the time they come up short and
sometimes aren't running but but the but
what what I understand I so New England
found is there's enough output from
distributed generation even in in the on
cold winter days uh that it conserves
enough fuel uh so that they've you know
most of these power plants now have
petroleum that they can airiz to to when
when they don't have gas or they have
propane that they can inject or whatever
but the point was that we now have
enough capacity that we can get through
extreme cold snaps without that power
plant because of the amount of output
from distributed generation even though
it's not precisely at the same time it
helps those power plants uh extend the
power supply that the fuel supply that
they have on hand to meet uh extreme
weather conditions thank you
representative
McGee thank you Mr Vice chair um so I'd
like to bring it back to we're going to
be executing this bill tomorrow and um I
always appreciate the authority that you
bring to the chair and answering our
questions around what's going on with
with energy in New England um but the
thing that struck me about your
testimony is you know I was here for HB
315 I I um understand that part of the
impetus for the House and Senate
supporting that bill and it getting
signed into law was the Fulfillment of
competition
in service of lowering people's bills
right so that the the competitive piece
and what I'm hearing from your testimony
is that it appears that that competition
will be edged out in some way because
you can't compete if we provide
advantages to the utilities that are not
afforded to those other people who are
currently that we put in place to
provide competition is that an accurate
assessment yes is it so um that's secur
it okay so so we would be undermining
our own efforts there right and and
furthermore I I I've just got to say
this I'm sorry I haven't grafted it yet
but in Discovery what we could see is
there's a pretty steep ramp in the last
few years of customers n of growth in
net metering both absolute numbers of
customers and in the capacity and um we
uh our
communities um and our local energy
committees are aware of a multitude of
sites that would be suitable for uh net
metering you know up up to a megawatt or
up to five megawatts um that we would
like to be direct off-takers for we
would like to say we're getting part of
our power from a local renewable energy
resource they're not on utility default
service so it's no cost to the utility
of default service customers there are
customer generators and we would like to
be able to use that output to offset
what we otherwise have to buy um uh and
it and that's actually what happens from
a physics point of view um but um that
that is what would get precluded because
modifying the load settlement uh uh for
us and for um the utility uh default
service um when we recover our cost from
our customers but they recover their
cost whether they're uh in excess of the
benefits or not uh from all customers so
it's an unal playing field that we can't
compete against so we would unless you
said okay uh if we compensate net
metered uh at the same or a lower rate
than the utilities do we can we can put
we can put that in the stranded cost
recovery charge then we can say well at
least we can compensate you even though
we don't get the benefit for it
everybody will get the benefit for it
because it'll but we won't be able to
tell you what it is because it's it's
buried in this residual I mean that's I
guess that's if we don't change the
system if we do change the system uh
then then then then I think we should
still be able to serve net meter
customers I think your answer was yes
yes thank you thank you I'm sorry it's
late and I'm rambling mon I'll take the
last question from representative Ms
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
for uh taking my question I want to I
want to try to summarize what I think
I've heard here and hopefully you can
tell me whether I'm on the right path or
not um you know what we heard testimony
earlier and I think you were here for
that that basically said that this bill
as it's written doesn't change anything
from the way things are being done right
now right that all it does is is codify
that in law and what I'm hearing from
you I I think is that there's a lot of
stuff that we do right now that really
is not in the best interests of of
aggregate power but you know from a
public policy point of view the state as
a whole and my guess is that your
concern is that if this bill passes it
makes it just that much harder to
address those concerns yes um and then
as a as a followup the followup ahead
what you're really I think looking for
is a bill to address some of the
underlying
problems that goes Way Beyond what this
bill is intended to do well and then no
I'm not asking you to try to amend this
bill to do something different um I'm
just saying if you're going to do it
you'd either need to uh limit the
mandate to those costs that are in
excessive benefits so that they can be
matched and paired up or and or if
you're concerned about transparency
there may be another way to get the
transparency that is even more
transparent and also lets people know
that they're actually are benefits that
could be Quantified but it's changing
the Status Quo that's okay and just just
I just want to say is um it it's because
th this treating these exports as zero
for load settlement purposes is
why this competition is not happened so
far you know when a year ago we were
fully expecting that we would be able to
serve net beer customers we had a plan
for how we would compensate them and all
that stuff until we found out that we
weren't going to get any data except for
zeros and that there was question plan
to be able to uh address that law that
says you shall uh settle the load as an
offset and and just my final comment is
that is one of the questions that's in
the net metering statute that the
commission is directed to answer which
is sure should we change load settlement
for default Service as well to count
those exports to the grid as an offset
to what the supplier has to otherwise
purchase from ISO New England this bill
would preempt the commission from
answering that question that the
legislature told them to answer thank
you I believe we've uh covered the
subject no further questions thank you
Mr Bao uh for your very thorough
presentation I thought we were sitting
in the Pu right now
but uh thank you very much I have no
further uh speakers so I will declare
hearing uh well we haven't done the
others yet I would like to get it all at
the same time I'm going to leave that up
to the chair as the one he wants it
presented on that one here uh with that
the public hearing on 1398 is
closed
Vose
all the business we have to conduct
today we will resume activity tomorrow
morning at
9:00 with two more public hearings
followed by a work session and then an
executive session thanks to everyone for
attending today and we'll see you
tomorrow oh and by the way there are
mic
that